The State Board will convene and begin with a salute to the flag.
Our first item today will be the report of the superintendent.
And then I understand that board member Gray will also make some comments.
Thank you, President Kirsten, board members.
Good morning.
This is a special day, a National Student Action Day, to express our grief for the victims of gun violence and to show solidarity as we work together with our students for change.
Later this morning, students all across California, all across America, will remember the high school shooting victims in Florida.
He will also remember victims of gun violence in San Bernardino and Rancho Tama.
We have all been deeply affected by these tragedies, and our hearts and prayers are with the victims and their families.
I look forward to continuing to support all students who want to talk about and act about improving and expanding school safety, who want to take action against gun violence.
Thank you to the students who are conducting on-campus discussions today across California and across America.
I have issued a superintendent's letter expressing solidarity with the Florida victims from Stoneman Douglas High School.
And for educators, this will be an opportunity to understand the range of students' feelings and their goals and ideas for reducing senseless gun violence.
For students, they will also learn civic participation and how to engage in dialogue about critical and often emotional issues.
Last week, I was in Washington, D.C.
for meetings on our California State Plan, our ESSA plan, and I asked our federal officials in Washington, D.C.
and all members of Congress to listen to the strong and powerful messages from our students.
They want safe campuses as a top, top priority.
In a few minutes, we will hear from our outstanding student board member, Jayden Gray, from James Logan High School.
And Jayden, you remind me of so many of my students over the years who wanted to make a difference, who got involved, who took the time to support important social causes, and I thank you for that.
And this is the time your voices will be heard.
Thank you to California teachers, administrators, and staff for providing opportunities for all students to remember those who died and for providing ways for all students to express their views on the tragic event.
I believe this will be an extension of the California safe havens discussions we have had here and around California, which have involved making our schools safe for all students and parents.
Along with the Safe Havens outreach, two years ago, I convened a statewide school safety committee to implement ways we can better partner with our law enforcement agencies and our social service and health agencies to make sure that our schools are taking all the necessary steps to ensure the safety of students and that we are sharing our best practices while doing so.
We must ensure that we are addressing the health and wellness needs of all of our students, reaching and teaching the whole child.
I believe it is imperative that we provide more mental health services for students and I look forward to working with the legislature on funding greater mental health services right here in California and counseling services with that.
It won't be easy, it won't happen overnight, but I know we can do it.
We can do it together.
And I'm proud of the more than 61 California Teachers of the Year, the best of our best teachers, who signed an open letter with me to President Trump.
I have spoken to these dedicated teachers and know of their determination to work with our students to truly make a difference.
The letter says loud and clear, we do not need more guns in our school campuses.
We need more mental health services, smaller class sizes, more counselors, more school nurses.
and more training for all faculty and personnel on how to detect students in crisis or students who may be depressed or may be suicidal or who might think the answer to their problems is violence against other students.
I know the commitment we see today, this dedication of making positive change will keep moving forward.
Please join rallies that will be happening all across California and all across America on March 24th.
And you can access on a website where the rally would be, the march in your particular part of California.
I will be joining the March for Our Lives rally in Walnut Creek and I look forward to spreading the same message to everyone.
Again, just check the website for those locations.
We will keep on supporting our students who want to spread the word about these important messages and I do believe together we will make a difference.
We can and we will make a difference.
And I now want to turn to Jayden to have a
Leader and the student voice of California to share his views Jaden um I'd first like to begin by really just sending my deepest condolences to all the students in Marjory Stoneman Douglas High School and And really everyone affected by the tragedy.
I think for students in particular this
tragedy hit so close to home because of the prevalence of social media.
I remember scrolling down my Twitter feed and just my Instagram and social media and seeing live tweets from the students at the high school.
And it made it so much more firsthand.
It felt as if you could experience their emotions.
I remember students tweeting from the high school as the shooting was happening, how they were fearing for their lives, how their friends had been shot, videos of
of students lying dead in classroom floors.
And I think that hit very close to home for me and for students all across the nation.
And I think if there's a silver lining in any of this
It is the action and the response of students all across the nation.
I think it really shows the ability that students have to catalyze change and the power that students have even at such a young age.
Today, all across the nation, from Florida to California, there will be 17 minute walkouts in honor of the 17 lives that were lost.
And we, as students, are standing in solidarity and we, as students, are fighting to show that we can never allow something like what happened in Parkland, Florida, to happen again.
So, just,
If I could say one thing, it's just for everyone who's out there today, be safe, kick butt, stand strong, and today we are all MSD strong.
So, thank you.
Thank you very much for that.
Board members, we have a long meeting today.
Our staff projects it at 11 hours, so you'll need your stamina to do that.
And before we begin with item one, I have some unusual announcements.
We have two new people joining our staff, and so I'm pleased to announce that
Lila Fahimadeen joined the State Board beginning on February 20th.
Lila has excellent experience for us, having worked prior for the National Center for Youth Law, SRI International, and ACLU.
And she'll be working on projects and policy on special education and English learner issues as one of her areas of portfolio.
So Lila, will you stand up there and welcome Lila.
Secondly, I'm delighted to announce that longtime person who's been interacting with the board, Terry Burns.
We'll be joining the state board staff in March.
Terry is currently the senior director and legislative advocate for the California School Boards Association.
And she's been a board member, a school board member at Natomas Unified School District for the last 33 years.
She has had an illustrious career in Sacramento.
including a consultant in the State Senate, and she was the Chief Deputy of the State Education Department under Superintendent Jack O'Connell.
I'm not sure Terry's here.
She is here.
There she is.
Yes, thank you.
Our big change for the day on our agenda is that the ESSA state plan item posted yesterday includes key areas of the ESSA plan, including weighting of indicators and school identification.
During the timing of
the completion of our negotiations with the U.S.
Department of Education.
We have not had time for a public reaction to this agreement, and so we modified our recommendation on item 4.
We are requesting, and the CDE requests, and I think the Board should go along, that we defer action on Title I accountability items in the revised state plan so that it can be considered at a subsequent State Board of Education meeting to be scheduled in order for stakeholder feedback and some issues around the impact analysis.
of the changes.
So we will announce the date as soon as it is finalized.
We expect it to be roughly within a month of this meeting.
So we will have an additional meeting in this calendar year of the State Board of Education.
There are six public hearings on our agenda.
Items 5, 6, 20, 21, 22, 23.
The waiver and consent calendars.
are there including consent items 11 through 19 and waiver items W2 and W4 through W15.
We have items 11 through 19 are our regular consent items.
And I want to remind board members, if you wish to remove an item from our consent calendar, please do so by Wednesday morning today at 12.30.
My usual announcements, we have a fully accessible
Electronic agenda, the public comment for items not on our agenda will be limited to one minute per speaker at the end of tomorrow's meeting.
If you're going to give something to the state board to read while you're speaking, please provide 25 copies to Amy Bubico at the desk in the front.
Please, if you're speaking to us, introduce yourself and the organization that you represent.
We have additional seating and TV monitors in adjacent rooms 1130 1103 and 1801 around the corner And we will have some board member recusals later.
So the board members will remember that so that is I think the preliminaries and so we're now ready for a multi item and
Item 1, which is around accountability and continuous improvement at this local, state, and federal level.
This is a multifaceted item of related but separate issues.
So I think it's best if members ask questions after each of the substantive items so we don't mush them all together and make them unclear for the audience.
So we're now ready with item one and Cindy Kazanis for the department will be the lead presenter and we have some illustrious guests.
Good morning, Superintendent, oh, good morning, President Kirst and Superintendent Torlakson and members of the board.
It's my pleasure to present item one today.
There's, as President Kirst indicated, there's quite a few pieces to this and we'll have quite a few presenters as well.
I'm Cindy Kazanis, the Director of the Analysis, Measurement and Accountability Reporting Division.
And to get started, just quickly, sorry, it feels like I have an echo.
Okay, so maybe we'll just take a quick pause.
Or perhaps I should keep talking.
Does it seem like it's gone to you?
Someone?
OK.
All right.
So we have five attachments in this item.
And we'll take up, obviously, each of them, for the most part, individually.
The last two will be combined together.
There are two, or rather three, recommendations, but two really for action in this item.
We're recommending that the State Board of Education approve first the proposed revision to the self-reflection tool for priority six, which is the school climate local indicator, and then number two, the proposed standard and self-assessment tool for local educational agencies to determine progress on the local performance indicator for priority seven, which is access to broad course of study.
The CDE is asking and recommending that the State Board of Education provide guidance on recommended changes or rather recommended changes to the state indicator and take additional action as deemed necessary and appropriate.
And I'm going to talk through what we mean by that last piece after our guest speakers today because I think there's been some confusion about whether or not it's a recommendation or not per se.
So just as a very high-level reminder, you have been at this for a number of meetings, maybe up to two dozen by now, working on our accountability and our continuous improvement system.
And it's been over a year, really, that you've approved the evaluation rubrics, and this month marks the official release of the beta test of our dashboard, which was released last year in March.
In September, you approved changes, but one thing I wanted to mention for March, this has been our annual time in which we set aside for you to look at our work plan and look at the work that will go into the release for fall, which is going to be our annual release of the dashboard.
Back in November, you also made changes to the academic indicator and you approved the inclusion of chronic absentees and data only on the dashboard released for last December, which was released on December 7th.
So to start us off, it seemed to go really well last time, so I'm sure it'll be just as great.
We're going to hear from a local educational agency.
So to get us started, I would like to invite up our two guest speakers who have traveled with us from the Bay Area, from Castro Valley Unified School District.
Joe Loss is their president of the board of Castro Valley.
Please come on up.
And their superintendent, Parvin Parvin.
Thank you.
Good morning.
I also would like to start by sharing my deep condolence to the victims of the Florida shooting and also commend our young people who have really
reminded me lately over and over again of the hope that I have for our future because of their advocacy.
I'm Parveen Amadi, the superintendent for Castavel Unified School District and this is our wonderful board president Joe Loss.
Good morning.
25 years of experience on the board so I'm very fortunate to have to work for Joe Loss and the rest of the board members so
Today we hope to share with you just a few things about what we have really focused on with the California dashboard and hope that if you have any questions you can feel free to ask us.
The topic is utilizing California's new accountability dashboard to improve our practice.
So the first step is that the board needs to value and honor their responsibility that comes with the dashboard because there's accountability for the board and it requires the board to accept the responsibility for their actions.
Boards have to respect the diversity of the dashboard
data and account for their actions by using the dashboard.
Boards should use the dashboard to determine the district's direction, setting goals, and establishing expectations.
These are for the board, the staff, the district, and the students.
The dashboard should be a guide for allocating resources and the backbone of all policy development.
Board members should be vocal and visible ambassadors throughout their communities to explain and educate that the dashboard is much more than a single numerical score.
Board members need to do more than review their district's dashboard to make use of this valuable tool.
My recommendation is that they spend some time learning about the ideas behind the dashboard to help keep their focus on what the tool can do for them.
Then avoid the temptation to look at the details and start with an overview that highlights what is working well and where improvement is needed.
I suggest that each board member take 10 minutes to examine their personal perspective and maybe their bias.
Make a list of the indicators and have each member write down a prediction of the color that they'll see.
Then look at their district's dashboard and list the actual color received.
Are there surprises?
It's really important that everyone knows whether their personal impressions are accurate or not
before they start asking questions and certainly before making board decisions.
Then I recommend that each team take a few minutes to chart the performance gaps for each indicator with only personal thoughts and anecdotal knowledge.
Now the team is prepared with the information that
helps define their personal beliefs and are ready to work with the staff for data to inform and guide their decisions.
And of course, boards must demonstrate the steps that ensure forward motion, monitor, evaluate, and adjust as necessary.
The dashboard unites all of the governance team's efforts in shaping the educational experience of the students.
The work that the board does in understanding the dashboard results and implementing improvement is the basis for all work for the governance team.
When a nexus is reached with the alignment of the strategic plan,
district goals and budget, board members will have the answer for any and all questions and the very tough decisions that they have to make at the board table.
So we'll start the conversation about what we've done with the dashboard in our school district by kind of sharing with you, as President Law said, our strategic plan really guides our work in our school district.
And it's aligned with our LCAP, which has been our guiding force and our school plans.
But I believe that our commitment to equity by all is key for us.
I have brought brochures, and in the brochure you will notice our strategic plan, our vision, mission, statement, and core values, and a real focus on the whole concept and motto of all means all.
In fact, you will see it everywhere in our school district, in our schools, on our website, to remind us every day that that all means all should be the focus when we look at every decision.
And our belief is that every system, as I'm sure you have heard and seen this, that is perfectly designed for the results that it gets.
So through a systems thinking approach, the past few years we've tried really hard to focus our efforts on the connection between the parts of the system and using systems thinking tools to look deeper at all of our work.
Our strategic plan is basically our roadmap.
We believe in empowering and engaging families and the community, and I'll share some things about that with you, and we encourage student voice and engagement at all levels.
When we talk about using systems thinking tools to examine patterns and plans for improvement, these are some of the questions that we have in mind.
So what are the overall trends and patterns when we look at the dashboard?
It is really easy for us to just look at the green and blue for any of our districts and just kind of move on and be happy about the fact that we have green and blues.
But we really need to look at the trends and patterns.
What are some of the specific patterns that we see and change over time?
What are the mental models in existence that may have led to current results?
And that's key, using that tool to look at why we make certain decisions.
What are the structures in place?
What are the patterns that we see?
But what's the mental model under that?
What are some of the steps taken to address areas of concerns?
Our district goals and LCAP goals and priorities in our strategic plan align in all sorts of ways, including how our funding decisions are made.
Are we seeing expected outcomes based on what has been in place?
What are the outcomes?
We can have a lot of different initiatives, but if we're not looking at outcomes, we're really missing the point.
What are some of the examples of best practices?
We don't have all the answers.
And what are the different parts of the systems that we need to connect?
And then are there things that we've been doing that are not effective?
And then are there new things that we need to be doing and stop doing things that are not effective?
And that's one of the top four decisions because everybody loves their program.
That's right.
And I think that having our strategic plan and a governing board that is focused on equity is the key to making those decisions.
So the dashboard is out.
Now what?
You know, to me, the most important piece is peeling it back.
Confirm and deeply analyze other data sources.
When you think about the API versus the dashboard, I always feel that real estate agents love the API because it was one number.
I remember families would come to us and say, well, I don't want to go to that school, I want to go to this school, because they were five points away.
Well, it really didn't mean a whole lot when you looked deeply.
The dashboard actually allows us to take a deeper look at things, but people can also misuse the dashboard.
and just look at the green and the blue versus peeling it back for even the blue and the green to see what's under it.
Are there any areas?
What groups of students are not being served as well as they should be?
What else can we do?
So some of the things that we use in our school district to make sure that we deeply analyze the data
We have Illuminate, which many districts have, the data management system that includes all of our assessments, formative assessments, and all sorts of things.
SWIS has been really effective for us.
We have positive behavior intervention.
actually throughout our entire school district.
And the data system called SWIS, Schoolwide Information System, has been very effective in identifying patterns of behavior and referrals and when they're happening, where,
by whom all of those things, groups of students that we need to serve better.
The California Healthy Kids Survey for us has been really effective this year because we actually gave it at the beginning of the year instead of at the end of the year.
And because the results come back in a couple of weeks, it's been an effective tool to use as well.
Aries is our grades, attendance, and discipline, and a lot more.
And using common assessments based on essential standards that our teachers have identified.
formatively and actually collaboratively working in professional learning communities for our teachers to look at their plans, look at the results of their formative assessments, and then go back and talk about what are things that have worked for one teacher, groups of students, and how do we then use that model to have interventions during the day because the most important interventions should happen during the day.
and then examine our support systems already in place and plan steps to improve them.
I can use a lot of examples that we've had, but again, as you look at the accountability tool, I think it's really, really important to look at the indicators, at the colors, and the green, blue, yellow, orange, and red,
But also take a look at the five by five, the matrix, because that's when you look for each school to see, you know, for example, for us, one of our title one schools, Cast Valley Elementary, I was actually working with our secretaries and clerks about, you know, talking about inclusive environments and how do we
As a office staff actually are the face of the school and they're they're just amazing people that support our families and We were going over the dashboard I think that's a really important piece as well to make sure none of you are part of our system is left out our Classified members as well as our teachers, but when I showed them, you know different schools and they looked at for example, Castor Valley Elementary School and they said wow, it's green or it's blue and
I had them, as President Law said, kind of, you know, think in their, just kind of write down a couple of things that they might see when we peel it back.
And our perceptions, and biases about all of that, and that's, we've done that with our teachers and administrators.
When you peel it back, they all loved it and clapped when they saw that Castaveli Elementary School had green for every one of their groups of students.
in all areas, including discipline, which has been an area of concern for us, frankly.
And that, again, was really important to see that there are things that people have in place that are actually effective.
And if families moved in and asked which school to go to, I'm very confident to say any of our schools.
I would feel the same that our board members could say that.
You know, I think the important piece also about our work in, I'm going to go back, with the dashboard is all of the things that we've put in place.
When we talk about taking deep dives, for example, we looked at our discipline data.
And when we looked at our discipline data, we were very concerned that we
are not where we need to be.
But we didn't just stop there.
We actually used Swiss data and all of our data with suspension and looked at patterns.
When were these happening at our high school, for example?
What were the infractions?
What were student groups being disciplined for?
And what we found out were some pretty simple things that, for example, if students were not, you know, had a detention to finish something and didn't come, they were given Saturday school.
And if they didn't come to Saturday school, then they would be suspended.
That just makes no sense.
But that was something that had been in place for a long, long time.
So we said,
We know that's not effective.
We want students in school, so that's our goal, keeping students at school.
Just that simple thing changed a whole lot of stuff.
Then we looked at our Swiss data to see.
I have to say I'm pleased to see that our teachers are not sending children out of their classrooms.
They're actually supporting them within the classroom.
But what was happening are things outside of school that we actually have some control over, and then the rest of it is our work with the community and parents.
Our culturally and responsive teaching methods and practices that we've had with Cherokee Holly, we've had to bring some of those things back.
We just had every one of our teachers in our district and administrators trained with Mike Matos, who is a guru of response to intervention.
We're looking at our schedules.
We have an equity task force that includes, it's almost half students and the other half are staff and parents.
As we're looking at our adoption of materials, following the FAIR Act, we have students and community members involved in the selection process.
We have a district student leadership alliance who we have formed in the last three years and we've taken them to conferences for systems thinking.
They are our ears and eyes.
They meet with me and advise us in an advisory role.
They tell us things that we need to do better.
We have noticed the need for mental health support.
It's huge in our school districts and all over the country.
We know that.
We looked at our budget cuts for next year, and we actually had a grant for counseling for elementary school that was running out, a federal grant, and the board and the community was very interested in keeping that, so we went back to find ways to keep our elementary counselors.
We also have a wellness center that we've started.
One of the other things we've done is any student who has an infraction, before they're suspended obviously with the conversation, they make a visit to the wellness center because we have many, many organizations that are at our wellness center.
ready to support students.
So there's a whole lot to talk about.
I know that I just have a few, a couple of seconds more to say our parent projects have been key.
PK, Parent Institute for Quality Education, and School Smarts.
for students.
And during our mariachi program, we have students who are actually in learning from classically trained musicians while their parents are in training and being given information on topics of interest.
So these are just some of the things we've done, but I would sum it up by
district who's serious about closing the opportunity gap must be relentless, must have a relentless, focused, targeted effort to close that gap and include everyone in that decision-making.
All of us need to be responsible.
Thank you.
President Chris, did you want to open it up for a brief question since we're here and we'll hand out the brochures while you're okay.
All right, Board Member Strauss and Board Member Rucker.
I want to thank you both for coming and taking time out of your very busy day, particularly today with all the things are happening in local school districts.
And just thank you for your quick but comprehensive approach.
And I think you really show us and show the public that it's not a simple approach.
It's a comprehensive approach and that you're really addressing it from a variety of directions.
I love your all means all.
And I just want to thank you for the specifics that you provided about how does the dashboard influence and inform your decision making and your actions.
So very comprehensive.
I appreciate some of the slides that you shared.
I know it was a really tight timeline for you, which we appreciate.
But again, for particularly today and for taking theory to practice and helping to inform and offer a model for other districts to follow.
So thank you very much.
Thank you.
Board Member Rucker.
Well, I also want to echo what Board Member Strauss has said.
Joe, I want to say hi.
It's been quite a while since I've seen you.
We go back a long way, so I'm very proud of the work that Castro Valley is doing.
And what I really appreciate in your, albeit brief, but very in-depth presentation, I've heard from a lot of districts in the time I've been on this board about the efforts they've made
to implement the dashboard and to use it to inform their LCAP, and they use all these highfalutin terms about implementation and what informs their practice.
What I really appreciate is in the work that you presented today, you gave a deep explanation about, as a stakeholder from the board, what it really looks like to do a deeper dive, what systems thinking really means.
I've heard a lot of districts say
that they're doing systems thinking and then when they give their presentation and the explanation about the work they're doing, they're not.
So I really appreciate not only the questions that you pose, but how the questions have meaning to truly inform what your conversations look like and how you study and analyze not only your performance gap,
but the expectations gap.
And this is really the first time I've actually heard a district talk about not only what their performance looks like, but what they expected their performance to be and how that informed a lot of what they wrote in their LCAPs.
And so in preparation for your presentation, I also looked back and read your LCAP.
Your LCAP has become more thoughtful.
I hope that's a compliment.
from where we started in developing and writing LCAPS, and it's informed and shows up from the work that you presented today.
So I am very pleased and very thankful that you came here to give us this model and to show us what you're doing.
Thank you.
Board member Valdez.
Good morning.
I just want to thank you and I really want to highlight the partnership between the governing board and the district leadership really having the same vision and working towards all means all and I think that that is a model that not all districts have.
So the health of your district is very high in your ability to be able to work and get this is a heavy lift and you're doing great work.
So thank you.
Thank you so much.
The heavy lift is when you're at the meeting and you keep, in my case, looking around to say, when's the grown-up going to come and handle this?
And then I realize that I'm the grown-up.
But we have the data and the material to support the decisions we're making.
Just one thing I have to say, I have to give kudos to the board for allowing us to go through an entire year in developing that strategic plan through listening campaigns.
We listened to 26 groups in the community.
We partnered with board members and took the whole year so that our strategic plan is a community strategic plan.
And our community alliance we have just recently formed with many organizations has been amazing.
It was in response to some racial slurs at one of our schools.
and we sent out an invitation and said this is a community issue.
They've all come together, we meet, and we have a social justice series of films, and our students are doing season of service period of peace, which we can talk about a lot, but they're leading it, they're amazing.
Board member Sandoval.
Thank you.
You've painted a beautiful picture of how this is really working, so thank you.
I really appreciated your discussion of your philosophy on suspension and how you were willing to take a good, honest look at an old practice that just made no sense today.
And that you are doing everything you can, and everyone's committed to keeping our students in the classroom, which is where they need to be.
and the work of the Wellness Center, too, in making sure that that is part of a comprehensive response to these behaviors that we're seeing, and also that it's a community strategic plan.
It absolutely is, because in schools we can't do it alone, and it really takes a whole community to work together to move things forward.
So thank you for the work.
It was very inspiring.
Great way to start our morning.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
I also want to say hi to Joe.
I appreciate you being here.
The thing I most appreciated and wanted to highlight was the contrast between what the API used to look like and what you have now.
Because I think all of us have a hard time with change and there are many, many constituent groups
that still would like us to smush everything together and say, here's what it means.
And your example of parents or community members who say, well, I went to Southern School because there was five points difference, really highlights how imperfect the API was, especially because it was based just on test scores, as you know, a little bit on graduation rates later on.
And you really did a beautiful job, as Board Member Sandoval said, you painted a beautiful picture of what it means to have multiple measures and how you have to go about using them and then allow that data to help you make the decision.
So I just wanted to say thank you very much for highlighting that.
I also want to thank you for the presentation and I think what stood out to me was when you mentioned Sharaki Hawley and I know that if you mentioned Dr. Hawley that means that you knew there was a special need to bring someone with expertise around African-American students and restorative justice.
So I appreciate the attention to specific subgroups in this presentation.
Thank you.
Thank you for coming to us and now we're ready for the second part of this.
We're going to jump out of our PowerPoint presentation and show you a brief video.
I'm going to just queue it up.
Actually, let me introduce it first.
So this video was produced as part of a project through the Alliance for Continuous Improvement and the Californians Dedicated Education Foundation.
They worked with partners such as Californians for Justice, California State Parent Teacher Association, Alameda Unified School District, Redwood City School District, Downey Unified School District, Bay Area Parent Leadership Action
Network, and the San Mateo County Office of Education and Achieve.
And for this project, they convened six parent dashboard interactive sessions at different schools and venues.
And at each session, diverse groups of parents and educators went online, used the new dashboard, and discussed what they found.
They also found out ways that they could use the dashboard to engage in more local planning.
They conducted one-on-one interviews with more than a dozen parents.
And in doing so, they're compiling feedback to share with not only the Department of Education, but the State Board about parents' experiences.
They're creating a series of videos featuring parents in their own words, telling other parents about the dashboard to encourage more people to check it out online and get involved in schools.
This is a preview of the first video.
This link is not yet public.
They hope to make these public.
I think later on this week, there'll be a large announcement around it, or early next week.
And for those of you that know Joe Lost, you probably also know Paul Richman, and he is the gentleman behind this, and unfortunately was not able to be here today, but is very excited, and as are we, to show you this version of the video, and I believe they are translating some of these videos into Spanish as well, so I wanted to mention that too.
It's a very short, less than three minute video.
Parents are always interested to learn about how the schools are performing and how the students within the schools are performing.
I don't think many of them know the dashboard exists.
I like that you can look at the district as a whole, that you can look at one specific school, and you can look at different subgroups to see how they're performing, if they've increased, decreased.
If English language learners are not progressing, then families could see that and they could go to the school and how can they help their students progress in English.
I learned a lot about different schools and even my school.
I didn't know exactly where we were at in our reading or in our English or in our suspensions and attendance.
I liked being able to see the individual performances of the student subgroups.
I work with special education advocacy groups, so it was helpful to see how the students with disabilities are doing, but also seeing how English language learners are doing and the Hispanic
community as a whole.
There was categories I didn't even know existed.
I think it could be a super powerful tool for them to dive deeper into learning about not only how their children's schools are performing, but also how the schools throughout the whole district are performing.
But just seeing the data and being able to compare and kind of selecting which way you want to view the data, like by this subgroup or by separate school sites, it's just another tool that we have to use so that we can advocate for what our students really need.
As a parent, you want the best for your child, but you also do understand there's more to just your child.
It's a community sense, and because it's part of your community, it's part of where you live, you want the program that your child is in not only to improve for them, but to improve for other children in the future.
It reminded me to mention there were several students and I think some parents during the video that were on their phones and perhaps they were looking at the dashboard because it's now mobile responsive.
But who knows, maybe they were looking at something else that was more relevant to the people around them.
So with that, we're going to turn into some policy discussions.
And I am going to turn over in just a minute to Jenny Singh, the Administrator of the Academic Accountability Unit, who's in my division.
But just to frame the discussion, as I mentioned in the beginning, this is the beginning of what we call our work plan.
So we are looking for feedback from you all to make sure that what we have planned ahead, which is based on feedback over the last year or two years from you all,
is appropriate.
This work plan represents what we have the resources to do and know we can get done in time for the fall or rather the dashboard in December.
If for some reason something is not as high priority for you all or you want to add something to that workload, we would probably think about doing that for a parking lot for 2019.
One of them that I think about that's come up time and time again is a high school readiness discussion, high school readiness indicator.
In fact, Riverside County Office of Education came to visit us prior to this meeting trying to get it into the work plan and we simply said we have so many other things going on.
If you were able to look at the last attachment,
In this document, you would have seen just alone in the last two months, we have done five policy input sessions with our workgroups.
That is not to say that we are fully engaged, but we are a small but mighty team.
We want to make sure that we do the appropriate analysis to put something in the dashboard that is fair, reliable, and
and equitable for all.
So I do have colleagues in the room from our Career and College Transition Division.
Donna Wyatt is here, Kristen Wright is here if you have questions about special education and their inclusion in the work plan.
Michelle Senner's always here to talk about assessments.
And then I think Veronica Aguilar was gonna come down as well.
So with that in mind, I think we're ready to turn it over to Jenny.
Good morning.
Again, my name is Jenny Singh.
I'm the administrator of the Academic Accountability Unit, and I just wanted to go briefly provide an overview of the information that is in Attachment 1 before we open it up for discussion.
There's a lot of information in there, and I just wanted to remind everyone of the recommended changes that we are considering for the 2018 release.
So first is chronic absenteeism.
We were planning on bringing the status to the board this March, but we decided we needed to do a little more in-depth analysis of the data, so we're going to bring both status and change to the board in the fall for review, so you'll set status and change cut scores at the same time.
We have the college and career indicator.
We already have those status cut scores, and that information is on the web.
We will be bringing recommended change cut scores between now and this summer.
We also are going to be bringing some additional career measures that we want to add into the dashboard for the fall.
We need to do some analysis.
We're going to be doing a paper on the process that we use in order to determine if measures are valid and reliable and should be included in the dashboard.
So, we'll be bringing that to you later on this summer.
We've been working with our alternative schools task force on the dashboard alternative school status or DAS for alternative methods that we would want to add into the dashboard this fall.
This is for schools that meet the criteria established by the board and we are using modified methods when appropriate for some of the indicators.
So we do believe that we will be bringing a recommendation for a one-year graduation rate.
and some modified career measures that would be available for DAS schools.
We have our safety net methodology.
You might recall that you approved that safety net methodology last year.
We applied it to only two indicators, the graduation rate and the suspension rate.
We did it at the school level only.
We didn't have a lot of time to do in-depth analysis for student groups, but we are, potentially we want to add that three by five table for student groups in those two areas, in those two indicators.
We have our student level growth model, which we've been talking about off and on for the last couple of years.
We were very lucky to have our testing vendor, ETS, run some simulations for us.
We provided a February memo for you on that.
They did a simulation on three different models.
We are going to be having some conversations, not only with our technical design group, but also with our stakeholders, and of course, some more in-depth conversations with the board as we move forward with this indicator.
Our English Learner Progress Indicator.
This should be no surprise.
When we first did our methodology for this indicator, we did indicate that we are going to be having a new test, and that is the English Language Proficiency Assessments for California, or the LPAC, and we indicated when we first did the methodology using the CELF that we would have to, when we have a new test, we'd have to revisit that methodology.
So we will be bringing that back.
We are working very closely with our LP work group again,
they'll be bringing forth some recommendations and it's very possible that they may want to do the same thing that we've done for chronic absenteeism and bring status and change to the board at the same time which means that we wouldn't be bringing that to you until 2019.
We have the participation rate, which is required under ESSA.
We have to incorporate that into our accountability system.
We indicated we would develop some icons to display on our dashboard.
We're working with our contractor at the Sacramento County Office of Education.
And once we get some icons that we can share with our stakeholders, we can get their feedback and then bring that back to the board too before September.
We are proposing to do a state-level dashboard report.
You might recall that for the ESSA state plan, we produced some state-level data for some of our indicators.
We got a lot of good feedback on that.
People were really happy to see that data, and it asked us if we were planning on producing a state-level dashboard, so we said we would certainly put that on the list.
We have our four-year graduation rate.
This is the only indicator where we use a three-year average for change.
We've talked several times with our technical design group on this and have determined that we really should use a one-year rate rather than a three-year rate.
I know we had discussed previously that we were thinking about using a three-year rate for all indicators, but after conversations with our TDG, we decided we should actually do a one-year rate.
We've had some conversation about a five-year graduation rate so this is one area where we are really asking for specific guidance from you today.
We may not be able to incorporate the grad rate into the four-year indicator that we already have so we want to know if you want us to pursue other options and that is because the requirements under ESSA so we would like some feedback on that.
You might recall that we had a business rule that we put in place where we assigned the performance level of orange for any district that did not certify their suspension data in CALPADS and for any district or school that did not test at least 50% of their English learners on the language test.
They were automatically assigned a performance level of orange.
We're considering changing that assignment to an automatic assignment of red.
And we would like your specific feedback from you today on this particular item.
So, with that, I'm happy to answer any questions.
We are bringing these proposals to you.
As I mentioned in the beginning, we're looking for guidance, especially on the last two that Jenny
specifically mentioned, we are seeking guidance on.
That does not mean that we're not open to having a conversation about the other pieces.
We will, like anything that we do, make sure that it has technical merit by taking it to our technical design group.
But we also, some of these ideas have come out actually through conferences we've attended with people from local educational agencies or parents or community members saying, why aren't you looking at this?
And so that's how some of these ideas come to pass, I think, especially with that safety net recommendation.
I think Jenny was at a conference last month in Monterey, and there was a lot of interest and some pressure to bring that forward.
That's not to say that by the time it gets to you all, you may disagree.
That is okay, too.
This is definitely meant to be a transparent process, which is why we have laid out a work plan for these next several months.
It will involve quite a bit of stakeholders, not only in our technical design group, but if we have a working group that we have established.
English Learner Progress Workgroup, or our College Career Indicator Workgroup, or our Alternative Schools Task Force, you will hear what they have to say as well.
We have an ongoing, every other month, discussion with the local control funding formula stakeholder group, which includes not only our education advocates, but our equity groups.
So there is a thorough vetting of these.
Sometimes I think the language we use makes it sound like it's a done deal, and it's not a done deal.
You all have the final say in anything that we bring forward, and hopefully for inclusion in the fall dashboard, which will be a very robust dashboard with two extra indicators with colors on them.
So there's a lot of work to do to get to that place.
Yeah, I'd like to start with comments on the fifth year graduation rate and hear views of board members on that, Ortiz, Lacombe.
Oh, OK, Nikki Sandoval.
About the five-year graduation rate, I feel very strongly that there should be a way to incorporate that in the dashboard, especially, I think we all should think about our students with disabilities and schools that are working to keep our students in school.
And sometimes it takes five years to earn a high school diploma.
So I think that there needs to be a way to reflect that in the dashboard.
Martiz Lacone.
I'm on the fence and I'll tell you why.
I think that it is great, it is ideal for us to graduate our students and some may need that five year, that fifth year.
My concern has always been a tracking system.
I read some of the letters and folks pointed to unaccompanied youth or LTELs, but we're not tracking information of students whether or not they're unaccompanied.
So we don't know that that's actually who's benefiting from this.
If they're LTELs, the majority of our English learners are born in the States and have started with us since kinder.
So we really should just try to graduate them by that fourth year.
And so my concern would be, one, if we included an essay, it has to show that it is more rigorous.
So some examples have been when students take that fifth year to earn an AA while they're earning their high school degree because they're doing concurrent enrollment.
So that would be an example of something that's more rigorous.
So I would like to hear how we would justify it being more rigorous.
versus just saying we want to give students extra time because I would hate to be that student that somebody determines that I need that fifth year when perhaps I don't right I just need to be better served so that would be my only concern is can this become a tracking system and if we want to pursue the fifth year how are we making this more rigorous
or we have a sense of who are these students that are pursuing the fifth year.
And again it can be intuitive because saying that it's unaccompanied youth we're assuming that it's unaccompanied youth and we wouldn't want to track that either because we don't want to jeopardize the well-being of our students and their status.
Thanks.
Other comments?
Board Member Sun.
So I would like to seek a fifth year graduation rate for a couple reasons.
One is the students on IEPs who may need a little bit further time and we are seeing a huge increase in the number of students on IEPs and 504s.
that do need that additional time and that pressure of having to finish or not graduate at all in the four years is something that I think actually puts them back when it comes to social-emotional stress, anxiety, all of those.
The other is more of a technical question.
Remember, I think I believe that we
have moved back the timing of the graduation, like when a student is considered a graduate, right?
From, I think it used to be in August, and now it is... Yes, August 15th was the date.
Was the date, and now it is...
So it is still August 15th, but with that I will say that we are moving up the timeline to submit data for the graduation rate.
You may recall this board and a lot of stakeholder groups and districts wanted us to have up-to-date information in the dashboard and you may recall that the graduation rate was always a lag indicator.
And so we were asked to see what we could do to move that up.
And of course, to put in the most current data, we have to actually shorten the timeline for submittal.
So even though the August 15th date will still be there, it might be more difficult for districts to report that data.
Yes, because we do have students who, their senior year, go to summer school to finish that one class, one credit, and then they would not be considered graduates within the school's information.
So the August 15th wouldn't pick that up because some of them are still in school.
Yes, they're taking summer school or something, but the schools have to report the number of students who did not graduate before that time.
Before that time.
Actually, it's after that time.
I think right now it's the 25th.
Is that right?
24th.
24th of August is the final deadline for end-of-year submission, which this will be part of.
Okay, so I'm going to support the direction of exploring the five year graduation.
We understand your recommendation, at least on this proposal is we have a four year and we'll have a five year.
And I would say, particularly for the kids who the students who do go to summer school to finish that last class or.
May and June got kind of crazy at school and they didn't pass and they had to do it.
But there are a few kids students who come back for fifth year seniors.
It's not very often, but sometimes.
And it's not only special needs kids.
It depends on what else is going on in students lives.
So I'd like the option.
So I would support the reporting both.
And I think that would just help ensure that those students try to get everyone graduated by four year.
But if it takes a little more time that there's a recognition that we are getting them to graduate.
So I would support the recommendation that we explore both.
Board Member Burr.
So I agree with the comments by Board Member Sung and Board Member Strauss about exploring it.
The one thing I want to be clear about, and this is where I probably differ from my friend on my left, that I think we want to have the presentation as what it looks like in our system, not what ESSA wants.
You know, there's a theme here about ESSA.
So just so that we have those options available, what does it look like if it's just the state system?
What does it look like if we're complying with ESSA?
Because I do think there are many circumstances under which a fifth-year graduation rate would be not only motivating to students but also helpful to our LEAs in terms of their planning.
Board member Valdez.
I'm also in favor of a five-year looking into that.
I have a couple questions though when we think about the rigor and I concur that the rigor needs to be there.
I think it's a question of not if they'll graduate but when they graduate and there are students who need that fifth year.
I'd like to know the number of students approximately and what are we talking about but I also think that this helps districts demonstrate their commitment to getting students a diploma, a high school diploma
and sometimes it takes a longer period of time.
So that's my thoughts.
I have to admit I was also on the fence for a while and it was about the access and the equity issue.
This can't be, but I am going to support the recommendation today.
This cannot become, by salutary neglect, some way that districts use of tracking or monitoring students either based on their performance or based on their
lag in completing graduation requirements.
It cannot become a systemic way of placing, monitoring, or tracking students and meeting graduation requirements in order to meet or do this report.
The fifth-year graduation should be an exception, not a rule, regardless of what the reason for the exception of needing the additional time is.
And so if we begin seeing in this reporting an increase in the number of students that are being placed through or being reported in this fifth year graduation rate, we have a continuing issue of disparate impact
that looks just like the significant disproportionate representation of students being referred to special ed or the significant disproportionate ways that students are being represented on the suspension rate.
So what I do not want to see is that.
And so it needs to be clear that this is a reporting activity, not an option for counseling, placing and tracking students.
And so again, I want to emphasize the fifth year is an exception, not something that becomes a norm for what schools do.
And so I will support that for this reason, but I do have that concern.
So I just want to remind everyone that under AYP we actually did produce a five-year grad rate so we have that data for those years and if I recall and I'm not saying that my memory is as good as it used to be but if I recall there wasn't an increase in five-year grad rates over time but we will look at that data because we have that and we can provide some information to you.
Board Member Holiday.
So the dashboard is supposed to provide us more information.
And this is the fifth year cohort is information.
And just because that information is published, I don't think that it necessarily means that schools and districts are going to somehow find comfort in their five year cohort.
So I think it's important to shine a light on those and to let us know how many and where they are and who they are.
So I am in favor of exploring that.
Yeah, I've studied this a lot in higher education.
And as you know, a four-year graduation rate was this norm for a long time.
Then we began to find that there was a whole lot of graduation in the fifth and sixth year.
So higher education uses basically four years, six years, and for tracking purposes they go up to eight years.
There's quite a significant... there's some who graduate, take as long as eight years.
So the theme, I support this too, but the mixed record of this, part of the four-year lack of graduation is bad scheduling.
by the post-secondary education institutions.
They don't offer the right required classes at the right time.
Whoever does their master schedules at a lot of these places are not looking at students, they're looking at what I understand we do in higher education.
You schedule the classes when the professors want to teach.
I always schedule 10 o'clock and
And there was a glut of 10 o'clock, but if you wanted to have a go at 5 o'clock, you know, the students had a lot more flexibility there.
So there's issues there, but I do think the other thing about higher education, and I've observed, is that there are
whole lots of things going on in students and family life that impact the graduation rate that are outside the control of the school.
They move around, there's family crises, they have to go to work temporarily, things of that sort.
So I think it is proper to do this but we need to keep in mind that and we're at the mercy of these high school master schedules and I often
wonder really we need to keep a sharp eye on that as we proceed with this.
So perhaps we can move over to the second place we were looking for specific guidance on the automatic assignment of red performance levels and happy to respond to questions or again feedback on on this particular.
Board Member Holland.
So this is about the automatic assignment of the red performance level.
So once again, I think the dashboard is a tool to provide information about what's going on in schools and districts.
I don't think the purpose is to use the dashboard in a punitive way.
And by turning this into a automatic red performance level, it is not giving accurate information.
That school very likely may not be in the red performance level for absenteeism or whatever.
Instead, my recommendation would be to make it a purple.
Seriously, seriously, because it is by doing that, you would say, this is what this means.
We didn't get the information.
You know, it doesn't mean that they're necessarily a red or an orange or any other color, it means
We don't know where they are because they didn't give us the, certify the information.
And that's what this purple means.
So it still is a red.
It still is a flag for parents and the community to say, well, something's wrong here.
And it certainly can be noted.
But to automatically assign it to red, I think, is a mistake.
Who's next?
Felisa Ortiz-Lacombe.
Can I ask why we're making this recommendation?
Has this been a pattern?
Is this something that we're encountering with some of our LEAs not submitting information or not testing at least 50% of their ELs?
So we did do an assignment of orange on the 2017 dashboard.
It was less than a dozen schools.
But we're doing this because if they're a red, we have some schools that could use some support in helping them with their system and how to report data.
And so if they get a red, then they might actually be able to get some support for
helping them better manage their data reporting systems.
And that's why we were considering it.
And how about on the LP?
And on the LP, of course, districts are required to test their students for language in the language assessment.
And we felt that if they weren't doing that, that they're that they should that we couldn't possibly give them a green if they've only tested, you know, 49 percent or percent of their students because it doesn't reflect all their students.
And I would agree with at least 50% of English learners being tested, if not, you know, defaulting to a red.
I don't agree in adding another color.
I think that that would be very, very confusing to people.
And we've already, we're kind of trending on our color scheme that we have.
So I wouldn't want to add something else to the dashboard.
But I do think that 50%, if you're not testing 50% of your English learners, that's bad.
That's really bad.
Sir.
Who's next?
Board Member Holiday.
Yeah, I understand how adding another color can be a problem.
And I understand how not testing 50% is a horrible problem and I understand how not certifying this.
All this is bad.
I think it's a slippery slope if you turn the dashboard from purely raw information into a punitive tool.
I think that's not a good route to go.
Board Member Rucker.
Well, I do understand the issue about the color, but I'm also not in favor of adding another color.
And as I'm sitting here listening to this conversation, I'm looking at Liz Guillen, because Public Advocates has been really strong in urging and advocating to the board
when LEAs are failing to make timely reporting and information about the material and content that's required for accountability purposes and what should be placed in the school report card and what should be reported.
So I think it is important to identify when schools are not making these reports in a timely manner.
But I'm also sensitive to the fact that if we're truly trying to use the dashboard to focus on continuous improvement,
using the dashboard to signal for a systemic failure of the schools to not have the personnel who are supposed to do the work they do.
We already have those conversations in our waivers when we have discussions about waivers because someone forgot to test a group of students or someone forgot to turn in some report on time.
I think that we do have other symbols in the dashboard that we can use.
If the information's not there, there are symbols that we've already approved that can simply say that there's not a sufficient amount of information.
to be able to give this report rather than punishing the school with a color change so that if the school did not turn in the information so it could be reported, there should be no color reported for that school.
That's still a performance indicator because it means something didn't happen and something wasn't reported.
I think it's the asterisk.
I can't remember what the symbol is.
So rather than doing a color change to punish some central office personnel who did not get
the work done to do the reporting in a timely manner.
I think it's more important to notify the public the data simply wasn't turned in by simply using that.
Approve another symbol saying the data wasn't turned in by the LEA for this item rather than create another color
or to use the colors to punish the district.
But further, for those districts that do these things, I think the other side of what we have to look at is how districts then use this process of not reporting or continuously failing to report
That's a separate issue from whether or not the reports are actually happening.
And so I think some work does need to be done with that because as you know, we do have districts from year to year that regularly have problems, not only getting their data upload for their school report cards done on time, but getting other things relative to the accountability and the assessment system done on time.
So that's a larger problem than accountability reporting.
So I think it would be really important to discern if it's a will or a skill from the district level who are not participating and so I think you already said Jenny that there were only a few districts who changed colors to orange this year and
And I think I concur.
I mean, I I would recommend no color, but I would also recommend some kind of a trigger that as soon as the window closes and you have, let's say, 12 districts that that there's an outreach assuming good intentions of why they didn't to help them get.
So so not just to use it as a gotcha and this is your color, but rather, how can we make this better?
Thank you.
Carrick Ashley, Deputy Superintendent, I did I did want to add one aspect to this conversation.
Fortunately, this is a small number of districts we're talking about, but I I can attest that a couple of years ago prior to the dashboard release.
There was a district, and I'm not going to name them publicly, but I'll be glad to talk privately with anyone who's interested, who purposefully did not certify their data because not having data was better for them than the negative publicity they would have gotten from the data that was accurate.
So, just wanted to make, we don't want to provide an incentive for those not to certify their data because orange is better than red.
And Karek also, I thought he was going to mention this.
We have, my colleague was down here just a minute ago, but he's disappeared.
Jerry Winkler, who's the manager or the division director of the, he didn't disappear, I'm sure he went upstairs, the Educational Data Management Division.
I'm going to get in trouble for that one.
He manages a contract with the Kern County Office of Education, CSES, the California School Information System, thank you, too many acronyms today.
And they do exactly what you're talking about.
They are, before any deadline, they have, you know,
Actually, before we even open a data collection window, they have a proposed, this is how you should maybe structure your data input activities.
By September, this is a milestone.
By October, there's another milestone.
And if by November and there's a deadline and they haven't met it, they're calling them.
They're calling them every day kind of thing.
So we have the benefit of that really fantastic outreach from our partners at Kern County Office of Education.
And so, but that's not to say that we don't have people that have submitted either no data or inaccurate data and told us afterwards, oh, we messed up kind of thing.
Senator Valdez.
So just to one other comment, then there should be some other sanction.
I mean, I'm saying a sanction, some kind of a monetary thing.
Hold back some EL money if they're not testing their EL learners.
I mean, those are the kind of things that I think should happen.
I don't know how that wouldn't happen.
Thank you for the feedback.
Is there any other on this particular attachment?
Are you ready to move on?
We can definitely go ahead.
Yes.
So I had a question about the safety net because we're using the word student group.
So are we saying subgroup?
Because we have an end size right now of 30.
So I'm wondering how this would look if we apply the safety net methodology to an end size of 30, which is very different than what we had previously with 120, I believe.
So what are we proposing here?
Because there wasn't a lot of information.
So the current safety net is applied at the school level and if you have less than 150 students, we apply the three by five grid to make a determination.
We are proposing to use that same methodology at the student group level or subgroups for all the subgroups that have between 30 and less than 150 students.
So they would get the three by five applied to make a determination in the suspension rate and the graduation rate only.
So it would be above 30, though?
Yes.
And are you recommending 30 and 120, or 30 and 150, or are you going to do some analysis around that?
Between 30 and less than 150.
Okay.
And we are going to be doing analysis on that, so we will be bringing that information to you.
And my second question was around the college or career.
So the CCI, the memo really helped to clarify.
I know I had some questions around that.
So I have a technical question, then I have more of a philosophical question.
The technical, how are we going, when do we add new measures?
How are we then doing the change considering that we're adding additional measures?
So that's the technical.
And then I honestly have to say I missed when we dropped and.
I thought we were college and career and I know that then it became CCI and I read some of the letters that came in and people think that is college and career but there was a memo that finally said or career.
So are we saying or until we have a well-prepared that could make it a college and career?
Or why do we eventually drop the and and become or?
Because I really miss that.
Well, we did drop the N, and we did it when we went from four levels to three levels.
We felt there weren't enough career measures in the CCI to have a well-prepared category, and that would be the category where it would be college and career ready.
So until we are able to add in additional information for career, we will not be having a level four.
But once we get to level four, the goal is that by 2020, hopefully we can add in a level four and it will be college and career ready.
But that is the goal.
Okay, so we're waiting for well-prepared to become and again.
Correct.
And can you tell us a little bit about the change, how we're going to figure that out once we add new measures?
So we will have to do some simulations.
We have already discussed this with our technical design group, and they don't feel that it's going to be a big issue.
They don't think it's going to be a technical issue that we should be concerned about, but of course, we won't know until we do the simulations for them.
But at this point, we're confident that we could add in measures because we're comparing cohort to cohort.
and when we add new measures in that is going to give a boost to LEAs that is that is true so but we will be doing the simulations and bringing that information forward to the for the board to review.
Board Member Sun.
I just have a comment on the CCI as well.
I just hope that before we start adding additional measures onto the CCI that we also are looking at the validity and reliability of what we've got currently because now we have the data really look at that, which students are included in CCI, which are not, and I think we've looked at it a little bit more closely and
There's some kind of scratching of heads and wrinkling of brows.
Really, is that what it means?
So I just would encourage before we add additional stuff to really look at the current measures that we have.
We have put more work into the CCI than any of the other indicators.
We've done some extensive simulations on that.
And we've worked with David Connolly in a contract that we had to review various things that would be appropriate to put in the CCI.
We've had a lot of vetting with our stakeholder group.
So we have put a lot of work and done a lot of simulations already.
But we will be putting forth a paper that will show you the process that we use and the criteria that we establish for adding things into the CCI.
I think there's a wealth of information and it's sort of hard to discern at this point, which is why the memo and it being more tailored and the feedback that you gave us at the last meeting and other meetings was really helpful to get us to focus on those particular areas.
I think we think that you remember everything from two years ago and unfortunately really none of us do.
So we have to remind ourselves of the work that's been put in.
Yeah, let me heads up for the board.
Under ESSA, if we remove, if we go along with the plan that we negotiated with the U.S.
Department, we're going to have to list the 11th grade assessment results separately.
And that will have spillover effects into the CCI.
So that they're not ready to discuss that yet.
We haven't approved it.
They haven't analyzed it, but that's coming.
So this is still a work in progress.
Member Valdez.
So I think I missed the memo on the or and the and.
It was before your time.
Okay, thank you.
So it's really worrying me because we just spent two days in our district talking about college and career and so we're going forward with all of the services and the programs and the support to be sure that we have this continuum of options for students and it just worries me that the indicator is an or
I mean an or, yes, and that we are an and.
And I think most of our consumers, our districts, have really embraced, and it has been an ongoing conversation for the last few years about and or or, right?
And was it politically correct to say or or and?
And so with that, I'm just really concerned.
I would love to keep the and, even though I know it's a little bit of semantics, but it's a mindset over time.
And so I just feel like it's gonna cause confusion.
And the way that it's set up, it doesn't preclude somebody from being and, and that is definitely not the intent, and I hope that that wasn't taken that way.
It's that we are working towards making sure that we can get there with the well-prepared piece.
But there are several, and you'll see in the data, if you've got a chance to look at some of the reports, that they are both, a lot of our students that are prepared are actually prepared for both college and career.
And I agree with you, it's just dropping it and changing it, it causes confusion and then sometimes it causes lack of trust and conversations happen and then it becomes confusing.
Thank you.
Board Member Byrd.
So on the CCI for just a second, first I do want to acknowledge the memo that was posted for February, which I thought was very helpful in helping refresh everybody's memory about what's in there, what's not, what we have moving forward.
And I think the one thing that I think gets lost a little bit in conversations that I've had is that the CCI indicator is an indicator relative to LEAs, not relative to students.
So while the student preparation, in my view, is the responsibility of the LEAs, and it's all kinds of different things, some of which that are in the CCI, some of which are not yet in the CCI, the way I look at the CCI for the state is it's like a good housekeeping seal.
that if I look at my data dashboard and my school, my LEA is green, then I know, well, they've got a robust program at the high school level that is reflective of both career and college opportunities for students.
So I think it's hard to kind of sort it out, and the reason, as Jenny and I were talking about,
Cindy have mentioned is that we're not ready for well-prepared at the state level because of our sort of rigor with respect to what's in the CCI.
So I just hope it's not sending confusing messages because at an LEA level, LEAs have expectations for their students and set their programming based on those expectations.
And we're not suggesting that that should change in any way.
What we're saying is we're growing into the CCI to get to the well-prepared level, which can be the end, ultimately, if we can meet our standard of rigor.
Okay, who's next?
Board Member Rocker.
Well, let me begin by saying I well remember the action the board took and the day that the name of the indicator changed from the and and the or, because I voice strong opposition and concern about what that would mean.
And I remember I used words that probably shocked my board president, like lip service.
to career preparation and board member burr is correct this is not an indicator that's concerning that operates at the student level this is reporting about the access and the types of programs that are available and being provided by the district it's an assessment of the district's performance in creating access and balance in the programs they're providing to students and having said that my
Concern remains that when we look at the individual elements that currently define the indicator, yes, the indicator does not have a balance of information that tells us about the scope and the type and variety and diversity of career preparation programs.
that are available.
But what and so and I also for that reason appreciate the February memo that was sent out to remind us about the work that has been done up to this point and the work that is in front of the department and the board
to fully build out and develop the indicator.
But let me say the same thing that I have said before and have been very consistent with.
We may be very busy doing a lot of things, but are we doing the correct things?
In the February Remember What Talk, one of the things that was discussed or at least touched upon, but not in the depth that it needed to be, was how we define career preparation and how we collect the data from districts about this, about what they're offering.
Because we know that there's a great deal of flexibility in what's reported in CALPADS and how courses are identified, it's very difficult to quantify and to categorize
all the different types of CTE.
I have personally been concerned that right now, the only type of CTE that is being reported or fully reflected in the indicator are the programs funded through the Career Pathways Trust.
I will.
I appreciate all the work that you have reported that we have been doing with Dr. Conway and all of these other folks in the workgroup, but the fact is there is a lot of work that needs to be done to straighten out the data gathering and the collection
and I don't think that that is fully explained or fully being vetted as well as it should be.
I do remember when the change occurred.
I strongly objected for those reasons.
I know the Department is addressing that, but that is where the work and the priority needs to be.
We have some members who want to and staff who want to do things concerning the student demonstration.
So we will resume at 1020.
Thank you.
Okay, the State Board will reconvene.
And if we can come back up, I think we're almost done with the questioning on that section.
So do you want to move on, Cindy, to the next item there?
Your next, it's a multi-item, here we go.
Go ahead.
We can, so seeing no other comments on attachment one, we'll move on to attachment two, which is going to be presented by Deputy, Chief Deputy Superintendent Glenn Price.
President Kuerz, members of the board it's a delight to be with you presenting on the proposed revision for the self-reflection tool for priority six and especially I think appropriate that we're taking up this item just after or walk out in our comments earlier from Superintendent Tarlekson and Board Member Gray around the importance of school safety and the need to
take further action in that regard.
As we dive into this item, I really want to thank all of the stakeholders that have contributed to our work on school conditions and climate, and particularly want to thank a couple of my colleagues here at the Department of Education, Jacqueline Oleson,
in my office and Jen Taylor in our expanded learning division who have really left it on the field in terms of getting ready for all of this work and helping stakeholders engage in this critical item.
As we move along today, I wanted to just recall our presentation of the School Conditions and Climate Workgroup back in November of 2017 to the State Board of Education.
And at that time, the workgroup presented three buckets of action that they were recommending in the area of school conditions and climate.
And the first was required legislative action and additional financial investments and that work is moving forward and I would especially refer you to AB 2820 where there's some significant discussion occurring in the legislature about these issues.
Bucket number two, work and actions that can be taken by the State Board of Education as part of your process of the dashboard's continuous improvement.
And that's what we're going to be focusing on today.
And then number three, areas where CDE and other participants in California's statewide system of support can be taking action immediately with tools and resources at our disposal.
So just to recap again, for today, we're going to be focusing on that bucket number two, and specifically a proposed revision to the self-reflection tool for priority six.
And this is contained that it's in your item, but also in a handout that you have in front of you.
And we're coming back to this.
And the superintendent and the California Department of Education are asking today that you take action to approve this revision to the self-reflection tool for priority six.
And of course, this work builds on the complete set of recommendations that was made by the School Conditions and Climate Work Group and that great group of stakeholders that we got together for that work of parents, teachers, administrators, researchers coming together to make those recommendations, which you also have in front of you, and the memo that we presented to you in February of this year.
This work builds on the continuous improvement framework that was put forward by the school conditions and climate work group, which you'll see reflected in the self-reflection tool that starts out with data, thinking about what is the data that we have in front of us.
What is the meaning that we can make of that data and how should we actually then use it to drive forward the kinds of actions that will make our schools and school communities have positive climates and reflect the kinds of safety that we'd like to see.
for our students and educators and their connectedness to those schools and educational institutions.
So just as we get started on this work, I wanted to just reflect and connect back to the improved performance standard for local
And we've got those up on the screen.
And the board has asked LEAs to meet the approved standard of measuring their progress using locally available information, reporting that to their local governing boards at regularly scheduled public meetings, updating that progress through the dashboard, and then assessing their performance on a met, not met, not met for two or more years scale.
The approved standard for priority six, and this is what we have in place right now, is that the LEA administer a local climate survey at least every other year that provides a valid measure of perceptions of school safety and connectedness, such as the California Healthy Kids Survey, and then report that information out at a regularly scheduled meeting of the local board and through the dashboard.
The current self-reflection tool is also up there on the screen, and the self-reflection tool calls for LEAs to provide a narrative summary around the administration of that local climate survey, and report on that through a text box provided in the dashboard.
And in the dashboard, LEAs have the opportunity to report out on their overall scores, such as through surveys like California Healthy Kids,
and also to analyze any specific items related to school safety and connectedness.
So at Your Direction, we gathered together a group of stakeholders and worked for about a year on a set of very comprehensive recommendations, again, which you have in front of you.
And we presented back in November of 2017 a proposed revision to the self-reflection tool.
And at that time, you all asked us to engage in some additional stakeholder work around the self-reflection tool.
We did that in a number of ways.
I just really want to thank the California Practitioners Advisory Group for several in-depth discussions on the new self-reflection tool, and I'll be reporting out on their feedback around the tool in just a second.
We also facilitated a great conversation with the LCFF stakeholder group in February and want to also thank representatives of small and rural schools who we met with also in February of this year.
And then to complement that, we provided opportunity for the public to comment on the self-reflection tool through a survey conducted also in February of this year.
So as part of that work, we asked, for example, CPAC and through the online survey, CPAC and members of the public, several questions about the self-reflection tool.
We asked them whether the self-reflection tool assists school districts to better communicate what is occurring around school climate within their district.
And you'll see there that 85% of CPAC members either agreed or strongly agreed that it did.
We also asked CPAG members whether the tool helped parents, families, and community members better understand the climate of schools and their districts, and 100% either agreed or strongly agreed with that statement.
CPAG members were also asked whether the tool helped to communicate decisions made and actions taken, and the vast majority either strongly agreed or agreed with that statement.
Those types of results and that range of responses was also reflected through the online survey where 68% of respondents agreed that it assists with better communication, 61% it helps district stakeholders to better understand the climate, and 67% helps districts communicate actions to improve school climate.
A vast and relatively large-scale agreement with the self-reflection tool being proposed, being an improvement to our current system.
Some additional feedback that we heard, and this is just a sampling, and we've been able to incorporate this into the tool.
To add the words data meaning and use to the appropriate guiding question,
And I just wanted to share with you a quote from
Superintendent Kaminsky from Azusa Unified who noted that these questions and those words speak to how LEAs reflect their key learnings on access and result.
It speaks to disaggregated data, which is helpful for us to see what is occurring.
And then the third helps us look at our next step, helps us deepen what we are doing, expand our change course, as they were discussing.
use of those guiding questions.
The small and rural districts were particularly happy that we added the language, asked to add the language and were happy that we did around additional data tools.
And that language specifically encourages those districts who have other tools or other surveys or other forms of data gathering that they've used around school conditions and climate to add it into the self-reflection tool.
So what are we proposing?
Pulling up your blue sheet here, we've updated the language for priority six, the self-reflection tool.
So this is the language that would be in the dashboard that LEAs would be responding to, as shown on the screen there.
And that's the first paragraph that's at the top of your blue sheet.
That local education agencies will provide a narrative summary of their local administration analysis of a local climate survey.
And then as we go forward, that we would include an analysis of specific items on a local survey and additional data collection tools that are particularly relevant to school conditions and climate.
We then have
added some footnotes at the bottom where we've linked into the Ed Code language around sense of safety and school connectedness as the constructs that we're looking at.
And then also a best practice around disaggregating where possible and if applicable to student groups in order to be able to look at student groups as we're looking at the results of these surveys and data collection tools.
Then as you go further down the page on the blue sheet, we've added this language where the following are suggested guiding questions to help frame the narrative summary.
Data, reflect on the key learnings from the survey results and share what the LEA learned, meaning what do the disaggregated results of the survey and other data collection methods reveal about schools in the LEA, such as areas of growth,
areas of strength or growth, challenges and barriers, and then use.
How are we using this data, these learnings to improve?
What revisions, decisions or actions has or will the LEA implement in response to the results for continuous improvement purposes?
So those are the changes that we're recommending to the self-reflection tool.
Again, staff are recommending that the State Board of Education approved this proposed revision and that we begin incorporating it into the dashboard and utilize it going forward for priority six school climate.
Thank you.
Board member comments or questions on this?
All right.
State Superintendent.
Glenn to share the names of those, and if any are here to have them be recognized who helped.
It was quite a team effort and a lot of intensive work and creative thinking.
And I commend Glenn, of course, but he had a whole team with him.
Actually, if you look into your School Conditions and Climate Recommendation Framework, right at the top of the page there, the members of the School Conditions and Climate Work Group included Ken Barrick, Aaron Brengard, Shannon Brown, Shannon Cook-Harvey, Brent Ducour, Sherry Griffith, Tom Hanson, Tom Herman,
Heather Huff, Taryn Ishida, Hannah Melnick, and Norma Sanchez.
And then I just want to repeat the tremendous amount of stakeholder engagement work that was undertaken with literally hundreds of people contributing through open meetings, through the survey, and in other ways.
Okay, if we have no comments on that, Board Member Ortiz-Lacon.
Thank you for the presentation, and I want to thank everyone who was involved in this.
I do think this is a huge improvement from the MET, not MED, because it allows us to really look and see how LEAs are reflecting on their data.
I love the data meaning use.
And in fact, I think we should do that with all of our local indicators so that we could see how the data is actually being reflected upon and applied, right?
Is this going to have links or is that an option to link to the actual survey?
And I know that folks would really wanna see this as an annual survey.
I think that seems like that is not something that we can move forward, it's optional.
But I think that it's important for us to have that data and then apply it, right?
So, you know, you reflect on it, then you apply it.
I do think it's limited for us just to have that data for students, because I know that teachers want their voices heard in this process.
Parents absolutely want their voice heard in this process.
And that is a good way to triangulate the data and see, does this school climate meet the needs of our community?
And the community goes beyond the student, although it should be focused on the student.
So I do think that this is a great way to reflect upon it and I would like to see this actually with the other local indicators as well.
And just in response to that the one piece around linking the dashboard will encourage LEAs if they have a link available to include that in the dashboard and then in addition to break that down by student group if available and applicable.
Okay, nothing more.
We can then we have one more item, sub-item in this item.
Good morning President Kerr, Superintendent Torlakson, members of the board.
I'm Jeff Breshears, the Director of the Local Agency Assistance Support Office.
And I'm here to talk about the request and the recommendation for local indicator for Priority 7.
We're recommending that the State Board approve the standard consistent with the standards adopted for the other local indicators and the proposed self-assessment tool to determine progress for the local performance indicator for Priority 7 access to a broad course of study.
It's attachment three is the draft self-reflection tool.
It is reflective of feedback from you when I was before you in November and also from the CPAC group and the LCFF stakeholder groups.
Some of the major changes that were made to the self-reflection tool is one is that we listed the courses that are supposed to be offered grades one through six and also seven through 12.
and then on one of the prompts, we changed the third and fourth prompt, which I will get to as well, but the first prompt was talking about just taking from statute.
We took also a lot of the statute that gets in the way of reading, but also to talk about
the access to a broad course of study of students who have that access and enrolled in for unduplicated pupils under LCFF, but also there's an encouragement that LEAs are not restricted to just the unduplicated pupil groups, to look at all of their students within the LEA to determine them.
And then also the prompts that were changed was the third and the fourth prompt, and one is the third prompt was to identify barriers
Given the results, identify the barriers preventing the LEA from providing an access to a broad course of study for all students.
And then the last prompt is, then given that information, what action have you take or will you take then to overcome those barriers and to offer that access to a broad course of study?
And I'm happy to answer any questions.
Questions?
Okay, I think we're ready for public comment now on this item.
No?
One more item?
This is maybe the fun part.
Sorry.
I'm sure Glenn's piece was fun, but we are going to have some fun today.
So we wanted to
Never mind.
My window's been closed.
I'm not going to take the time to do that.
But I do wanted to talk about this mock-up here.
So one of the things that we've gotten feedback on is really that landing page and how reports look and feel.
And there's a lot of white space and a lot of text heavy.
So we wanted to jazz it up.
This is one mock-up that our contractor has put together for us.
and thinking about doing it in like a rotating carousel, sort of like you see on our department's webpage.
So I wanted to show you this.
There's actually, if I had had the site up, which it was this morning, you could see that we put together really a mission statement.
That was one thing that they said.
You don't clearly articulate really what people should get out of this.
So this is the beginning of, I think, a process until we get to our new dashboard release in the fall.
to change the look and feel to make it a little more visually pleasing.
I know the Governor's budget proposes an additional $300,000 towards this.
While this is only the homepage, the look and feel of some of the concerns you've raised in the past about equity report and others, trying to make that a little bit more manageable are things we are looking into.
The other thing we have directly asked the contractor to look into and to further as we think about redesigning this is to make it a translatable website into Spanish.
That is still on the list of things to do, but we want to make sure that they're not doing it now when we know we have a redesign.
it planned in the next several months.
And then the final piece is that we do have now the functionality to print to PDF.
So if you wanted to print a single report or if you wanted to print the entire school or district, that functionality is now in place.
And so with that I just wanted to point out one extra piece and actually give some
some kudos to Veronica and her staff.
They're hosting a migrant parent conference this weekend in San Francisco, and they invited us to do a presentation on the dashboard.
And unfortunately, none of my staff are certified bilingual, but one of her staff is actually going to do the presentation for us, and Jenny Singh will be there to help respond to any questions in which they'll obviously be translated back into Spanish.
One that we've not gone to in the past and we're pretty excited about.
So with that, we are done with the presentation.
Thank you very much.
So, Cindy, I know that the governor's budget that you commented on is going to do some stakeholder input and update the dashboard.
So my hope is, and I guess I'm interested in the timeline, is the plan to have a bunch of stakeholder group input and then the contractor work and that when the release comes in the fall, it'll come to us for recommended edits and then it'll go out?
Is that the plan?
I don't think we've quite figured out the process.
It's proposed for next fiscal year.
So that is the
What can we do in the current contract to keep this moving along so that by the December release we have a site that has been rebuilt?
We will leverage Paul Richmond's group.
We will leverage the other efforts that are already taking place and start getting this mockup out to begin the conversation.
Our intent would be to get something out with this coming dashboard in 2018.
All right, clerk will call the roll on public comment.
Would the following people please line up.
Doug McRae, Terry Burns, Martha Alvarez, Alfonso Gattagarza, Christy Sinclair, Carrie Roda, DeRay Totten, Sarah Monte, Sheila Whitley, Liz Guillen, Danny Espinosa, Brian Rivas, Elizabeth Robitaille, and Jessica Sacco.
Thank you.
Good morning.
I'm Doug McRae, retired management specialist from Monterey.
I've got two general comments on the evolution of the California dashboard.
First, much of the data contributing to state indicators are either substandard or works in progress.
particularly the academic indicator change data that due to the Smarter Balanced 2017 gain score problem.
I'll have more to say about this problem when you hear the CASP item tomorrow morning.
Secondly, the desire to continually improve each indicator messes with the truism.
Those are technical terms.
The truism that if you want to measure change, then don't change the measure.
California needs to attend to mechanisms that address the problem of changing indicators from year to year.
for the change portion of the dashboard.
For more detail on the agenda materials, more than two pages of observations on nitty gritty detail for plan changes were included in the comments I submitted to your electronic folder late last week.
Thank you.
Good morning, Terry Burns, on behalf of the California School Boards Association.
Regards to the five-year graduation rate, we completely concur with President Kirst.
A lot of things happen in kids' lives and we think it's very important that you acknowledge the five-year graduation rate.
that we show that districts are trying to serve those students and that we put diplomas in their hands to make them economically viable.
As regards to adding a red indicator if districts have not submitted data, we concur with the comments stated by Member Holiday and Member Valdez.
We don't think that the dashboard should be the penalty place.
Have that conversation with that handful of districts.
set up other penalties, have an indicator that says insufficient data reported or collected, whatever the case may be, but don't give them a random red indicator for that.
And finally, as regards to priority six, we're really pleased to see the inclusion of the statutory language on every other year for the surveys that that recognizes both district resources and capacity.
Thank you.
Good morning, Martha Zeregoza-Diaz representing the California Association for Bilingual Education and Californians Together.
First, I'd like to say that we appreciate what is stated in Attachment 3 regarding the data, especially under differentiated assurance, the review of data, and analysis of underlying causes.
which all LEAs should take into consideration when doing their updated LCAPs.
Also, we would like to make sure that the individuals who are going to provide the technical assistance and support, differentiated support, have the expertise and knowledge with regards to services and programs for unduplicated students.
and especially with regards to English learners that they have knowledge of the EL roadmap that was recently approved by the State Board and what are the elements of high quality programs and services.
This is important in order to make sure that the technical assistance and support is appropriate, especially for our English learner students.
Thank you.
Good morning, Elizabeth Robitaille on behalf of the California Charter Schools Association.
We respectfully request that the State Board direct the Department to explore other options for including a five-year grad rate in the dashboard, and we appreciate the comments that you've made this morning about that already.
We ask the State to direct staff to compare the State's tested options to the growth model that the core districts have now refined over a period of multiple years
Also, we ask that modeling be provided to show the impact of various growth model options on charter schools and small school districts.
We feel that the shift from an automatic assignment of orange to red is overly drastic and unwarranted.
Not only does it send misinformation that may not reflect the performance of the school, but it feels premature to make this decision when we have not seen the modeling for how this would impact charters and small school districts and whether a safe harbor methodology would be applied in these circumstances.
And finally, there were a few attachments at the very end that were presented that I don't think are yet publicly available, and we would appreciate being able to see those as well.
Thank you.
Good morning.
I'm Sheila Whitley, and I'm here representing California Teachers Association.
On behalf of California Teachers Association, thank you for continuing your commitment to include school climate as an important piece of the state accountability and continuous improvement system.
And we appreciate the report and the information that was given this morning.
We support the inclusion of data, use, and meaning in the proposed school climate self-reflection tool.
We recommend that the language be even stronger and rather than suggested guiding questions that it needs required elements to be included in all narrative summary responses.
Thank you very much.
Good morning President Kirsten, Superintendent Torlakson, members of the board.
My name is Jessica Sacco representing the California Science Teachers Association.
I'm here to talk about the 2018 dashboard.
Perhaps it'll be the 2019 dashboard because I can't imagine action will be taken on it today.
However, I would like you to consider in future iterations of the dashboard that much as it has been done for chronic absenteeism and the CCI, that a placeholder be put on the dashboard for the science assessment.
In 2016, this board committed to putting the CAST assessment on the dashboard when data was available to be able to be put on the dashboard.
However, we have heard from our members in the field who work at district and county office levels that there is a little bit of doubt in the field that that will actually ever happen.
And as we heard from our presenters this morning that talk about how they utilize the dashboard in their planning process, it becomes very important that they understand what's coming in the future and what future targets they might be expected to meet.
Not just the outcomes that they're looking at right now, but also where they're going.
And we feel that this is critically important to support NGSS implementation.
I just wanted to comment on the presenters this morning at Castro Valley, how much we appreciated their commitment and responsibility for really promoting equity and how that manifests at the local level, and in particular, the connections they were making between the dashboard and their own local data and digging deeper.
what we can do as a State to really support those efforts.
So along those lines, seeing all the work that CDE is doing to try and continually improve the dashboard is really well received.
We know that on this item you have a lot of things before you and that is included in our letter.
The one thing I wanted to note was there was a conversation earlier about the 11th grade assessment and certainly from our perspective and kind of building on Super's comments that the
use in the college and career indicator versus the standalone 11th grade assessment.
Those are being used for different purposes.
They're being used for student level versus LEA.
They're also being used for individual student growth over time, whereas in the CCI, it's really about giving extra points for LEAs for demonstrating time.
So we think that's important to note.
Thank you so much.
President Kirst.
I'm Brian Rebus speaking on behalf of the Education Trust West.
First I want to say we're supporting the funding in the governor's budget for improving and upgrading the dashboard and question whether it's enough.
So please let us know if we can help with that.
We want to make sure that you have the resources to do the job right.
We like the work on the local indicator related to priority seven and access to a broad course of study is, I know all the indicators are important, but we think this one's especially important from an equity point of view.
We would urge you to consider a couple more of what I would say are refinements.
They have to do with adding or linking things to the dashboard.
So we think it would be a good idea to add a link on the dashboard so that the public can access self-reflection tools that the districts use to measure broad course access.
And we also think it'd be helpful to have some data on the dashboard disaggregated by race so that we can all see who's accessing things like A through G. Thank you.
Good morning.
Hi, I'm Liz with public advocates.
I know you received the letter from the equity coalition and it comments on many things.
I want to make sure we thank staff at state board and department for all the hard work they've been doing.
It's pretty amazing.
I want to focus on the priority seven indicator around broad course access.
Appreciate the improvements being made on it but we think that there's an opportunity to make this a hybrid indicator for state data as well as local data and we've made recommendations with a suggestion in our attachment of a mock-up.
and we urge you to have staff work on that, to consider that.
On priority six around school climate, we support the refinement of the evaluation tool.
Again, we think that that indicator should be measured like the other indicators.
I want to highlight that we are working on budget advocacy as well as legislation to try to get more resources to school districts so that they can do these climate surveys on an annual basis and so that everyone is surveyed as well as engagement efforts.
Thank you.
Daniel Espinoza from the Learning Policy Institute.
We thank the board for your commitment to and modeling of continuous improvement within the state's evolving accountability system.
We offer three brief comments today.
First, we support the proposed revision to the school climate self-reflection tool, given the importance of school climate and conditions to students' well-being and academic success.
Examining data on school climate and disaggregated by school and student subgroup can be a key driver of continuous improvement efforts.
Second, we appreciate the inclusion of three new measures of college and career preparedness in the college career indicator.
And similar to many board members comments, we look forward to the inclusion of a well prepared category that can further incentivize both college and career preparation.
Third, we repeat our support for the inclusion of the extended year graduation rates in California's accountability system.
Such a measure is an important lever for equity that over 30 states have included in their accountability systems under ESSA.
Thank you.
Good morning Martha Alvarez on behalf of ACSA, the Association of California School Administrators.
Thanks to all the staff, CDE and State Board for all of the work over the past several months to expand and make our accountability system and dashboard more robust.
With that said, we did provide an extensive letter with comments.
Particularly, we are appreciative of the annual review of our indicators.
Specifically, we'd like to see more conversation and review of the chronic absenteeism and suspension rate definition.
Those comments are in the letter regarding transient students and students who are medically ill and how do we capture them into the data.
Regarding the automatic assignment of a REDD for any schools who do not submit their data on time, we are concerned and would object to the REDD category as it was previously stated by board members.
So we urge the CDE to go back and come up with a different alternative, whether it be fiscally withholding money or any other alternative.
Communicating the dashboard continues to be a challenge just because of the ever-evolving changes being made.
We are willing to partner in working with administrators and make sure that they have the right tools to communicate it.
Self-reflection tools, last comment.
We just want to ensure that it does not become a mini LCAP or additional work for those in the ground.
Thank you.
And with me, I have an administrator to provide additional comments.
Good morning.
President Kerr, Superintendent Torlakson, members of the board, my name is Alfonso Garagarza.
I'm a superintendent principal in wonderful Siskiyou County.
My school is Butteville Union Elementary School District.
I'm pleased to be here on behalf of AXA, small school districts, micro school districts that were formerly also pegged as frontier districts.
That was interesting about 10 years ago.
Administrators, we believe in the opportunity presented by the multiple measures as a system that focuses on teaching the whole child.
A little context, my school enrolls about 202 students.
In addition to myself, we have 12 teachers, 14 classified, 6th grade, all the way up to 6th grade, self-contained classroom, more or less of a 7th and 8th grade departmental setting.
We are, believe it or not, actually a medium-sized district for Siskiyou County and we are proud.
36 to 40% of our student population is on inter-district transfers to our school because of our wonderful teachers, our arts and performing arts programs.
We're sort of a magnet school in that in spite of being 51% free and reduced,
five English language learners.
We have a super strong PTO, strong community and county support.
But what does the dashboard mean to us, to our community and to our stakeholders?
And it's my pleasure to know that or to express to you that, you know, the color coding components are being
I have spoken about this morning with some areas of concern for small school districts in terms of turning red automatically.
And that has to do with some of the metrics that are involved.
If you just look at my EL population, five students, that's 20%.
And if you extend that out to special ed and other significant subgroups, I may have 12 students.
And yet I'm still compared to LA Unified.
So we're looking for an opportunity for you to consider as a board an additional layer of review on those metrics that also assigns a number, a student count, prior to changing any colors or anything like that.
And the fact that the self-reflection tool doesn't turn into a mini L-cap in addition to all that.
My bus driver pulled an elk tag and went hunting for two weeks, and so I'm driving the bus for two weeks.
So I'm not afraid of hard work, but it'd be nice to be able to consolidate and not create additional redundancy.
Thank you very much for your time.
Good morning, LeAngela Reed on behalf of the Small School Districts Association, although I can't be any more articulate than Superintendent Caragaza, but if you want me to explain what pulling an elk tag means, I'm happy to do that.
So I will speak on behalf of the association, Small School Districts Association as a whole.
We do share the concerns echoed relative to the automatic indicator, red to orange, particularly in some of these areas where we're still getting the feel of things.
So I'd like to have a little more time and thought
on that before we make that change.
Relative to the CCIs, as you can imagine, some of us who have worked really hard to get to that end are a little nervous about the fact that it's an OR, but I think the way the documents have been shared, the fact that it's a slash and that we're getting to the end and we're really talking about it always being a mix regardless, and if we continue to have that conversation, I think that will be important as we move forward and finally get to
fully to well prepared.
I want to take a moment to thank C.D.
Easton and particularly Jacqueline for the conversations with small school districts relative to.
Time.
Thank you.
Relative to the self-reflection tool.
Those changes are evident in here.
She took the time to meet with about six superintendents.
It was really wonderful and I think it's reflected well so thank you.
Okay, that concludes the public testimony.
We do have a CDE recommendation for action and maybe one of our liaisons.
I would move the department recommendation to approve the revision to the self-reflection tool for priority six and the proposed standard and self-assessment tool for priority seven.
Second.
Okay, any further board discussion?
If not, all those in favor.
Board discussion.
Board member Williams.
I'm supportive of the of that motion and the recommendation.
This is going to surprise probably most of you that I'm totally supportive of the California Science Teachers Association request that we put a place saver on the dashboard that indicates as
Member Burr made the motion in May 2016 that we would include results of the NGSS state summative test in the state accountability system once it was operational and considered valid.
I know that's years off and it could certainly wait until next year.
But there is a field test, a complete census field test this spring of the NGSS, a summative assessment.
And the next year, if all goes well, it will be operational.
And so knowing for all the field to know that it's coming and that will be reported will provide a really powerful incentive to help with these last years of implementation.
I'm assuming it can't be done this year, but I just want to put it on the table that I support it for next year as soon as it can be done.
the place saver.
I think we're ready for the vote.
All those in favor, raise your hands.
Okay, carries unanimously.
So we're on to item two and this is a no action item and update item and Melanie will lead this and we will start with also with some presentations.
Good morning, President Kerr, Superintendent Torlakson, members of the board.
I am Melanie Sheppy, the Director of the Improvement and Accountability Division.
Item two is intended to be a short information only update on California system of support for local educational agencies and schools.
I will say if I'm short of breath, I don't need medical attention.
I'm just almost seven months pregnant.
So bear with me as I also try to keep the momentum of the item moving.
But I just appreciate being in front of you today to provide this short update.
First, we will highlight some of the work underway to strengthen our level one support for all local educational agencies and schools.
Then we will highlight a partnership approach to differentiated assistance between the Dulce Palos Oro Linda School District, the Merced County Office of Education, and the California Collaborative for Educational Excellence.
Then we'll close for questions.
You'll note that in the posted item, we provided updates on the differentiated assistance process across county offices.
At our May meeting, we will have county superintendents available to speak to those updates.
However, for today's short update, we will focus on one partnership to highlight how multiple support providers can work together to support a district community.
Keep this goal in mind as we discuss the updates today.
Reflect on if the highlighted work is measuring up to our system of supports goal.
Consider if the work focuses on building capacity so that communities can sustain improvement and does it effectively address inequities in student opportunities and outcomes.
Let's dive into updates on support for all local educational agencies and schools.
As I mentioned in January, stakeholders have asked for tools to help them identify successes and strengths across California.
Given your feedback from our January meeting on the GIS tool demonstration, staff has started mapping the performance levels for each indicator across California.
In a few weeks, the public will be able to view districts and schools who have green and blue performance levels by each indicator spatially on a map of California.
We'll also post training materials for how to use that tool.
Another highlight of support for all districts and schools is the ongoing communication about the system of support.
The extended system of support planning group, which now includes the agencies charged with support under the local control funding formula, stakeholder groups representing parents, students, and educators,
and practitioners from the field have worked together to create a resource to clarify topics of importance that have arisen about our new statewide system of support and differentiated assistance.
This is an example of how the state agencies, stakeholders, and practitioners in the field can work together to respond to needs as they surface.
This example is also illustrative of how the extended planning group can get started on a need, make progress, and then come back to reassess what else is needed after completing this initial work together.
Because you and I both know shared communication is only a step in the need to further support stakeholder engagement out in the field.
But it's an important step that this group was able to come together and create.
You'll find that resource in attachment three.
Next, we'll have a brief update on level one resources related to data and evaluation from the California Collaborative for Educational Excellence.
Good morning.
President Kirst, Superintendent Torlakson, honorable members of the board, my name is E. Shryaroo.
I'm the Assistant Director of Training and Outreach for the CCEE.
And as Melanie mentioned at the outset, this is intended to be short, so I have a timer with me.
And although I'll keep it brief, I'm obviously happy to answer any questions you might have at the end.
So we were asked to speak to the modules that we do and to offer a few different comments about the data and evaluation module in particular.
So the purpose of the training modules that the CCEE does is listed there for you.
We're working to establish a common baseline for using the dashboard and LCAP as tools for continuous improvement.
We started that work with large-scale events in fall 2016 and spring 2017 going across the state and holding these in-person sessions.
After a lot of reflection, talking with folks in the field, reviewing surveys, we switched then to a modules-based approach, which is looking at very specific topics.
And the sessions are generally shorter.
So as opposed to these close-to-full-day sessions that were in person before, these modules are often much shorter, and people can access them in lots of different ways.
Here's our attempt to define a module.
It is a professional development opportunity that's focused on some LCFF-related topic of interest.
Like I said, it could be structured in any number of ways.
Many of them have been online, structured like a webinar.
Each module that we have includes those three things.
There's one part that's an overview of the topic for all audiences.
There's a second part, which is designed for some specific audience.
And in all of our modules, we partner with the county office of education.
The role that they play varies a bit, depending on what works best for them.
They often provide input and often support in content development.
And in many cases, they co-facilitate our trainings.
So based on survey results, these were the four topical areas that we focused on for our trainings.
And again, each one of those four bulleted topics includes two parts, one that is designed for all audiences and another that's designed for some particular audience.
As I mentioned at the outset, we wanted to provide just a handful of comments on data and evaluation because I think there was some interest there.
So for part one of data and evaluation, which again is designed for all audiences, we wanted to look at this idea of dashboard literacy.
We knew that some of our trainings provided updates.
We talked about what were some of the updates since spring of 2017 for the dashboard that you might want to know.
And instead of just going into updates, this idea was to dive in deeper to look at specific reports and to go into greater detail generally.
We partnered with Humboldt County Office of Education, and as you can see there, we had our part one session designed for all audiences on February 8th, with approximately 200 virtual participants.
And these were the topics that we addressed in that part one session designed for everybody.
I'll just call out one idea, which is that we consistently received feedback that folks wanted to hear about distance from level three.
and could we explain it in some way that would both allow the participants to understand distance from level three, but also be able to turn around and talk with their constituents, district administrators talking with school administrators, school administrators talking with teachers about distance from level three and making sure that everybody understands it.
You can see then the other topics that we explored as well.
For part two of data and evaluation, so we went from an audience that was inclusive of virtually everyone to an audience that was focused on the needs of small schools and districts.
We have heard so much from small schools and districts that they want to understand how they can best use the dashboard and also how they can use other sources of data to complement the dashboard.
Again, Humboldt County was integral in this work.
They have a number of small LEAs in their community, so it was great to have their insights.
We had another Zoom session this time with approximately 100 participants, and you can see here what we addressed.
I'll zoom in just on that second bullet.
For part two, we looked at an optional protocol that small schools and districts might use if they don't see a performance level on the academic indicator for English language arts and math.
All of the resources from the PowerPoint presentation to the video of the presentation itself to links that we referenced during the presentation can be accessed on our website.
The first link is for part one, which again was designed for all audiences, and the second link there was specifically resources for small districts and schools.
And Melanie, I think I'm good.
All right.
And each will be staying to answer questions at the end, of course.
I'm excited now to switch gears.
So you've just heard a few brief highlights of level one support, support that's available for all districts and schools.
Now we're gonna focus to a highlight on a partnership for differentiated assistance.
Today we'll focus on the partnership between Dos Palos Orlando School District, the Merced County Office of Education, and the California Collaborative for Educational Excellence.
Good morning and welcome, everyone.
Thank you for allowing us to join you.
I'm Socorro Shields, Director of Education for the California Collaborative, with team members here from Merced County Office of Ed and Dos Palos Superintendent, and they'll introduce themselves in just one moment.
As you know, you heard Eash earlier talking about the professional development.
Another effort of the collaborative has been the partnership work, long-term, side-by-side partnership work, really actualizing, giving meaning to whatever this work in continuous improvement looks like for districts in the field.
And to that end, we've been working together with county offices, really thinking about this
time in our accountability system?
What does that look like when all of these things might happen to a district at once, when they're experiencing all of these opportunities?
Does it make sense?
And so we're very proud that with Merced County Office of Education, we've really been able to learn together, plan together.
Will this make sense?
And you'll hear from Dos Palos about their experience and how it felt as a recipient hearing the intention as well.
And when we, I think you've seen this before, but we really talk about kind of what the phases were in our partnership work with all of our districts.
And as you'll recall, they were volunteer districts.
So we believed that some of them might end up in the accountability schema.
We didn't know, they didn't know when they volunteered for this work.
But it really was about kind of putting meat on the bones about what continuous improvement is and how do you support people going through that.
And so this really was about kind of how we got to know the district and then specifically build capacity with the county offices and with the Carnegie Center around what continuous improvement means on the ground for people who are literally doing this improvement work every day.
And so that kind of sets the stage of what our summits look like, and we bring teams together.
We've grown this to include not only the superintendent, but district-level leadership, site-level leadership, and teachers.
So created teams of these districts to come and learn and work together, have these shared learning experiences about what it means, and develop kind of a learning continuum so that they can make meaning together as a team.
of educators about what this means and thankfully county offices have been with us as we're doing these opportunities with districts and so we've been partners the whole time.
I'll let Merced County talk more about kind of how they framed their differentiated assistance work.
Good morning, ladies and gentlemen, the Board, Board President, State Superintendent Francisco Romo from Merced County Office of Education, also Differentiate Assistance member.
In essence, happy to be here and from the Central Valley.
When we think about Differentiate Assistance and the Differentiate Assistance Guide that was provided to county offices, there are very nice resources within that guide.
Within that, you have six steps.
You have the dashboard dive.
You have it looking at the local indicators.
You have an L.A.
self-assessment, a root cause analysis, and an opportunity to do the work a little bit different or a lot different.
Merced County Office of Education, we've been infusing the six Cs from Dr. Michael Folan in our work, in all our networks, the Curriculum Learning Network,
the Categorical English Learner Network, LCAP workshops, and also into the differentiate assistance.
And what that means is intentionally thinking about creativity, communication, citizenship, critical thinking, character, and collaboration.
And what does that look like within this new improvement science, continuous improvement?
So today we'll have one of our districts talk about that partnership and our intentionality about that.
Tomorrow we finish our differentiated assistance with our last of eight school districts.
Wonderful journey.
Within that, also, because the district's requests, those forms have been different.
Three of our districts asked for, can we pair up since we're TK8s together?
So one cohort was a cohort of three of our districts that were TK8.
Another cohort was three other districts from TK-12.
That was at the request of the districts through this journey, because they wanted to live these six Cs.
The other two independently wanted to work individually, so that was the differentiated assistance for them.
So what that said is, I'd like to be able to pass it on to my colleague, Dr. Ozzy De Luna, and then have our district tell their journey.
Thank you, ladies and gentlemen, and State Superintendent.
As we think about the work, there's policies pushing down on schools.
We think about how we work.
The work is, we have structures in place, and we think about how the human dynamic, how people work, how we build trust.
how we build a relationship to ask critical questions of student success.
When we think about the students who may not have access, we need to have that trust and relationship to dig deeper and say, what might work here?
And then how might we transfer that to where the students are failing?
So we ask those questions to see where our beliefs might be, our values, our purpose.
And if we think about our purpose, the student success, it's about how we use our structures to support our adults, to support our schools, to support our students.
And the outcome is the students.
It's how we trust each other in asking those questions that are critical for success.
So Bill?
Good morning, President Kurtz, Superintendent Torlakson, members of the board.
I'm happy to be with you this morning.
I appreciate this opportunity.
My name is Bill Spaulding, and I'm in my second year as superintendent of the Dos Palos Oro Loma Joint Unified School District in Western Merced County.
We're a rural district.
Our community, Dos Palos, is 2.2 square miles.
We have 2,500 students, but 5,300 in the community.
We are a district that covers 600 square miles in rural western Merced County.
We are 90% free and reduced, 28% EL, 78% Latino, a fairly typical Central Valley community, a small town, and a community that is going through some economic transitions, not all good, but dealing with a lot of issues.
When I first came to the school district a couple of years ago, and you might remember me from about a year ago, talking about CCEE, we were invited by our county superintendent at the time to be a part of a pilot with the CCEE.
So, we joined 10 other districts.
and became a pilot district with the CCEE.
And you might remember that we came, Dr. Tietjen, Steve Tietjen came with me last time to talk a little bit about what that experience has been.
More recently, we became a differentiated assistance district in our county, one of eight in the county.
And to be honest with you, when we first got into the pilot program,
We got in because we pretty much anticipated that we were going to meet with differentiated assistance.
Our arc, our trajectory over the last several years, both through CSTs, the old API measure, and then more recently the CASP and the dashboard, really had us struggling in some of our academic areas.
We knew that was going to happen, so we wanted to embrace that rather than dodge it.
We didn't want to wait to be told.
So when I did get the phone call in December from Dr. Tietjen, we were not surprised.
We were aware that this was happening.
And the communication we had done with our board and with our community was, we're getting into this pilot because we want to get better.
We want to get into this pilot because we want to improve.
And we believe that CCEE will learn from our experience, but we will also learn from that.
And if we get in at the ground floor, we could see some early gains and make improvements right away.
So, for us, differentiated assistance has not been a big deal.
Not that it's not important, not that it isn't something that you need to take seriously, but we knew it was coming.
And I know not every district has had that experience, but for us, we did.
We saw it coming, we embraced it, and we feel good about how we're going about it.
I talked a little bit last year about some of our efforts with CCEE.
And we continue to go almost monthly to the CCEE summits.
We've expanded our team at the district to include myself, my assistant superintendent, the president of our teachers association, and a middle school principal.
And with that kind of broad base of representation, I think we represent the district very well and we're able to bring back a lot of what we're learning at CCEE to our district.
Because we have our CTA president involved, we've been able to really work more directly and really get our unions to focus and join with us as we work on our improvement efforts.
The other thing that we've been doing is that we were involved with a CCESA training on the science of improvement.
Both my assistant superintendent and I attended the three sessions.
We got some help from CCE to get us in there.
There weren't that many districts that got to participate, but we did.
What we have found is
We've been able to use first the coherence framework from Dr. Michael Fullan, and then more recently, the science of improvement book that we have from Dr. Mayhew, and really start to implement the science of improvement mindset with our leadership and throughout our district.
I joked the other day when Ozzie and Socorro were in our conference room, we had fish bones all over the place.
And I said, you know, there are more fish bones, there's more fish on the wall here than you'd find in a red lobster.
We're really delving into that process.
Here's the fishbone.
This is looking at PBIS.
The fishbone process, if you're not familiar with it, is a root cause analysis.
It's one of many tools.
that are available through the science of improvement that we wouldn't have known about had we not had that training.
But we were able to start working on that with individual situations and problems and to start to really look at what are our issues and how can we go about working on those issues.
One of the things we try to avoid is something that those of you who have studied this or seen this, called solutionitis.
The desire to jump in, fix the problem.
We're all checkbox people, or most of us, or many of us, I'm a checkbox person.
We checkbox people.
We have a reading problem, let's buy a program.
We didn't like how it worked out this year, let's buy a new one.
We've got another situation with tutoring, let's buy a new tutor.
We don't like that, after a year, let's go to something else.
This has really forced a discipline on us to really look long and hard at our issues,
and to try to determine what are the causes, what are the changes that we can make that can have a high impact long-term, and what are the changes we can make that can have a shorter-term impact, because sometimes you need those short-term wins to start to really move things forward.
So that's one kind of portion of the work that we've been doing and a lot of that has come through our work with the science of improvement training through CCEE and partially through the county.
But what I really want to give the county office credit for is that they've been working with us really all along in a very tight partnership
with CCEE.
We see Socorro at just about every one of our sessions, and we see Ozzie at about every one of our sessions, and we work very closely with Francisco through the whole differentiated assistance process and developing the LCAP revisions that we want to make in support of our improvements.
And so working together, really as a team, and we're working very, very closely together, we've been able to integrate all these kinds of things in a way that have meaning.
And it's really changed the culture of our leadership.
One of the things that we've tried to be very intentional about is developing the capacity for this to grow and for this to be sustained.
I think a lot of times you bring a book study to your leadership, you bring a book study to your district, everybody reads the book.
My friend calls it church camp.
Everybody reads the book, everybody feels good for a while, and then you go on to something else, it becomes a fad.
One of the things that we've been working with Ozzie on from the county office is he comes and works with our leadership team.
We meet once a month and we do some very serious team building and some very serious work, both around the relationships that we have with one another, the relationships of our team, and also around the content of the work that we're doing with this.
And we have really strengthened our district leadership as a team.
that I was joking today, if I were to get hit by a bus on the way back today, this work would go on.
It's not just me.
It's not just a book.
It's not just this year.
It's work that is sustained.
So I guess that was my only picture.
Oh, here's my other picture.
The high-impact, low-impact, high-leverage, low-effort, and high-effort.
These are the quadrants we use to try to take some of those ways of dealing with causes and issues and to determine which ones we can deal with more long-term and which ones we can deal with more short-term to have a high impact and to start making movement.
So we're doing some work around various things.
Like I said, we've done fish bones, we've done empathy interviews, we've looked hard at our PBIS program, you know, around how we're doing with our student support and culture, and we're really delving into our areas of academics and looking hard at our ELA and our mathematics and where the areas that where we need to make growth.
One thing I wanted to add is something that has happened through the differentiated assistance model is very different from what I am used to.
I go back long enough to be able to remember the IAUSP process, the high priority schools process.
I was a date provider for a while, so I inflicted that on some people.
I know that old model.
This is a very different model and it feels very different from our point of view.
So when we went into our first meeting for a deep dive into our dashboard with the county office, I have to say there was a little bit of stress, a little worry, because now we're going to start talking about what's wrong.
and we spent three solid hours and what was really impressive is that my assistant superintendent and I, although we talk every day, we never had three hours ever to sit down and really delve into things in quiet, you know, where the phone's not ringing, where people aren't coming in.
We never had that kind of time.
So now we had the time with the differentiated assistance team at Merced County Office of Ed,
to really delve into our dashboard, look into the tables, look at our groups, look at our CASP scores, look at our trends, look at three-year trends.
We came out with a two-page spreadsheet list of everything that we noticed.
And a lot of things that we noticed were positive.
A lot of things that we noticed through this new dashboard process where we used to get worked up about our English and our math scores and feel bad and feel terrible about what we were doing.
Now we're talking about suspensions.
Now we're talking about chronic absence.
Now we're talking about graduation rates.
Now we're talking about college career.
And there are areas where we're excelling.
There are areas where we have the highest graduation rates in Merced County.
We have the highest ELA scores for 11th grade in Merced County.
Two-thirds of our 11th graders are on the CASP ELA are meeting or exceeding standards.
That's not the story with all of our other grades.
So we were able to do an empathy interview to sit down with our 11th or actually all our high school teachers.
What are you doing?
What's the difference?
What's your secret sauce?
How are you making this happen?
And we learned a lot from that process that we're going to carry out to the remainder of our district.
So, it's not only surfacing the issues and the concerns that you have.
It's not just surfacing the things that aren't going well.
It also surfaces the things that are going well.
And we have a number of things that are.
So, you get a more balanced view.
So, that's been our experience.
It feels very integrated.
It feels very tight.
It feels like there's great integration and cooperation and collaboration between our three entities.
And I couldn't be happier with the process that we've been taking on so far.
Thank you.
Yeah.
So in closing, I want to highlight our next steps.
We'll continue to engage with stakeholders on what's working and what they need.
We'll engage in collaborative feedback with other agencies and organizations.
And we'll also continue to coordinate and align the work of each agency through the expanded system of support planning group.
So we still have all our presenters here, and we would like to close for any questions.
Board member questions.
Board member Strauss.
I want to thank the presenters and Melanie for putting this together.
I know you're tight on time because of the extensive length of this particular day of our agenda, but I think one of the things that as a policy and practitioner, a policymaker and practitioner, I think about is it's great to spend a couple years putting together a policy, but we're really interested in seeing how this does impact, in fact, improvement work for the areas we've identified and how local districts and counties are using this information.
You did say Melanie at the beginning that you were limited today.
All you wanted to highlight and I want to thank the district and the county for coming.
It's really helpful to do the theory to practice connection.
And my understanding is that you have plans for more of this work in May.
I guess I would just say as one voice, I would really like to see a little more time to the next steps in system of support and what we're doing.
what CCEE is learning from their pilots, what the next steps are that counties are doing.
I know we built on Riverside County last time, which was really exemplary in my opinion, and I've heard from other superintendents saying it really helped to raise the bar for people.
So these kind of opportunities to hear how this is making a difference, I think many of us remember many of the different systems that we've been under and trying to illustrate that it is different, but
What are we really doing to impact practice so that things are better for kids and achievement is improving?
So I just would I know you may have some plans for May, but I'd like to spend a little more time on what the next steps are and what the practices are as we continue to refine the system.
Thanks.
Thank you.
So I just want to also express my appreciation.
Superintendent Torlakson and I get to spend our time in our off months hearing what CCEE is doing, so I especially want to thank the CCEE staff for being here to share with the State Board.
It was also really helpful to hear for a second year from Dos Palos and Merced, because we heard kind of at the very beginning.
I really appreciate the superintendent's comments about how that's changed, how the prep work really led to what's happening now.
And just to reinforce, and again, thank you for talking about multiple measures, because this is the second time we've heard this morning from a district about
how valuable that is, both because you get to celebrate successes, you're not just pounded on test scores, but you also get to identify areas of strengths within your district that you can then spread to other parts of your district.
So again, thank you very much, and Melanie, thanks for organizing the presentation.
I think we're ready for public comment.
Will the following individuals please line up at the podium?
Candace Benji, Martha Alvarez, Alfonso Garza, Angela DeRamos, and Liz Guillen.
Hello, my name is Candace Benj, and I am here on behalf of Partners for Each and Every Child, a project of the Opportunity Institute.
I'd like to share recommendations that highlight the need for explicit guidance, especially regarding the complementary and sometimes overlapping roles of the CDE, County Offices of Ed, and the CCEE.
Establishing clarity will ensure that districts and schools receive responsive, high-quality support and maximizes valuable capacity-building resources.
We also want to emphasize the importance of strengthening a meaningful approach to engagement that is central to continuous improvement efforts.
This requires counties, districts, and schools to consider one, representation, two, transparency, three, sustainability, four, collaboration, and five, alignment.
These are further discussed in our materials.
As we shared with the CCEE board last month, Partners for is optimistic about the work to strengthen schools and districts to address their most persistent equity challenges, and we look forward to supporting these efforts.
Good morning, Martha Albers on behalf of AXA.
We provided some comments in our letter regarding the system of support.
We're very grateful for this informational item today.
I just wanted to mention that AXA is continuing to want to partner with the CDE State Board and all other state agencies to communicate the system of support to the field.
We just met with our members in the last couple of weeks, different groups of AXA, and one of them pointed out that when they Google CDE system of support, MTSS always comes up as sort of the Google searches.
So, we want to let the field know there's definitely more than just MTSS as opportunities for them to take advantage of.
We have a lot of ways that we can partner with you.
Just this week, we released a stakeholder Q&A regarding how to incorporate stakeholder engagement in the system of support.
On our EDCAL, it's a publication we have every week, so it went out to more than 10,000 of our members.
We also are willing to do any website, social media, advertisement to really get this information out to the public.
If anything, communication is really key to ensure that the public really knows what system of support and the dashboard means.
Thank you.
Good morning.
Once again, Alfonso Garagarza.
I just wanted to say that data is important to us, especially in small rural school districts where access to data can sometimes be difficult in those resources.
So we very much appreciate free and online resources.
You know, we do our own internal PD, and I regularly share our financials, our first interim, second interim, our LCAP, our dashboard data with our staff, and we use that to inform our decisions and our practice, as all of us should be doing.
And one of the metrics that I'm most proud of right now is looking into how students perceive their school, whether or not they're safe, and incorporate that into our school safety plans.
And so, you know, part of the self-reflection tool in the process was very helpful.
And I just wanted to say, Jayden, I was very impressed with your presentation this morning.
Coming down from the mountains last night at, you know, 1230 at night through rain and storms and everything was kind of tough and it was long ago and I'm not going to be around for, you know, our 17 minutes of silence, but all the reports I got is that they were very respectful.
So know that the students at Butteville Union School District in Siskiyou County stand in solidarity with your leadership.
Thank you.
Good morning, Martha Zaragoza-Diaz representing the California Association for Bilingual Education and Californians Together, and it seems that I jumped the gun.
The comment I realized later when I sat down.
My comments that I made regarding item one really was meant for this item two.
We appreciate the data that's in attachment three, and we also want to make sure that the personnel that provide the technical assistance and designated support
have the expertise and knowledge which regards with regards to services and programs for our unduplicated students and with respect to English learners that they also have the knowledge of the English learner roadmap that was approved by the State Board and what constitutes high quality programs and services for our English learners only in that way can we make sure that the technical assistance or designated differentiated support is appropriate and effective for all students including English learners.
Thank you.
Good morning, my name is Ephraim Mercalla from Children Now.
We continue to appreciate the direction and evolution of the system of support, so we look forward to that.
Some key points to emphasize from our letter on item two, to reinforce what Member Strauss said, we really look forward to the year two planning of this effort and to learn from the CCE pilots as well.
We also like to reinforce the idea of a robust vision for level one supports as we continue to evolve and move along, so we look forward to that.
I also want to applaud the efforts of David Sapp, Melanie Shepp, and Jason Willis on their work for the System of Support Planning Group.
It has been wonderful to work with them.
The communication update was tremendous, and I think that is going to send a very clear signal to the LEAs in the field.
Lastly, we know that local control is central to the California way, and we look forward to supporting that.
Thank you.
Hi, Angela DeRamos representing California Teachers Association and I was really pleased to hear the report, previous report of what this looks like on the ground.
Dos Palos is doing it right.
I can say I just was there giving a PD because they believe in teacher agency over their professional development and part of the process.
And on that I want to speak to attachment three, the addition of giving the responsibility for the stakeholders to the superintendent.
That's an example in Dos Palos of the superintendent doing it right.
But that's not the case in all schools.
They have a different purview.
So I want to emphasize the need to change the language to include all the stakeholders including the teacher,
It's not just in the what happens after, but in the entire process.
Teacher agency matters, and if you don't have buy-in from the teachers, we're not going to have anything.
Thanks.
Liz Guillen with Public Advocates.
We're really pleased with the inclusion of Equity Coalition members in the system of support planning group.
The talking points that came out of those conversations about engagement are really important.
And we think that they clarify that the reflection and the shifts in direction because of the differentiated assistance process really should be part of the changes or lead to the changes in the LCAP in real time and the community stakeholder engagement needs to be part of that reflection.
We also think that if an LEA is in the process of differentiated assistance, that information should be communicated and the dashboard we think is a good place for that.
Data, as we're talking about fiscal transparency, we also know that the transparency of other information really contributes to stronger community engagement.
Thank you.
That concludes item 2, which is not an action item.
And now we're on to item 3, which concerns students with disabilities.
And we do have approval of a recommendation of CDE.
So Kristen Wright, welcome back.
Thank you, President Kurtz, Superintendent, members.
Thank you, Jeffrey.
While this is coming up, I just want to mention that this presentation and this item went to the Advisory Commission on Special Education at their last meeting.
And they have drafted a letter that's coming around to you and that there'll be some in the back as well asking for your support in moving this forward.
So we are enjoying, in the special education world, a great deal of inclusion at the state level.
And your commitment to ensuring that students with disabilities are represented across all elements of our system, I believe, is truly being realized.
And so the trick now is, and then what?
First you're included, and then we have to do something to engage you.
So that's sort of where we are.
And as you know,
Last month we had an update or you passed a motion to approve our federal indicators, APR, which were indicators 1 through 16, the ones that we talked about, including least restrictive environment and assessment and other things.
This one is the part two to that, which is our state systemic improvement plan.
And a few years ago, prior to my time in this role, actually 2013, the Federal Office of Special Education Programs put in place results-driven accountability.
And essentially, they added this indicator in order for states to work on improvement for students with disabilities around outcomes.
So, California, in our wisdom, really used this vehicle in a little bit of a different way than some other states.
Some other states were very narrow in their focus about a specific student group at some specific schools, sometimes even very few schools, where you would do a treatment and then you would see what the result is to measure your outcomes.
California used this as a vehicle to really push the envelope on including special education and students with disabilities in the array of changes that our state was making.
So, I would say that at this point, we're seeing the true realization of that.
We are in phase three, which is our evaluation, implementation and evaluation stage.
And so if you recall, our theory of action was really that if students with disabilities, which were among our LCFF subgroups, if we made our system more coherent and started including students with disabilities in the greater system, that we would start seeing results because they're in the bigger system.
They're not in a separate system.
And as you know from the task force, that was really the cry.
So, I will have Shiloh come up in a minute and talk about the measurement, but let me just say that currently, as you've heard from all of our presentations, special education and students with disabilities are really included across every single aspect of the work that's going on internally, as well as externally with our partners.
So we are in the process now of building our resource array and working in partnership with CCEE and others to make sure that we have a coherent array, sort of it's like all these districts are in this differentiated assistance status.
What do we want to provide as resources at tier one, two, and three?
So we see that as our goal.
We have really moved towards a more coaching to compliance
attitude, and have seen a lot of shifts in our own division in terms of the work that we do and the alignment we are trying to accomplish.
A few things that we have done I would like to point out.
We are continuing to refine our TA contracts, meaning that everything we do is in that vein of the system of support that is aligned.
We are putting a continuous improvement process in all of the activities that we are doing internally.
to point out that we are working hard to align all those indicators that you saw before represent monitoring activities.
All those activities happen throughout the year.
And what we heard from our stakeholders and from LEAs was it would really be helpful if you could give us that information around the same time that we got our dashboard results so we could really use that information to inform our improvement.
And so our data administrator, who you'll hear from in a minute,
She's worked hard with our staff at the CDE and our focus monitoring teams to completely realign all of our timelines so that all that data will be A, more current, and B, will be on the timelines of the dashboard.
So as you know, the system of support, you heard the last presentation, and we've been working closely with our partners within the system of support and are a key member.
So I won't go into what the system of support is, but I'll say that we have aligned to all the same sort of ideologies so that we're very consistent in our messaging.
The theory of action has evolved a bit, so the special education alignment to this larger accountability system will result in benefits and increased instructional opportunities.
I think what we're seeing now is we do have a more
forward-facing commitment and a statewide uniform commitment around more inclusion of students with disabilities and general ed, which in turn will give access to our students to more of our state standards and more depth of our standards to give them more opportunities like we were talking about for a career in college later.
And in terms of our own evaluation, that's what you'll be approving today, if you will.
And that would be that we send this report on to OSEP to let them know the status we're in.
We've been talking to them all along, reporting that we have seen incredible amounts of change and alignment in our system.
I think our dashboard is a really good example of our statewide commitment to be very transparent around how each and every one of our students is doing.
So thank you for that.
So, we had a few evaluation questions that we answered as part of our initial evaluation, and you'll see them, how is the state system of support impacted by the state systemic improvement plan?
Really, these just indicate some of the things I just talked about.
We are cross-cutting with all of these teams, we're doing work with all of these teams, and in turn, my staff in the department is also getting some great training and professional development by working with all of these teams.
In terms of the next question, how students with disabilities are represented in the larger statewide accountability system, I think that speaks for itself.
They're front and center.
And now the question is, what are we going to do about it?
The third question, how has the Special Ed Division changed its practices to align?
I am very proud to say that we have gone under a pretty significant restructuring to really hone our practices so that all the activities we do are incredibly relevant to LEAs and their improvement processes, so that we are not just doing things to monitor someone, we are doing things that are relevant to how they are going to work towards improvement.
Again, our timelines and activities have also been revamped, as well as our TA projects.
I'm going to have Shiloh come up for a minute and just talk about the measurement really quick, and then I'll be back for just a minute to close out, and then we'll ask for your approval to move this forward.
Good morning, board members.
It's still morning.
Thank you so much for having us here.
We will try and be brief, and I did not bring you any boring data to show you right before lunch, because I know you might be getting a little bit hangry.
So I just wanted to talk a little bit about some changes that we made to the ESIP given last year's submission.
And one of the major changes is how we're looking at the state-identified measurable result.
If you remember our first iteration of the ESSIP used assessment scores for students in the three LCFF subgroups who were also students with disabilities as sort of the measurement that we would use.
That was not always our initial choice.
We wanted to use other types of outcomes like suspension expulsion or least restrictive environment.
We were informed by the U.S.
Department of Education that we needed to use a true outcome.
So we were kind of limited to either graduation assessment scores or post-school outcomes.
And because about 600 LEAs are elementary school only LEAs, it made sense to use something that we could use for everyone.
So we looked at the assessment scores for those student groups who were also students with disabilities.
Last year, we looked at some of the stuff that was happening around the LCAPS and the system of support as it was beginning and realized we really just needed it to be for all students.
So if we really were talking about all means all, we were looking at all students with disabilities and really moving the needle that way and how the work that we're doing can make that happen.
So the change that we're implementing this year is when we initially set those targets, we used Kappa data because at the time, CASP data was still in field tests, so we had nothing to benchmark but the Kappa data.
As you're aware, we don't have the Kappa anymore.
So we can't continue to hold the data to targets for data that doesn't exist anymore.
So we changed the targets.
So now the targets are based on the CASP source.
So that's what we're submitting to the U.S.
Department of Education.
So that's what we're looking for your approval with as well.
I also did want to sort of note that part of our alignment, which we've been really excited about, has been a couple of things.
Having students with disabilities represented in the dashboard as a student group, I think, has really helped a lot of the conversations that we have.
When people look at that data, they can really see that broken out.
And we're excited that over the next two years that the special education data, this data for students with disabilities will be moved into the CALPADS data system.
And so that will begin in 2019.
And that alignment will also help ensure that we have really high quality data when we're making these decisions and moving these plans forward.
So what are we going to do moving forward?
So absolutely making sure that we're continued to be engaged in all the activities we currently are.
And it's a very different place to sit, to not have to create things by yourself, but to be working with a group of people and to be part of the conversation from the build, that's exciting.
Also, we will be continuing to increase the expertise of our special education division staff so we can be true experts in technical assistance, as well as doing more training in the field.
Shiloh will be running a series of data boot camps to really work on data quality, especially with the transition coming, so that folks can really understand where their data is coming from in order to inform their practice.
We will continue our work with cross-division teams.
As you know, we have realized a great deal of collaboration among all the CDE directors.
I have not been a CDE director that long, but I do know that there is a deep sense of collaboration and respect among all the division directors and a high level of communication.
We will also be empowering and continue to engage SELPA, which we believe are a great regional resource, and we'll be working with them as part of some regional hub activities so that they can gain expertise and be special education experts in their regions in a variety of places.
Also, we'll be selecting LEAs for performance monitoring using the same methodology for graduation assessment and suspension.
One of the complaints from the LEAs was that we had our own special ed system and targets, and then we had our other system, and what were they supposed to pay attention to?
Again, we'll be coming back to you with some of that.
That's it.
If there's any questions, we're happy to answer them.
Well, this is a really dramatic change.
Really something.
Board member comments.
Is it, you know, quite impressed with a huge change.
Board member Sandoval, who represents us on the Advisory Committee for Special Ed.
Yeah, thank you so much.
This is informative and concise and very helpful and it just describes how this item is basically a plan for increasing the academic achievement or performance of our students with disabilities within a coherent system of support so it all fits together.
I also want to applaud the cross divisional work that's happening because it's really making an impact as you said when you're part of the conversation from the build makes all the difference in the world and
I also want to acknowledge my colleagues on the board for always including students with disabilities in these conversations about accountability and assessment, and it's just a natural part of the work, I think.
So while we've seen incremental progress in several areas, we still have a lot of way to go.
So I want to be sure to mention that.
But this plan moving forward really describes how our statewide system of support in California is going to lead to improved outcomes for our students with disabilities and all students.
So I also want to acknowledge the letter from the Advisory Commission on Special Education.
They're in very strong support.
our approval of this item this plan for submission to the Department of Education so I would move approval of this item for second okay we're gonna have to have public comment so Alfonso Garra Garza
I hope you don't tire of me too quickly, but I'm making it all count.
We are encouraged that the CDE Special Education Division is looking to streamline and align to the extent possible
the activities described in state systemic improvement plan and welcome and support the the greater system alignment as I mentioned previously I did draw a PIR review for participation rate the special ed under the end factor so there are some things there that are concerning and
We have a student who is needed to be sent to the East Coast for educational services to be provided at the cost of what is 50% of our ending fund balance.
So if there could be a consideration for a special considerations piece, I would be happy to look into that.
Thank you.
I hear that kind of example from rural counties frequently and there is a move from the cities and suburbs into the foothills and into the rural areas and the parents bring their special needs kids with them and so the district all of a sudden has two or three students which take a big chunk of their budget.
So it's a need I don't have the answer to it but we need to keep looking for that answer.
Yeah, you can get out of the courtroom.
Because that just gets more expensive, right?
Yeah.
Part of it is that I'm going to look at is, you know, the SELPAs distribute the money in California.
And nobody really knows where the, how they can, there's no add up of how they calculate that and it's pretty much of a mystery to me as a school finance expert, how the money goes from place to place and what criteria they're using.
So, at some point it would be interesting to look at, you know, how the self was splitting up the money.
Maybe they can do nothing but I, in,
meeting with a small school district's association, there were wildly different policies between SELPAs for small schools.
There was no uniform state policy, and we don't really have a vehicle to have a uniform state policy.
So I know there's some bills before the legislature this year to look into this.
PPIC had a report on this as well.
So these issues are part of a larger systemic finance issue that has yet really to be overhauled.
All right, we have a motion, and I think we're then ready for a vote.
All those in favor?
All right, that carries.
Thank you.
So our lunches are ready.
And we'll take a small break now and reconvene at 5 after 12.
OK, the state board will reconvene.
And we're going to take up item four, which is the federal ESSA plan.
And before we begin with the presentation by Marguerite, I wanted to paint a little bit of the picture here as I see it.
First, I want to assure everyone that is aware of the item addendum.
where we, due to the timing of the posting of the addendum, we have modified the CDE recommendation to delay a vote on some of the crucial items of ESSA until an additional meeting that we will have within a month.
Board members got a sheet of what we were going to be deciding today.
and it is called handout and it says handout.
It says State Board Meeting March 14th and it has the items we will be acting on today, the disproportionate rates of access to educators, Title III Part Sub A, English Language Acquisition and Language Enhancement, Entrance and Exit procedures,
and issues concerning the McKinney-Vento Homeless Assistance Act.
Held over then are most of the meatier items, status and change, indicator-specific issues,
measurements of interim progress, weighting of indicators, school identification, exit criteria, and the size of numbers.
So that will encompass the meeting today.
The additional meeting, we have been negotiating
with the U.S.
Department of Education and really appreciate their response in a professional and collaborative and open way to try and get the yes in these issues.
We have striven at every turn to align the federal ESSA with the state plan and our LCFF and other state policies and we believe we have accomplished that.
In that regard, our staff and the CDE spent over five hours one day in discussion with the U.S.
Department, and we've had several discussions after that.
I think we have, as Margarita mentioned, I think we have gotten to the point where we
an agreement with the U.S.
Department, which is necessary to have an approved plan for the ESSA by the Department of Education.
So we've come a long way.
We ran out of time.
to get this posted early because of the discussions that were still going on.
It takes a while to go back and forth and get sign-off from U.S.
Department officials and NRFs to rewrite it.
So it became clear from the start that the U.S.
Education Department
has a narrower reading of the law than we have had in our prior deliberations and discussions.
And they had used these definitions to approve other state plans and we were not open to revisiting what they saw as the correct legal interpretation.
The U.S.
Department of Education is sticking very close to the statute.
As you may recall, the Congress killed the proposed regulations of the Obama administration, so they are really basing, at the Washington level, everything pretty much on the statute.
I think that, as you'll see if you read what was posted yesterday, state priorities and policy directions lead the plan that has been negotiated with them.
The multiple measures dashboard and others are really crucial and preserved.
We believe we can create a coherent system that avoids the complexities of separate state and federal accountability structures.
That being said, we still have the opportunity to pursue waivers during this process, and the burden of proof is much changed through ESSA on the
The U.S.
Department of Education showing reasons why they can't approve your waivers.
Under the older version of Congress, it was the other way around.
The burden of proof was on the state proposing the waivers.
So we can use this added meeting to talk about all the issues.
We can talk about the implementation implications of what has been negotiated.
We can talk about waivers and what we should be waiving, asking to waive at that time as well, as well as waivers in the future.
So let's have the CDE complete their presentation.
and then we'll use our procedure of asking clarifying questions to CDE and then we will move on to public comment.
So let's begin and Marguerite will start with a formal presentation by the department.
Good afternoon, President Kirst, Superintendent Torlakson, and members of the board.
I'm Marguerite Reese, CDE's Federal Policy Liaison in the Government Affairs Division.
As President Kirst just indicated in his opening remarks, I will provide information related to item four, update on the development of the California State Plan for the Every Student Succeeds Act, approval of the revisions to the state plan for resubmission to the U.S.
Department of Education.
As the board takes an additional look at California's ESSA Consolidated State Plan, I will spend just a few moments reiterating the foundational elements of the Every Student Succeeds Act, the reauthorization of the Elementary and Secondary Education Act, or ESEA.
ESSA maintains the original purpose of ESEA, equal opportunity for all students.
This act ensures that disadvantaged and high-need students receive the same educational opportunities as their peers.
A hallmark of the 2015 reauthorization is the increased emphasis on local control.
ESSA grants much more authority to states than under its predecessor, No Child Left Behind.
ESSA funds comprise roughly 3% of California's education budget.
California's total kindergarten through 12th grade funding for the 2017-18 year and California Budget Act is $92.5 billion.
State funds are $55.4 billion, local funds are $29 billion, and federal funds are $8.1 billion.
And California's ESSA allocation is a portion of that federal $8.1 billion, approximately $2.8 billion.
In the years prior to the reauthorization of ESEA, California embarked on an overhaul of its public education system.
New standards, frameworks, and instructional materials were developed and adopted, a corresponding assessment system was implemented, and California's new accountability and continuous improvement system rooted in the local control funding formula and local control accountability plans was rolled out across the state.
In many ways, the principles of the Every Student Succeeds Act complement California's efforts to increase our resources and attention on continuous improvement for all student groups.
California continues to be committed to ensuring the ESSA Consolidated State Plan simultaneously meets the federal requirements while allowing for the full implementation of the Local Control Funding Formula.
The State Plan submitted in September 2017, January 2018, and the proposed revisions provided for the Board's consideration today each outline the steps taken to develop an integrated state, federal, and local accountability system.
As previously indicated, the work to integrate the revised federal requirements are grounded in the principles of LCFF, which empowers local communities to make local decisions to address local needs.
Throughout the plan development process, the board and the majority of stakeholders have been in agreement on that point.
And letters to the board for this item today reiterated this foundational belief.
Following the action taken to approve the ESSA Consolidated State Plan at the September 2017 State Board of Education meeting, California submitted its application on the 15th of September of last year.
Peer reviews took place in late October and early November for just three sections, Title I, Title III, and McKinney-Vento Assistance for Homeless Youth.
From the date of submission, the U.S.
Department of Education had 120 days to review state's plans.
In late December 2017, staff from the State Board of Education and the California Department of Education participated in a conference call with staff from the U.S.
Department of Education, or ED, in order to review ED's interim feedback letter.
Prior to the January State Board meeting, the CD hosted a public in-person and webinar meeting related to the proposed revisions to the state plan from the accountability sections on January 9th.
Staff walked through the areas of feedback from the U.S.
Department of Education and described the proposed modifications to California State Plan for approximately 100 meeting participants.
During the January State Board meeting, CDE staff presented to the State Board a revised version of the State Plan based on the content of the Interim Feedback Letter from ED.
The SBE discussed and approved the revised ESSA state plan for submission to ED with the revision to replace the proposal related to the identification of the lowest performing schools with revised language indicating that the State Board would consider a proposed state plan supplement at its March 2018 meeting for submission to ED that further described the approach.
As you will recall, states were permitted to submit their ESSA state plans in either April or September of last year.
As of today, the Secretary of Education has approved 35 state plans.
16 states and the District of Columbia submitted their plans as part of the April submission window, and all but one of those states, Colorado, has been approved.
Another 34 states turned in their plans this fall.
Thus far, 13 of the September states and territories have been approved.
It is worth noting that no states were immediately approved upon submission.
All received at least one round of feedback.
California's approach is somewhat different than those recently approved September submission states and that the state board weighs in on each draft of the state plan.
Throughout the state plan development process, the State Board and CDE have worked together on what has been a highly collaborative development process shared by our two agencies.
Following the January State Board meeting, the SBE and CDE staff came together and worked in partnership to find ways to seek final plan approval that continued to honor the tenets of LCFF while also moving expeditiously in order to shift California's focus towards implementation.
Through conversations both with approved states and pending states, we learned that most had gone through multiple rounds of back and forth with ED in order to tentatively agree on a provable language in their respective state plans before providing a formal resubmission.
With this information in hand, staff members from the State Board and CDE reached out to the U.S.
Department of Education, and a small delegation traveled to Washington, D.C.
in late February to discuss the outstanding areas of feedback from the U.S.
Department of Education related to the January resubmission version of the state plan.
The California team included Karen Staff-Walters, Executive Director of the State Board, David Sapp, Deputy Policy Director and Assistant Legal Counsel, State Board, Glenn Price, Chief Deputy, State Superintendent of Public Instruction, CDE, and Cindy Kazanas, Director, Analysis, Measurement, and Accountability Reporting Division, CDE.
Staff met with Jason Botel, who has one of the longest titles I've ever come across.
Principal, Deputy, Assistant Secretary delegated the authority to perform the functions and duties of the Assistant Secretary of Elementary and Secondary Education, as well as other senior officials from the US Department of Education, for approximately six hours during their in-person meeting and through many
You know, I've had the pleasure of meeting Mr. Botel, but have not received a business card.
So I'm sure he'd be happy to share one.
I'll find out for you.
Let's see, so they met together for approximately six hours and continued conversations for the days and weeks leading up, frankly, just until yesterday.
Over the course of multiple conversations, officials from the U.S.
Department of Education indicated they were willing to explore innovative approaches for the implementation of ESSA related to the remaining areas of concern, but only within their arguably narrow reading of the federal statute.
Staff from the federal and state agencies worked together for weeks and discussed potential language that would both meet Ed's interpretation of federal statute and continue to align with the California way.
Based on the conversations with staff from the U.S.
Department of Education over the last several weeks, the CDE proposes to make further revisions to the State Plan.
The proposed revisions maintain the core principles of California's approach to accountability and continuous improvement, which is based in the LCFF and reflects the extensive stakeholder input received over the last several years.
Many of the changes are technical in nature.
However, some substantive changes are necessary to address ED's interpretation of several ESSA provisions.
The proposed language in the item reflects the changes the CD believes need to be made in order to have an approvable plan.
Based on our conversations with ED staff, the CD is confident that if the Board ultimately adopts these revisions, the Secretary will approve the plan.
And in order to complete the review of the timeline, on March 2nd, 2018, the State Board published the board item related to the proposed revisions for your meeting today.
Although both the State Board and CDE shared the goal of posting a complete state plan inclusive of all of the revised sections, ongoing conversations with ED prevented us from publishing a full proposed and revised state plan until earlier this week.
In order to provide as much information to the public as possible prior to today's board meeting, the CDE hosted an ESSA accountability stakeholder meeting on March 7th to review the proposed changes to the state plan, and nearly 70 participants participated in that webinar.
Given the State Board and CDE's desire to have a transparent and open plan development process with stakeholders and the public, the CDE will present three sections for the Board's consideration today.
The formal recommendation will follow on subsequent slides.
The remaining items, inclusive of the Title I accountability sections, Section A of the State Plan Template,
will be presented to the board at an upcoming state board of education additional meeting.
The additional meeting will take place within the next month and this extra time will allow for additional dialogue and will honor the requests for multiple stakeholder organizations to postpone the full board discussion on this item.
This extra time will also permit staff to collect questions received feedback from the comments letters and use the information to inform
the presentation of the additional meeting to the State Board.
The CD also plans to host an ESSA stakeholder webinar about one week prior to the additional State Board meeting.
So here is your formal recommendation.
The CD recommends that the State Board approve the revisions to sections A.5, E.1,
and I.7G of the State Plan pending the State Board of Education Executive Director approval of final revisions requested by the State Board of Education and correction of any typographical errors.
The CDE further recommends that the State Board consider further proposed revisions to Section A of the State Plan at an additional meeting.
Provided for the board today, as well as for the public, is a handout articulating the sections of the state plan the board will consider over the course of two meetings.
The left column of this slide, as well as the handout, refer to those items that the board will discuss and potentially take action on today.
And the information on the right column references those items for consideration at an upcoming additional meeting.
The handout also cross-references item numbers from the U.S.
Department of Education's February 14 resubmission elements found in attachment 3 of your board item.
So to reiterate, today the board will consider disproportionate rates of access to educators, Title III, Part A, Subpart 1, English Language Acquisition and Language Enhancement, Entrance and Exit Procedures, and finally, Title VII, Subtitle B, Education for Homeless Children and Youth Program, McKinney-Vento Homeless Assistance from Counselors.
And during the additional meeting, the board will consider the sections related to Title I, Accountability, Status and Long
excuse me, status and change, which are inclusive of long-term goals and indicators, and also include the academic achievement, graduation rate, English language proficiency, and other academic and school quality or success indicators, indicator-specific issues, which include the college, career, and English language proficiency indicators, measurements of interim progress, weighing of indicators, school identification, exit criteria, and end size.
There are three attachments and two addenda related to this item today.
Attachments one and two provide identical content, but are displayed for the board using two different formats.
State and federal agencies must comply with section 508 of the Rehabilitation Act of 1973, which in part requires documents and other public resources provided by public agencies to be accessible for individuals with disabilities.
Attachment 1 displays the proposed revisions to California's ESSA State Plan in a format compliant with Section 508.
Double brackets indicating the modifications delineate additions, changes, and deletions.
Again, Attachment 2 includes the proposed revisions to California's ESSA State Plan displayed using Microsoft Word Track Changes formatting.
The forwarding in Attachment 2 is the method in which the U.S.
Department of Education has requested that revisions to State Plans be resubmitted.
Attachment 3 includes a matrix of ED's resubmission elements cross-referenced with the page numbers from California's ESSA State Plans.
The first column numbers the areas of feedback from ED.
The second column lists the ESSA State Plan section.
The third column includes the direct feedback from ED's February 14, 2018
resubmission elements, the fourth column displays the page numbers from Attachment 1, the 508 version, and the final column shows the cross-reference page numbers from Attachment 2, the Track Changes version.
Addendum 1 includes proposed revisions to the sections of the State Plan related to the weighing of indicators and school identification, as well as proposed revisions to two sections that were inadvertently excluded from Attachments 1 and 2.
The second addendum provides additional data tables that will be submitted in the proposed revised state plan, including the baseline data for the grade 11 academic indicator and the English learner progress indicator.
So finally, we're getting to the meat of the item.
The following slide highlights the areas of feedback identified by the U.S.
Department of Education that are included in today's revised board item.
All other areas of feedback will be incorporated into staff presentations at the additional meeting.
So disproportionate rates of access to educators, which is as a state plan section A5 and is included in attachment three as number 19.
The CDE recommends that the state plan be updated to include a number of steps outlined in section 8.5 to ensure that low income and minority children enrolled in schools assisted under title one part A are not served at disproportionate rates by ineffective out of field or inexperienced teachers beyond the evaluation and public reporting of equity gaps.
The statutory provision requiring local educational agencies, or LEAs, to submit an annual plan to the state education agency that describes how it will identify and address any disparities that result in low-income students and minority students being taught at higher rates than other students by ineffective, inexperienced, or out-of-field teachers will be required to be completed in the revised LCAP amendment beginning in the 2018-19 school year.
If the LEA's response is insufficient, California will return the LCAP addendum with suggestions for ways to sustain the LEA's response.
Further, this section will be updated to act able to provide the most recent year of analyzed teacher data disaggregated by Title I schools.
Title 3, Part A, Subpart 1, English Language Acquisition and Language Enhancement Entrance and Exit Procedures.
This is ESSA State Plan Section E1 and is included as Item Number 22 in Attachment 3.
The CD suggests that this section of the state plan be supplemented to add three additional details of the timeline to be undertaken to standardize English learner entrance and exit criteria for English learners in California, including one, the adoption by the State Board of Education of a new English language proficiency assessment for California reclassification criteria, two, the development of the standardized language observation tool and parent involvement protocol, and three,
work with the state legislature to begin to change the reclassification criteria in California statute.
Finally, Title VII, Subtitle B, Education for Homeless Children and Youth Program, McKinney-Vento Homeless Assistance Act, Assistance from Counselors, S.S.
State Plan Section 1.7G, and Number 24 of Attachment 3.
Based on the feedback from the U.S.
Department of Education, the CD suggests that this revised state plan clarify and describe how homeless youths will receive specific assistance from counselors to advise such youths and prepare and improve the readiness of homeless youth for college.
We're back at the recommendation.
I'm happy to read it for you again, but I'll leave it up as a slide for your consideration while I turn it back over to President Kirst.
Thank you.
So this is a time for technical questions.
We have more time on our agenda than I think is indicated.
Viewing the audience, we're not going to have a tremendous number of speakers.
So this is a chance for the board to pursue some of the understandings in advance of the additional meeting as well as to what has happened here and what has transpired.
I've seen some articles that say that we were unable to preserve the single line system, and I don't think the people saying that understand how this is going to work and all the details that are related to that.
We can continue to provide some information for Federal purposes, but still provide the same information we always were.
using for our dashboard and other things of that sort.
So, it's not entirely an either-or situation.
So, with that, let me open it up for board questions and I think the floor is open for anything you want to ask in addition to the items we have for approval today.
So, Board Member Burr and then Board Member LaCon.
So I have really kind of a process question, because as I understand it, the pieces attached to accountability, we want to defer to the additional meeting, right?
Okay.
So at least in conversations that we had initially, there was discussion, and this may be a question actually for Carrick, but maybe you can answer it, Marguerite.
about, it seemed to me there was the understanding from the Federal Department of Education that we had to have an approved plan before we could submit a waiver, which seems opposite of what we've done in the past where we asked for waivers from statute.
And it won't surprise anybody here, there are several provisions that I would like to have waived.
So I just want to understand that process.
What is that accurate?
Is that legally the process that we have to have an approved plan before we can submit a waiver?
And if so, on what basis given how we've acted in the past?
Sure, so I'll do my best to answer and of course my colleagues can join me.
Frankly, in the in-person meeting with the U.S.
Department of Education, I think it's fair to characterize that the first hour was a little rocky.
And so, both state board and CDE staff at that point said, okay, well then,
maybe we can't come to agreement, then California will submit waivers on these subjects.
And the State Board said, or excuse me, not the State Board, the U.S.
Department of Education said, wait, hold on, we will not even entertain conversations related to waivers until California has submitted an approvable plan.
Which, in another way to say, is California needs to modify your proposals in order, in their eyes, to be fully compliant with federal statute
And then we can talk about doing things that may be different through a waiver.
So my question is, is that legal?
I can say, especially if you're having a very difficult conversation and in a fit of pique, say, we're only going to operate this way, that's different than what the actual legal process is for asking for a waiver.
Good afternoon, David Sapp, Deputy Policy Director and Assistant Legal Counsel for the State Board of Education.
Since that's a legal question, as counsel, I will do my best to try to address it.
So, I'll try to quickly summarize what the SS statute itself says, and focus there, and then sort of can answer any follow-up questions.
There are a couple of provisions in the federal law that specifically address the state plan approval process.
And so the first of those has to do with the actual provision that requires states to submit state plans.
That's ESSA section 1111 for those following along at home.
But the first part of that section talks about the requirement to submit plans.
And specifically it says that states who desire to receive a grant under, this is title one, must submit a plan for approval.
It specifically grants the secretary authority, actually requires the secretary to approve the plan and grants the secretary authority to disapprove plans if she determines that the state plan fails to meet the requirements of the section.
So it's an explicit sort of provision that to approve a plan she needs to determine that it doesn't meet the requirements.
The second part of that section that's relevant here is the statute also expressly authorizes the Secretary to withhold state funds if the state fails to meet any of the requirements of this section.
So that's the question about being able to withhold funds if the state plan essentially doesn't meet the requirements of the statute.
There's a second or separate section of the federal law.
It's much later in the statute that actually expressly describes the procedures for state plan approval.
That's SS section 8014.
And that lays out essentially the standard that the secretary applies.
And the language there in reviewing the plans on the front end is that the plan is not in compliance in whole or in part with the relevant provisions of the section that I was just discussing, which lays out the requirements of state plans.
And if the secretary finds or disapproves a plan based on that standard, there's a hearing process that's laid out in statute.
It has specific timelines.
The secretary has to notify states in writing, has to hold a hearing, but ultimately at the end of that process, the secretary still determines whether the plan is approvable and it's the same standard.
It is whether it meets the requirements of the relevant statutory provision under the state plan.
So those two provisions together have to do with whether the plan meets the legal requirements of the statute.
There's a separate statute that addresses the waiver authority under the federal law.
And I believe, Member Burr, that's the question that you were asking.
And that authority specifically authorizes waivers of statutory or regulatory requirements.
That's section 8401 of ESSA.
So, it applies specifically to statute or to regulations that are under the federal law.
The issue is that the timeline for waiver requests is actually more extended.
Essentially, the secretary could not approve the plan unless the submitted plan meets their interpretation of what the state plan law requires.
And so the question of whether we can have an approved plan, unless the plan meets the specific reading of the statute that they're applying in the review of the plan, I believe my understanding of the discussion with the U.S.
Department of Education is they won't approve a state plan if it is contingent upon receiving a waiver.
So essentially the plan has to be submitted and address their reading of the statute in order to be approved.
because this is like a chicken and egg conversation to me, that what if we say initially, and I'm just speaking on my behalf obviously, that we want to ask for a waiver from a statute before we ever submit a plan?
Don't they have to act on the waiver?
The overall, I mean, if I heard what you said about general waiver authority, and I don't want to put you on the spot here, Dave, but I do think that when we get ready prior to having this additional meeting or whatever we're calling it, we need to know what our options are and what the timeline is for those options.
And I also think we also, and I appreciate Marguerite saying this, but I would really call people's attention to the fiscal analysis of this report, of this item, because again, we're talking about an overall investment of state and federal money that is 10 times more than what the feds are doing.
And if we're ever in a tail-wagging-the-dog situation, we have been there from the get-go on this ESSA thing.
And now we're getting down to brass tacks.
So I just think we need to know what all of the options are in the event we want to go in a direction that says, no, we think this needs to happen in order to preserve our state accountability system as we've been building it for the last three or four years.
I'll do my best to try to address quickly, and I think we can do further analysis and try to lay it out more thoroughly in advance of the next meeting.
But I think ultimately, it's more a question of, it doesn't make a practical difference, candidly, because in order to approve the plan, the plan needs to meet the statutory requirements.
So, holding off on submission of the plan until a waiver is submitted and ruled upon.
If the waiver is denied, it would still be in the same place as if submitted an improvable plan and then pursued a waiver which was subsequently denied, except we would have an approved state plan and the receipt of funds would be guaranteed.
So I think the short answer to the question is ultimately the standard for review and approval is the same for the initial submission of the state plan and to the extent there's a hearing.
The same is true for the waiver authority.
It has the same standard for the initial review.
There is a right to a hearing.
It's actually a longer, the period of time from start to finish is a little bit longer than it would be for plan approval, but it's ultimately the same standard and ultimately from the secretary's discretion under both.
but I think that's something that we can, you know, take back and try to lay out a little more concisely in advance of the next meeting.
Okay, while you're doing that analysis, Mr. Sapp, I'd like you to, what are the, as I understand the waiver statute part of ESSA, the Secretary must respond in a certain amount of time
So I'm trying to understand the downside of, you know, submitting a waiver a month later after the plan or to, you know, we're going to, we're going to meet approximately sometime in April.
So the state plan would go in, in April.
we have a board meeting again in May, we might be able to get approval of the submittal we did in April by our board meeting.
We could submit the waiver then.
So I want you in your analysis to consider whether this is, you know, if we have to go with submitting the plan and then the waiver,
given that we're having an additional meeting, what, you know, what, how quickly could the turnaround happen?
How quickly must the Secretary respond?
I remember she has a, you know, there's a period of time.
It's a, the Secretary has 120 days to respond to a waiver request.
And what would that deadline then do to our,
anything we would possibly take action on within that 120 days.
I'm trying to see if there's any real problem here with, of acting since we're, you know, we are doing an additional meeting and so on.
So if you could include that in your analysis, I would find that useful.
Okay, Board Member Ortiz-Lacombe.
State Superintendent wants to...
I was just going to say in addition to the analysis you just asked for, Mr. President, my staff could work with the board staff and just how much money, how much federal money is at risk under any of these scenarios and what's the time flow of the dollars?
Can they turn the faucet off at a certain point if certain steps haven't been followed that they think must be followed?
And if so, what consequence is that to cash flow to the programs and the students supported?
OK, I had Ortiz-Lacombe.
Oh, OK.
OK, Board Member Crocker.
Thank you very much, Board Member Lee Cohn.
David, I noticed that in giving the explanation about the sections in ESSA concerning the approval of the plan, I also have read that statute and I know that there are 15 specific statements concerning the waiver process on limiting the Secretary's authority and behavior
in approving waivers and one of those statements explicitly states the secretary cannot establish preconditions or conditions for considering or approving a waiver.
If what I understand you just articulated the secretary articulated a condition for considering or approving a waiver that's beyond her authority in the statute.
So I'm always reluctant to try to characterize what other people meant in a conversation or what we heard them say.
I would just go back to what I described in looking at the statute, which is the secretary is not
The secretary is not authorized essentially to approve a plan if she determines it does not meet their reading of the statute.
I understand.
So I think the one thing under the statutory structure is that if we submit a plan that is contingent on approval of a waiver, I think that there is very clear basis to say we're not approving your plan because it doesn't meet our reading of the statutory requirement.
So, you know, I think we can follow up and have further conversation to try to clarify this.
But I think rather than sort of focusing on on that issue, I think the timing and what the practical implications is something that we can work on trying to bring back to the board prior to the next meeting.
Okay, so the only comment I'm going to end with at this point in the conversation is I want to understand what the priority of the state is.
Is it to approve the plan for the purposes of making sure the funding continues or is it to make sure that the state has the opportunity to exercise all the flexibility that the Congress intended when they crafted the revision
of No Child Left Behind and got ESSA signed into law.
Because the flexibility that I'm hearing is more a one-size-fits-all interpretation and not true flexibility that states are supposed to be allowed to exercise.
So I want to understand the purpose of what we're trying to accomplish with doing the revision.
Simply crafting a plan that gets approved or doing the innovation that we thought we were being allowed to write into the plan.
because I'm happy to know which way we're going because that will either limit or define how I consider what it is the department is asking for us to approve.
I would consider it to be both of those things.
I don't think California can really truly move forward with implementation of any of the provisions of the final version of the state plan until we have an approved plan and we are assured that funding will continue.
It's our understanding at this point, and I know we'll certainly clarify before your next meeting,
that if California and the board chooses to submit waivers at a subsequent point that that will allow for some of the flexibility that we were hoping for.
Yeah, let me add to that.
We have over $100 million in set-asides, which this board has not discussed.
And these set-asides are under the federal law.
We must withhold 7%, which is over $100 million alone of Title I.
It would be very good if we could get on with deciding how we will use that assistance money.
So the longer we delay, the longer I think we delay that, the discussion on the assistance money, which is something that at some point we will, we will want to deal with.
Board member Ortiz-Lacombe.
so please be advised that board member Burr and I did hug it out before this item and we will be good we'll be good because believe it or not there are I'm also tempted to use the W the waiver pathway for some of these recommendations and the questions I have a process question and then I know that we're gonna come back for a meeting on title one part a which is really the heart of what I've been most interested in but
We can adopt or approve a plan and then internally have a motion that says we will pursue a waiver for this section and this section without including the waiver language in the plan, correct?
I'll confer with Council, but I believe the answer is yes.
I actually do like some of the recommendations and some of the things that are being proposed like moving the 11th grade data to our dashboard.
I think the reason some folks are wondering are we moving into a dual accountability system, I think that's a fair question to ask because in the
in the many, many documents that we receive for item four at various times within a two-week span, we keep on hearing this phrase that almost sounds like a caveat, for the purpose of the ESSA plan, for the purpose of the ESSA plan.
And I myself was wondering, are we having these two dashboards, one with just status, one with status and change?
It is confusing.
And if we did commit to a one system of accountability,
I do think it is possible to still have that one system of accountability, but I do want us to consider some of the things that were proposed, such as the 11th grade.
If we're going to come back for that, currently we're looking at the cut scores based on third through eighth grade.
And if we recall back last year, a year and a half ago, we looked at the data and for the lower grades, we see that math is up and ELA is down.
In high school, ELA is up and math is down.
So we should be looking at data based on actual data, not setting cut scores for 11th grade based on the lower grades because the data is trending differently.
So if we are moving in that direction, I would like to see some actual data when we come back in April.
and in terms of the I'll just I know that we're coming back to this but I do want to pitch it out there we do I would like us to consider waivers on things like the EOP indicator for sure and I it took me a while but I am warming up to the status plus change I think that it is important for us to keep one methodology that is consistent and but also incorporate the
11th grade into the data dashboard and those interim growth targets.
Thank you, baby step, but it finally puts it out there.
And the data and the gaps are daunting, but they are, right?
Jorge Aguilar spoke recently and he said that data humanizes education because the common denominator are students.
Those tables humanize the need and they humanize our students and it speaks to why we need to really set those targets and not in an LEA report card because when we're talking about one system of accountability, we're looking at the LCAP, the LCAP addendum, and then the consolidated application, not the report card.
So if we're going to put it out there and express the need, then let's follow our principles of equity, transparency, and continuous improvement and keep it together, one system of accountability.
Thank you.
The type of information that incorporates into our presentation at the additional meeting.
Board Member Holliday.
I agree with Member Lutiz in the notion that perhaps submitting and having approval of a plan would allow us then to have a waiver process come after that.
And I certainly agree that the EOP is one area where I think a waiver is probably going to be really necessary.
However, I am much I guess I'm much more pragmatic about this whole thing in the sense that it is a lot of money and we do not want to disrupt the flow of that money.
It is important to the state.
Yes, it's a small percentage compared to the California contribution, but at the same time, it's important money.
I think we do need to move ahead, you know, without too many delays in order to get a plan approved and to get this behind us, if you will.
I don't think that
It really is an indication of two different accountability plans.
When we stick to our dashboard and the data and the approach that we use and how we display it is the California way.
If a part of that data, the status part, for example, is then sent to the federal government, I don't see that as a conflict.
I don't see that, you know, we're sending one piece, we're not sending it in the exact same way it appears on our dashboard.
So, I can live with the changes for the most part.
I do agree about waivers for the LP.
There are a couple other things, but in general, I think we need to keep pushing on with this.
Marguerite, do you have any comment on his comments?
No.
OK.
We'll incorporate them into our presentation.
Pardon?
We'll incorporate them into our presentation for the additional meeting.
All right.
Who's next?
That's it.
OK.
Public comment.
There are 20 people signed up for public comment.
Will the following individuals please step forward to the podium?
Leticia Garcia, Doug McRae, Terry Burns, Martha Alvarez, Alfonso Garza, Michael Flores Castaneda, Ken Burt, Mumi Citron, Angela Duramos, Sheila Whitley, Enrique Raucho, and Liz Guillen.
Please come forward, yes.
Hi, good afternoon.
Leticia Garcia on behalf of Riverside County Office of Education.
So basically your conversation here has reflected the conversation that we've been having with our local experts.
So on behalf of educational experts in Riverside County, we urge you to reject the proposed SSA plan
Instead, seek a waiver from the U.S.
Department of Education and stay true to California's accountability system that is based on multiple measures and continuous improvement.
The proposed changes would create a bifurcated accountability system, one based on improvement at the State level and at the Federal level based on proficiency, decoupling status from change
leaves us with a system solely focused on proficiency, which tends to become over-reliant on test scores.
Over the last decade, California has embraced innovation with new standards, new assessments, and new funding model rooted in equity.
So we can't afford a system that ignores student achievement and improvement and measures schools against a static proficiency model.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
I'm Doug McGray, a retired measurement guy from Monterey.
The addendum posted yesterday was, at least to me, convoluted and not clear.
So I'd like to make two general observations on identification of schools and weeding.
First, identification of the lowest 5% schools is a status-only calculation.
The status and change strategy is better for many other dashboard applications, but identifying lowest performing is a status only.
A school with low status is low performing whether or not it had significant change in recent years.
Second, weights are heavily determined by federal statute.
The academic indicator must be at least 50% of the weight.
Do that, spread the remaining weight over the other indicators,
The only exception to this, from my perspective, would be reduced weights for new data collections until they are mature enough to support full weights.
Finally, I would agree with Board Member Holliday.
We don't have two systems.
We are providing a subset of the status and change dashboard system to the Feds.
And you do not have to distribute that to all of the locals.
They just get the dashboard in full flavor.
Thank you.
afternoon terry burns on behalf of the california school boards association and we very much appreciates the board's action to defer action on this until we can all get more information on what the real outcomes are that's always the fear is that we take action here and then the boots in the ground it works really differently than folks expected so we would just like we are very appreciative of the opportunity to look at it the three items you're taking action on today we are supportive of
We do concur that it's important for you to continue to consider the waiver on the ELPI, including those students have been reclassified so that you are not discouraging reclassification.
We do have the concern that it is more than simply reporting data to the feds.
If there is action to be taken on that, we really are concerned that the feds will then ask for
action to be taken against those schools based on those scores and that you could have a school that is out of compliance with the federal law and the federal plan but doing just fine under the California plan.
So the federal government will be the right place to go.
Thank you.
I'm from Stockton and we have been working on this issue with our parents in Stockton.
I'm with the Stockton Schools Initiative.
We fight for education policy, really engaging young people on how does ESSA really impact our lives.
I'm here because we are concerned with some of the cases specifically around LCFF statute and that may overlook school districts, may overlook districts that have one or two low performing schools.
In Stockton we have seen that happen over and over consecutively especially with our elementary schools.
Also thank you for bringing up the 11th grade.
because that is something that we strongly urge you to approve, including that because we also believe that data humanizes this work.
And we in Stockton move a lot of our families around this data.
And so I think it will be important that we need this measure of student achievement to give us a clear measurable information regarding student performance in high schools.
So if you can please consider to do that as well, we really appreciate it.
We want to be able to have accountability system that's coherent and aligned.
So thank you so much.
Good afternoon, Enrique Rocha with the Los Angeles Unified School District.
And first off, we recognize the complexity of responding to the federal government.
So we're very appreciative and thankful of all the work that you have done, including your staff.
Given the latest developments on item four, we definitely support the action
to defer and have additional conversations and analysis on the overall conversation related to item four.
We also support the identification of the lowest 5% for Title I schools as it came out in the latest information that we received regarding item four.
And lastly, we would urge the consideration of a waiver as it's related to the English
learner progress indicator as well.
My colleagues have already said it.
We believe that this is a very important issue to be considered.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, Martha Zaragoza-Diaz representing the California Association for Bilingual Education and Californians Together.
And I just have a question in terms of two items because there's been so many blue sheets that were going around.
I want to make sure that
Title the the addendum to Table 3 Regarding the LP performance level is what it's going to be included in the plan forwarded to the state I mean they were forwarded to the feds if it is then we support a waiver on this item I'm unclear as to whether the exit procedures
for Title III regarding English learners is also a part of what's going to be forwarded to the Feds.
And if so, it is?
Okay.
Because it's unclear.
Thank you.
Just that I support the waiver.
I appreciate the complexity of the issue and also support the deferment on Title IA.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, Michael Flores Castaneda with California Teachers Association.
And I will be also speaking for the rest of our group back here.
You've received our letter highlighting our specific concerns with the most recent plan.
The current draft, most importantly, the current draft fails to adhere to the guiding principle, which was to create a single coherent system and avoid having two separate accountability structures.
We are encouraging CDE and state board to pursue waivers in the following areas.
Number one, the double counting of the 11th grade test scores.
We don't need to overemphasize test scores.
We've gone down that route before.
Number two, deleting the reclassified English learners from the EL progress indicator.
It gives no credit to the students and the schools who are making progress.
And where I teach in Arvin, down in Kern County, we make a big to-do every year about the students who are re-designated.
And number three, identifying the identification of the lowest 5% schools.
It's still ambiguous.
It's a punitive system.
And again, it's not something that we need to go down that route.
So we're asking for you to seek waivers in those areas.
We will be back next month for the next special board meeting.
And to say it with me one more time, one accountability plan.
Thank you.
Good afternoon Martha Alvarez on behalf of the school administrators.
Huge thanks to CDE and state board staff for working under the clock in getting these items ready for public discussion today.
Similar to prior comments we appreciate the delay in Title I accountability provisions of the ESSA state plan.
We would also encourage the board to keep talking about a waiver, not just on the ELPI, but also for acts that we're very concerned about removing change from the indicators.
We want to continue to have that inclusive conversation about status and change as part of our accountability system.
And there might be other waivers we would like to pursue, but let's talk about it in the next coming month.
We would ask, in addition to the options and timeline that Board Member Burr indicated, we would also ask for a table such as this one, the handout, that outlines the differences that we might have between the California dashboard system and if we were to have a different requirement for the feds so we can really clearly communicate to the field.
And lastly, we would also ask for the next month to talk about system of support and how would that work between the low performing schools and linking it back to LCFF identified districts.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
My name is Felicia Jones.
I am with COPE, a network of congregation students and parents in San Bernardino County.
And we are here first to thank you for the reconsideration of the 11th grade assessment as an academic indicator.
We certainly support that and hope that the board will take that into under strong consideration in the next month.
We're also deeply concerned about accountability and assessment, particularly as accountability and actually support for the comprehensive schools.
We are concerned that low-performing schools who may be in high-performing school districts will be overlooked, and we want to make sure that there's adequate identification and support for that.
We are especially concerned about subgroups under the identification of targeted support.
Again, we want to make sure the students aren't masked, particularly African-American students who continue to be underperforming in schools, and particularly in schools that may be high-performing, but the subgroups are still very much underperforming.
So we certainly hope that you will take that into consideration moving forward.
Thank you.
on behalf of the California Association of School Counselors.
The revision relative to Title VII gives us a little bit of excitement as well as nerves because counselors aren't mandated under the education code so not every school district has counselors.
We're happy to change that.
But we look forward to working with Marguerite on how we work together to make sure that we are serving students and utilizing the counselors that we have in those areas.
So I think I'm looking forward to that and our folks are too.
We want to support our homeless youth but just want to make sure we keep in context the limited number of counselors we have.
And also just want to take a moment to thank the board and the staff for sticking true to what we're doing here.
and to pushing back as much as we can push back.
I know it has to be a very difficult conversation with the feds, but I'm not as worried about what they're doing at that level because we're doing the right thing here.
So thank you and we look forward to working with you on the waivers and other pieces.
Good afternoon, Samantha Tran with Children Now.
And similar to the other speakers, we appreciate the additional time to really reflect and think about the identification of the 5% of schools so that we can engage in that a little bit more.
Really pleased with the direction around 11th grade assessment.
As I mentioned earlier, we see that assessment being used in different ways for different purposes and that that's appropriate within our system.
We are also pleased with the movement around the interim goals, similar to what Member Ortiz-Lacon mentioned, small steps.
I think it is going to be really important to clarify where that data is going to be.
The plan mentions an LEA report card, but we haven't used that vernacular, so trying to understand where that sits in the system will be helpful.
Finally, the last point I want to raise, which I know has not been talked about much today, is the issue around the exit criteria for schools.
We clarified that schools can't be declining in order to exit the system, but I don't think that lends well to what we are trying to accomplish overall as a system and that we need to have higher expectations.
So talking a little bit more about that would be helpful.
Thank you so much.
Good afternoon, Dean Drescher on behalf of EdVoice.
We're really looking forward to the future meeting on the accountability items.
We're heartened that the state is considering ways to help teachers by requiring LEAs to articulate what they're going to do to address inequitable distributions of teachers.
And we would even encourage the department to recommend to the legislature that the state use Prop 98 general fund resources to provide that additional help.
We urge the board to articulate how the state plans to provide feedback on the LCAP addendums and how the state will support LEAs in achieving an equitable distribution of teachers.
We would also add that teacher effectiveness should be defined by measures of teacher impact on student outcomes.
And for example, if we had a more robust definition of teacher effectiveness, regardless of years of service, the state could have recommendations of how an LEA could support teachers to become more effective to serve low-income students.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, Sarah Lillis with Teach Plus.
And just echoing the comments from Ed Voice, we think that there is more that we can do.
I think as we stand up and say we're doing this the California way, in addition to just meeting the ESSA requirements on disproportionate rates of access to effective educators, that we in California can stand up and say we can do better.
We can make sure our teacher leaders really believe that access to quality teachers are the number one civil rights issue of our time.
What are the questions that we can't answer from the data that we're planning to collect and report?
And I think there are critical questions we still can't answer about this disproportionate access to effective teachers, looking at issues of turnover, looking at issues of absence, whether it's performance, something about where there are pockets of underperforming teachers who need extra support, and how do we really explicitly get the support to those teachers that need it and to the schools and districts that need it?
We appreciate the addition on the state plan for the LEAs articulating their LCAP addendum, what they're going to do, but we do think that the state has a really important role in this as well.
Thank you.
Eric Primack, Charter School Center.
We remember the API, AYP confusion, really strongly urge you to continue to press to avoid that.
I call this as a chicken and so I can urge you to continue to play the chicken game and try to get
The guy with the long title, Mr. Botel, and his boss to blank first.
It is worth noting that she spoke to the Council of Chief State School Officers a little while ago, reaming
assembled masses for not being innovative.
And yet, here, we're putting something very innovative forward.
And maybe it's time to call them on that.
I will also note, though, that we feel your pain as charters, because we're always swimming upstream, too.
And we continue to have concerns about the way charters are treated in the ESSA plan with respect to the teacher credentialing issues and whatnot that partially recognize our flexibility, but partially don't.
And we would still like to see that clarified.
Thank you.
Hi again, Elizabeth Rovatay, California Charter Schools Association.
While we're appreciative of the deep thought and continued work towards developing a final lowest performing 5% identification methodology, we would like to reiterate our call that academic indicators in the aggregate should receive much greater weight than non-academic indicators.
Also, we applaud the department's use of distance from level 3 change.
sorry, status as an academic indicator in California's ESSA application.
As we've asked in previous meetings, we continue to urge the State Board to add a state academic indicator for high school to its top-level dashboard to prioritize academic outcomes.
Without simple comparable academic data like the distance from level three, it's unclear how academic achievement for schools, particularly charter schools at the high school level, can be truly measured in a targeted, clear, and timely manner.
Thank you.
Hello, Liz Guillen with Public Advocates.
Very pleased to see that the state plan now addresses or requires the district's LEAs to articulate in their LCAP addendums what they're going to do to address an equitable distribution around various teacher preparation and preparedness and assignment.
We still think that there should be articulation about how the state's going to support LEAs.
to equitably deliver on this.
We support seeking a federal waiver around the LP.
And beyond that, we're really pleased that you are keeping your focus on the federal
the multiple measures and California's dashboard and just using the federal requirements for information.
Thank you so much.
President Kirsten, I'm Brian Revis speaking on behalf of the Education Trust West.
I want to say first I understand the point about $2.8 billion relative to the entire state amount spent on education.
But I think we would disagree that that's a negligible amount.
We think it's still quite a bit of money.
Remember, that's intended for low-income students, Title I schools.
And for comparison purposes, it's about the same amount that the governor is proposing to put into LCFF this year to get us into full implementation ahead of schedule.
So I would say it's an impactful amount that matters.
Secondly, I think we would agree with many of the comments that Member Holiday made about the path forward.
We see the changes that are being asked of you from the federal government as things that compensate for potential shortcomings in our state system, like the possible overlooking of low-performing schools or subgroups.
So we would urge you to be very cautious when it comes to seeking waivers and use them sparingly.
Daniel Espinoza from the Learning Policy Institute.
We'd like to thank the Board for your perseverance in revising California's ESSA plan in a way that will hopefully lead to an improved plan while maintaining the heart of California's innovative accountability and continuous improvement system.
The proposed revisions leave intact California's school dashboard, which takes into account both status and change, although status and change will now be reported separately for federal accountability.
We feel that California's approach represents a fundamental change from the NCLB era when schools were judged solely on static test scores and not on the growth that they had been able to help students make.
By holding schools accountable for both status and change across multiple measures of school and student success, California's new system encourages school behaviors that enhance educational opportunity and support greater equity.
We'd also like to echo the comments of other made today regarding the English learner proficiency indicator and to support or urge the state board to seek a waiver for all the reasons stated prior.
Thank you.
Board member Strauss?
Yeah, no, there's one more commenter.
Oh, that's.
I've already said my piece.
So I just I feel like I first I just want to thank the State Board and CDE staff for their continued effort to help us stay coherent.
And I think that's certainly been the guiding practice and philosophy in all of our work over the last several years to make a single coherent system and to help it make sense with the work as we try to improve schools and focus on improved achievement.
And I do feel, and I think Eric Premack said that, that there's a mixed message coming from Washington, which is there's state control, you need to be creative, we want you to be creative, but you can't do this, this, and this.
And I think that is a mixed message, and I think it's frustrating for those of us who've worked, and I'm sure other states as well, tirelessly to try to make it a coherent system.
So I look forward to the meeting probably next month that we will spend more time on this, but I think a couple things.
And I do, as other board members, I think there are a few of the tweaks that I think will help us and enhance our work.
But I think to reinforce our philosophy, which is with low performing schools, the LEAs have a responsibility to support them.
So as the CDE does their technical runs on methodology to try to identify the lowest performing schools, and I know there's a real desire in Washington to know where are the worst ones and where do we need to really help them.
I think we need to remind ourselves as we move into system of support, which I know we'll spend more time in May on, is what's the support for all schools, what's the support for some, and what are the support for few?
And what's the role of the LEA, what's the role of the county, what's the support of the collaborative and other support providers?
Because really, our work is about improving achievement for students.
which I believe in spite of all the, that's what we all want and how do we get there in a clear and coherent manner.
I do think that some of the recommendations which we'll talk about are helpful but I guess lots of it is politics about the attacking the California way and why we're using colors and not numbers and not rankings and I feel like the message is stay coherent, focus on the students and LEAs and schools that need support
and trust us.
So I do feel a conflict on, we'll consider a waiver once we approve your plan.
So therefore, write a plan that you don't really want to do, and then we'll think about you really wanting to do it.
And that, I think, is the real conflict in the areas where we have agreement that we need a waiver.
So, I know we'll get more guidance from staff at our next meeting, but I feel like that's a real mixed message rather than saying, we agree to all this, but we're not going to do that.
And so, it's an interesting dilemma, I think, for us as we move forward.
But I do agree that we need to get looking at what the action is.
I share all the voices on the issue of not including reclassification and believing that that is so important.
We spend a lot of time talking about the issues of reclassification and long-term English learners, so I would like to look at a way, as we submit our plan, because I know there is a requirement for waiver procedures that we have to do, but it is money that is significant to helping districts, and we want to
make sure that we don't take away funds to support that, but I think philosophically the idea of focusing on long-term English learners, reclassified students and supporting them, I don't want to lose that in the message that the federal government without regulations have interpreted our direction as well.
So I think, I guess I'd support by saying is that we're making progress.
We've taken the coherent approach consistently through all of our actions.
And I like as you come back, Margarita and the team, and Dave, I think as you think about guidance for us, how we maintain the intent of coherence.
to the outcomes that we're focused on and make sense of it so that it's not a fragmented system that many of the schools and districts have lived with for so long.
And so I'm hopeful.
I appreciate the stakeholder input in the letters and the testimony today.
I do think we have to find a way to make this work but not compromise the coherence that we've worked so hard to have in our plan.
Thank you.
Okay, Board Member Ortiz-Lacon.
So I have two questions and one clarifying because I don't want to mislead Martha who had a question about the waiver under Title III Part A. And Veronica, I think you're here in the audience.
So my understanding is when we speak the next time on Title I Part A, we'll discuss the English language proficiency indicator and then that's where some of us may want to recommend a waiver.
However, under Title III Part A,
We're not there's no waiver to be considered and maybe Veronica.
Can you tell us a little bit about what's under that section?
I mean, I have it but it's there's like five documents that I try to open and I couldn't get to it.
Veronica Aguilar, Division Director for the California Department of Education.
The title three part section that they wanted clarification on was the reclassification section.
As you know, California has four criteria.
With ESSA, we could just have one criteria, the English Language Proficiency Assessment.
But because California has poor criteria, they are asking us to standardize all the criteria.
As you know, there was a bill last year that is now a two-year bill, SB 463, that would look at those four criteria.
We also need to wait until we have the LPAC assessment data and we have the cut scores so that we can recommend to you the reclassification criteria that it takes into account, the LPAC.
In terms of teacher observation or teacher evaluation, the criteria and the parent opinion that's in law, we're proposing to do a pilot of a language observation tool.
And then based on that information, we would also recommend to the board how to make that standardized.
come back to us this fall, correct?
The protocol, standardizing the protocol.
Yes, in terms of what we would pilot with teachers once it's developed, yes.
Okay so I hope that answers the question that Martha had.
We will be discussing the EOP indicator the next time.
Yes.
Thank you Vero.
The next question is on title on the identification of the title one schools the bottom 5% because I read the item the same way that some folks read it in that if we move to status only then we're identifying the bottom 5% because remember under LCFF we don't have to identify schools we have to identify LEAs.
So once we move to the status for the purpose of as a plan, then I also inferred that we would be identifying based only on status.
Not status and change because status and change is LCFF and what we're proposing is just status.
And if that is not the case, if we could have somebody that explains what we're still, how we will identify the bottom 5% and I know we'll have more of a discussion.
But again, because school identification falls under ESSA, and we're saying that under ESSA we're identifying based on status, then it does send a very conflicting message, at least to some of us that read it that way.
Sure, and I just would like, certainly as you suggested, it will be covered in more depth at the upcoming special meeting.
Excuse me, but if you look, oh sorry.
Hello?
OK.
We will certainly include those into our comments at the additional meeting.
But I'd like to also point folks to Addendum 1, page 2, the second paragraph.
There's a sentence that I believe clarifies your point.
To meet the US Department of Education's interpretation of the provisions, the CD proposes using the color-coded performance levels on dashboard indicators to identify at least the lowest performing 5% of Title I schools statewide.
I know there are a lot of materials related to this item.
And also one of the things that I think it came in the last yesterday's item for addendum, which I agree, I'm not against identifying the schools.
I do think that through the LCAP, we could still work with the LEAs to be accountable for the schools and supporting the schools.
there I think this the recommendation was to include something in the LCAP that identified the schools every three years and those schools would be part of the LCAP template.
So while we may directly identify the school the support would still be on the LEA to provide that support.
So I like that idea.
Okay, Board Member Ting, maybe you can make a motion too.
Yes, I will be very, yes, I'm almost ready.
Thank you.
So just quickly, I just want to echo what Dr. Kirst started this discussion with at the beginning, the gratitude to the CDE and state board staff who have worked diligently and patiently to come to a place with the Federal Department of Education
that maintains a path forward under LCFF and allow us to still access federal funds to support our work and for some of our neediest students.
So when I look at this and I look at a little bit higher view, I look at the changes that we've had to work with and look at, I ask myself, will this support students?
Will this help kids?
And I do believe it is.
And that's the really the larger
question I think we need to ask ourselves when we dig ourselves out of some of these details.
Now, certainly more work needs to be done.
I'm hopeful that the CDE and the state board staff will be able to continue working with our stakeholders.
I know it is difficult to kind of read this and try to conceptualize how LCFF and these new provisions are going to work together.
We will need to see how this works on the dashboard, how it's going to be displayed.
I think all of those will help with that sense of coherence once we're able to see this implemented.
So I do think that we need to move forward, and I do think that based on many discussions with staff that I think we can find a way that we can make these provisions work and complement LCFF and not be two different systems.
So with that comment, I would like to move the approval of the proposed revisions to Section A1, disproportionate rates of access to educators, E1, Title III,
1.7.G McKinney-Vento Homeless Assistance Act of the state plan pending the SBE executive director approval of final revisions requested by the SBE and correction of any typographical errors.
Is there a second to that motion?
One just just one clarification was the motion to section A1 or A5 disproportionate access?
A5 sorry A5E1.
Any further board discussion?
Seeing none, all those in favor, raise your hands.
OK, that is approved unanimously.
So we cannot start the charter hearings till 2 o'clock.
So I propose we take up and begin SBE priorities at that point.
But we'll take a break first and come back and do whatever we can.
Let's try and get back by quarter of 2, and then we will do whatever we can on SBE priorities.
We have opened the search for our executive director.
Dr. Cohn is retiring from his esteemed career, so there's information about the executive director search on our website.
We've contracted with Leadership Associates.
We will shortly be posting a position description, and we will begin to interview
in May, the board will interview and we hope to have a new executive director selected by our June meeting.
So if you know of good candidates, please send them our way.
Okay, member Holiday.
Well, first of all, in regards to charter schools, on behalf of Member Williams and the CDE, I wanted to make sure everyone understood that the CDE has posted the public charter schools grant program request for application on the California Department of Education website.
The charter school developers may apply for these funds to assist in the development and initial operations of newly established or conversion charter schools.
Charter schools who have not opened or did not begin serving students prior to July 1, 2016 are eligible to apply.
All applicants must have a charter petition submitted to an authorizer before April 3rd, 2018 to be eligible.
The charter petition must be approved by May 10th, 2018 to be funded.
The request for application is available now and is due to the CDE on or before April 3rd, 2018 by 4 p.m.
And of course, we'll have quite a bit more charter work to do.
The other topic that I often report on is Environmental Literacy Steering Committee.
And as much as it's great to have Glenn here, I wish Tom were sitting here right now, because I would certainly like to acknowledge
how important Superintendent Torlakson was as a catalyst for beginning the work on the Environmental Literacy Initiative and the formation of the Environmental Literacy Steering Committee.
We will meet again this coming Monday, I believe in Yolo County Office of Ed.
To continue that work, the committee has been putting together a 10-year strategic plan, which you'll hear more about later on.
But in particular, the committee and the students and the teachers of California and all of California owe Superintendent Torgerson a great deal of thanks for his efforts on behalf of environmental literacy in the state of California.
Thanks.
Okay, Board Member Gray.
First, I was lucky enough to talk to the Fremont Unified School District board member and other students who wanted to get involved and talk about accountability and LCAP and how they could get more students involved in their guiding coalition to increase student voice.
Recently, I along with the student board member on the Hawaii, New Orleans, Maryland, and Iowa state board started a state student board member Facebook group and we're hoping that that's something we can continue on for our successors so it's a way we can help each other grow in our jobs and help our successors grow in their jobs as well.
I also was very involved in the walkout that happened today at my school, and it's something that I was very passionate about.
I saw some videos online of some of my fellow classmates participating in it, and I'm very proud that it went very well, so yeah.
Okay, we're up to my president and myself and what I would report is that Carrick Ashley and Tony Alpert of Smarter Balanced and I met with the admissions advisory committee of the California State University system.
It included many of their top administrators and faculty members.
And the agenda item was adding Smarter Balanced to the admissions process criteria for California State University.
I think we were favorably received.
Also there was Linda Rogers, Dean at UCSC, who represented Smarter Balanced as our contractor.
And this is a long process in higher education to get this done.
Any changes are glacial, and therefore I would say that we were encouraged, but it's a long way to go, but it's an opening discussion.
So now we move to Ortiz-Lacombe.
So I've been traveling to Sacramento quite a bit this year.
I was able to attend the Health Framework Committee meeting and to see how this process really unfolds.
I wanna thank the department and of course all of the very committed participants who really sat there through a very rigorous process and it was a very well-structured process that the department put together.
And these educators were very, very passionate
And we are, the health framework will be coming before the IQC next Tuesday, I'm sorry, next Thursday, March 22nd.
So we should have something before us in a couple of months.
And I'm also part of the, I was part of the LPAC standard setting, just observing, and that was also facilitated by the department and ETS with several EL experts and practitioners.
It was a two-day, I'm sorry, a four-day process, so they had two different sessions, and I was only there for one day, and God, are these processes rigorous.
I mean, they sit there, and they debate, and they look, and they're looking at the LPAC assessment.
They're trying to identify the borderline student.
There was a memo that went out.
But I just want to say thank you to all of those educators and everyone in the department that facilitated that because it was over the course of four days, including Valentine's Day.
And if there's one thing I don't want to do is look at memos and test items during Valentine's Day.
So thank you for that for that passion.
I won't be here in May, so I just wanted to say that because I have to be traveling, but one of the things that I know this is not related to my liaison assignments, but I am a parent, and one of the things that I would encourage us to consider, since we have the right people in the room, is how to speak to our students and our kids about some of the things that they're witnessing.
whether it be the gun violence or the walkout or arming teachers, which is really arming students.
Students are really alarmed by that.
My elementary school kids were like, no way, mom.
And as a parent, I didn't know how to respond to that.
These kids are picking up on the conversations.
And so if we could do something to equip parents with the talking points to help students
understand the larger context and the political context, it would be great.
Because the last thing I want my kindergarten student and my second grader to do is to think that their teacher is going to have a gun or that there's going to be an active shooter on their campus.
And as much as we want to prevent and be aware of the reality, it's also a very traumatizing thing to have to explain to an elementary school student.
Thank you.
Okay, Board Member Rucker.
Good afternoon.
I'm looking, first of all, I want to say I had the opportunity and I wanted to thank Tom Adams for the opportunity.
I had the opportunity to represent the board on February 28th on a panel that, in the LEAD Learn Conference, it was a focus from the Subject Matter Project on History, Social Science.
The panel contained six different policy leaders having a discussion, not only about civic engagement, but what it really means
to develop and encourage this development with students as a function and focus of the work that schools are doing.
It was a very engaging panel and while a lot of the time we were speaking to the choir, there were a lot of great questions that were asked and a lot of good opportunity not only to identify areas and points of consonance and agreement about what it means to teach civic engagement and to develop
civic engagement among students, but also to think about what that also means in the academic and education community at all segments, not just in K-12, but in higher education as well.
In May, I'll be traveling down to Southern California to participate in the next California Interstate Compact meeting.
It will be at the Camp Pendleton Marine Base on May 4th.
Some of the details from the meeting that'll start around nine o'clock.
is going to be at a high school near Camp Pendleton, but there's an opportunity being provided by the base commander to tour the facilities and to look at the impact of the work the compact does.
I want to remind you the purpose of that particular work group is to support students who are dependents of military personnel.
who have to travel to California or follow their parents from other states to make sure their transition into our schools and our school programs support their work and support their continued matriculation as students.
The focus of the work that they are doing continues to be looking at how the state will add the federal requirement to report military dependents
into our state's data system and to also make sure that we continue the work of the agreements that California has as a Participating in the compact Thank You board member Sandoval
Good afternoon.
I'll offer some updates on history, social science, adoption of materials.
Final edits and corrections meetings with publishers were held on February 5th and 6th, and that was with representative IQC members and CDE staff.
And all of the state board approved edits and corrections were reviewed and finalized, and we can expect final versions and the price list to be available early April.
for Visual and Performing Arts Standards.
The Visual and Performing Arts Standards Advisory Committee is halfway through in the work in updating the Visual and Performing Arts Standards, also known as VAPA, and their next meeting is April 4th and 5th, and the committee will be continuing their work on revisions to the standards.
All members of the public are invited to participate in that work and provide public comment, or you can submit comment in writing.
So you can write to VAPA at CDE.California.gov and that's one way to participate in the process.
For the California State Summer School for the Arts, applications were due February 23rd and more than 1,400 applications were received.
for 500 slots.
So these applications came from high school students from every corner of California, an impressive number of strong applications from rural parts of California, so I have to commend the outreach that's being done.
The administrators, the staff of California State Summer School for the Arts is doing a phenomenal job.
There's seven disciplines in this Summer School for the Arts, film, animation, writing, dance, music, theater, and visual arts.
And every year, in this wonderful pre-professional training program, the school brings in artists from around the world, actually.
and just some names to note.
Acclaimed LA Fusion Dance Company, Body Traffic, and there's an emerging East LA-based music group called Kwekani, and those are just some of the names.
Another thing that I'd like to highlight is one of the
school alum, Adrin Molina, who is the co-director of Coco, Oscar award-winning.
And so what was really wonderful is he acknowledged the role of this wonderful public school for the arts.
He said it was there that he found his tribe, and where his path to becoming an award-winning Pixar animator truly began.
So I think that speaks to the power of this school, which is in its 32nd year of operation.
And then for special education, regrettably, I could not attend the Advisory Commission meeting.
However, my colleague, Member Valdez, did, so I'd like to invite her to say a few words about her time.
So it was a full agenda, and it was an amazing commission panel and a great opportunity.
Very inclusive agenda, and it really showed the leadership and the passion around special ed within the state, with two-thirds of our districts identified for differentiated assistance.
qualifying, if you will, because of our performance with students with disabilities.
It's all hands and hearts on deck and that was very evident that day.
I think one of the highlights of the day was one of the agenda items was on the system, the continuum of care and the idea that multiple agencies have to come together to talk about wraparound services and the child welfare and the mental health and that was very evident because we know that so many of our students, whether they're special ed or not, the whole
focus and Sadly the opportunity to experience trauma is across all groups But especially special ed was one of the areas that we talked about that on that day It really inspired me to begin to think about an integrated system framework.
And I think that's where we're going that we have Academics and we have behavior and we have social emotional and how are we putting them all together?
What do they look like and it brings everything together when we're talking about whether it's RTI MTSS
system of support, it's really looking at all that continuum of services.
So that was a highlight of the day.
Very, very strong agenda.
And I think as Director Wright talked about, we have special ed at the table.
We're being very inclusive.
And so now what?
And so that's the job.
And very passionate leaders talking about that.
Thank you.
OK.
Board member Strauss.
So I'm just going to focus on several areas.
First, science.
The Science Collaboration Committee met on March 2nd.
The Collaboration Committee is a group of 30, 35 people who work to plan the community of practice that meets three times a year, really committed, trying to align the practice, focusing on administrative and core concepts and really enthusiastic.
There's also a
There was another meeting on March 1st, the day before, with the NGSS early implementers.
They had a meeting in San Diego at High Tech High with the superintendent's roundtable, and particularly committed to and reports from each of the participating districts on what's working, what they're finding, what their information is, and so this was focused on the district leadership teams.
The materials review process begins on April 16th, and so CDE will be guiding that process.
My encouragement to them was to make sure they spend plenty of time with their staff on their frameworks so that when they get to an adopted materials that we hope to recommend in November, they'll actually be good consumers when they look to that in 2019.
The Social Emotional Learning Task Force, that's a group that's led through CDE, met in Oakland on January 22nd, and there's now a compendium of resources that are posted on CDE, and I think they would like in the future to be able to share, should we have any space in our agenda for any updates on what resources there are to show how to integrate that into the work that we're doing.
We have a Standards Implementation Steering Committee that's coordination between CDE, CCESA, and State Board.
There was a meeting of that group that met in Huntington Beach at the end of January.
The CalSTAN Network, which is the network's advisory that WestEd ran, it was all focused on English learners implementations, or what are the next steps statewide to support English learners, and really some thoughtful recommendations that each of the subcommittees around the state looked at.
the Standards Committee Advisory.
We meet quarterly, and they met in the early part of February.
On accountability, several different venues for discussion.
The AXA Superintendent Symposium was in Monterey on the 25th of January.
We talked a lot about systems to support.
We had lots of county leads there, and some superintendents really talking about what the next steps are with system support, which we've been talking about here at the State Board meeting.
In Riverside, there was a panel meeting in February with an education panel summit, also talking about what the next steps are with the voice from state board matched by a local center, local assemblyman talking about what the needs are.
So I think everyone's looking at ways to now move into implementation.
And at LA County, Nancy Brunel, who's still actively out there doing our work as a member of WASC, we represented
the state implementing the California way with strategies for success at L.A.
County.
And so we had a large group of L.A.
County districts presented as well.
My final comments are around CTC because CTC does work with credentialing around many of the areas that we're talking about with college and career.
A lot of focus on early child development and a lot of discussions about what we need to do to strengthen that, why we need child development teachers.
Lots of stakeholders talking about that as well, and then quite a bit of discussion about career tech and how long it takes to get the credential, how we prepare them.
There's a shortage of CTE teachers.
We had a lot of testimony about that and some concern.
You'll hear more about that.
And then some about the reading instruction competency assessment, better known as RICA, and that it's not aligned with Common Core.
How could we better assess teachers' competency in the reading assessment?
So I think we'll hear more about these, but a lot of these link into the work we're talking about as far as early childhood content support for teachers.
Very active, and you'll continue to hear more.
And thanks to Pam Kasselman for always supporting me in my work at CTC as well.
Thank you.
Board Member Sun.
Very good.
So the California Workforce Pathways Joint Advisory Committee is meeting tomorrow.
No, excuse me, Friday after our state board meeting.
And we're going to be in that meeting.
It'll be the first time we can really dig into some guiding principles that will support K-14 pathways.
to careers.
So there have been several common themes that have come up in our looking at the different programs that are out there and systems of support for students as they move from the K-12 into the community colleges.
And so we're looking at principles that will provide infrastructure and support on a regional and local educational agencies to build efforts to connect, to build connected, equitable, accessible and high quality K-14 college and career pathways and beyond.
So we will be digging into that and I'm hoping that we can provide you with a refined draft very soon for the rest of you to review.
OK, now board member Valdez.
My only other report is going to be about the World Language Committee they met, and they will be meeting again next week.
Member Williams.
So there's been a lot of work that's gotten started on computer science, expansion of computer science in K-12 in California.
I think that 2018 is going to wind up being felt as the year that California got serious about expanding computer science education, at least at the state policy level.
As an example, we have a computer science standards advisory committee, and they have met, they have finished their work for the first draft.
of model standards for computer science and that will be going to IQC later on in March for review.
It'll then go out for public comment and eventually come back to IQC and then it's expected to come to the board I believe in September for consideration of adoption.
In addition, Senate Bill 2329, I think it is, created a computer science strategic implementation advisory panel, and they had their first meeting last week.
This is 23 members, the majority appointed by the governor, some by the state superintendent, some by the legislature.
And I attended that two-day meeting.
It was their first two-day meeting, and then they'll have another two-day meeting in April, and then skip June and have their final two-day meeting in June.
And they are supposed to, by statute, take a look at various kinds of interrelated issues that need to be considered when expanding computer science in California in K-12, like will teachers need credentials?
and if, or supplemental authorizations, or what kind of training, what will be okay and what will not, and which teachers.
A variety of other, what are the resources for it?
What kind of curriculum and professional development is already out there available?
Which of it is free and which of it is for a fee?
Does there need to be any additional state resources?
So they'll take a look at a wide variety of things.
and they will finish their recommendations in June and then the CDE will take the next step of determining how to turn that into a plan that would be eventually come to the State Board for consideration of adoption.
Another CS thing that is a state policy is, like President Kirst, I have been meeting and talking by email and phone with UC Boards for the last 20 months.
They reached out to me since I have been a liaison to Next Generation Science Standards and the lead on computer science education.
The board adopted NGSS in September of 2013 and within a year and a half or two years, UC boards revised their Area D description of goals and criteria to align very tightly with NGSS.
including the practices in NGSS, which are very different.
They represent very different conceptual shifts.
But the other thing is that NGSS has standards for engineering and applied science, and it has practices for computational thinking, and it has standards that have to do with human impact on the environment.
And so this past 18, 20 months, UC Boards has had a working group of
of UC faculty in science and computer science meeting to talk about whether or not they should consider expanding the courses that might be eligible to be considered and approved under Area D beyond the traditional sciences, and those might include environmental science,
some kinds of applied sciences, computer science and engineering.
So they've been making pretty good progress on that, and I think that probably we will hear some news from them by the end of this spring or this summer.
On the NGSS front, Member Strauss is handling the instructional materials.
I've never been a teacher, so I said, please.
She said, of course.
So I did get invited and participated last week on a public policy institute of California
panel on NGSS implementation in California.
It was a terrific panel.
I loved the way it was handled.
It was standing room only in the room.
And it was with Jessica Sacco from the Executive Director of the California Science Teachers Association, plus a science lead teacher at Moreno Valley School District.
I apologize, I can't remember her last name, but it was Stacy, and she was fabulous.
So what we had was, I did the state policy from, you know, how the policy is implemented and what they all were.
Jessica Sacco did, well, here's what we see as an overview about how implementation is going in the state.
And then Stacy did, this is how we're doing it in our school district and how we've handled, for instance, like the difficult decision of whether to go with discipline focused or integrated model for middle grades.
And it was really well received.
And the other fun part about it is they ended the panel by asking each of us,
to kind of step out of their roles and not represent our organizations, but just speaking from our perspective, what is it that we would hope that the next elected education officials in California, the governor, the superintendent, the board members, the legislature, what would we hope they might do to further advance implementation and next generation science standards?
So that was kind of fun to speculate and pretend we had like a magic wand and could make something like that happen.
And lastly, I attended last month the advisory commission on charter schools as I do every other month when I'm not at a board meeting.
Thank you.
That concludes that item, the SBE priority.
So we're now ready for item 5, the petition for the establishment of a charter school in the Bayview District of the San Francisco Unified School District.
And Lisa Constancio, our CDE, will present.
Then we will have discussion by the Board or questions by the Board, I should say, on technical issues.
Then we'll have the public hearing and then more Board comment and discussion.
Go ahead.
Is that better?
Okay.
Sorry about that.
You only missed my introduction, so that was all fine.
Is it back?
Okay.
Item 5.
Everyone can hear me now?
Okay.
Item 5 is an appeal by KIPP Bayview Elementary School to establish a new charter school.
Pursuant to the Ed Code section 47605J, petitioners for a charter school that have been denied at the local level may petition the State Board for approval.
On November 14, 2017, the San Francisco Unified School District voted to deny the petition on a vote of 7 to 0.
On November 28, 2017, KIPP submitted an appeal to the State Board of Education.
The program proposed is a TK-4 site-based program.
Their targeted enrollment is 137 students in the first year, 2018-19, increasing to 437 students by year 2022-23.
They are targeting traditionally underserved pupils in the San Francisco Unified School District, and specifically those in the Bayview-Hunters Point area and surrounding neighborhoods.
The Advisory Commission on Charter Schools met on February 7th, 2018, and the commission moved to recommend approval of the petition.
The motion passed with a vote of five to two.
The petitioner then submitted some additional information after the ACCS meeting that was reviewed by CDE staff.
The details of that review are included in the item of the additional information that we did review after the ACCS meeting.
The CDE is recommending that the State Board hold a public hearing to approve the request to establish KIPP Bayview for a five-year term.
The recommendation is based on demonstrably likely to implement the attended program based on a sound financial plan and operational plan, and a sound educational practice and comprehensive description of the educational program.
I am here and available for any questions that you may have.
I just want a clarification.
It's my understanding that that CDE reached out and wanted just some clarification on a couple of items.
Nothing substantive that changed anything about the petition, just some clarifications.
Correct.
We had some questions about philanthropic funding, for example, and so we did get some additional information from the KIPP Foundation, bank statements, financial statements.
We also had some questions about
the San Francisco Proposition A and H and how the narrative language was was in the proposition.
We got some clarification on that and then we're able to include those funds as part of the financial analysis.
Once you got the clarification?
Correct.
And the law allows interaction getting the clarification at all levels.
It could be at the district level, the county level, or the state level?
We felt we were just clarifying information.
So that's my point.
We felt that it was within our purview to do so.
Thank you.
All right I'm going now going to declare the public hearing open.
So first we're going to hear from the supporters of the CDE staff recommendation to approve the charter school petition.
This is the KIPP charter school group will start first and they you have a
under the public hearing, a total of 10 minutes to present to us.
Then the district and county and other speakers will have a chance to speak against the CDE recommendation and against the establishment of the charter school.
and they have 10 minutes also.
Then we will go to public comment and each commenter will have one minute.
And therefore, we'll hear public comment for as long as that's needed.
And then after receiving all public comment, I will close the public hearing on this item and commence with board discussion and action on the recommendation.
So if your PowerPoint's ready, you may go ahead.
Thank you.
Good afternoon board members.
Thank you for thoughtfully considering our charter petition.
My name is Allie Welch and I'm the founding principal of Kipp Bayview Elementary.
I became a teacher eight years ago and I am now a school leader because I believe that all students deserve a world class education that enables them to reach their fullest potential and live lives of choice and opportunity.
And I believe that all families deserve to have access to public schools that make this vision a reality for their children.
We are here today because when it comes to equity in education, San Francisco is far behind, and families are coming together to demand change.
This map shows the rankings of San Francisco schools across the city.
The schools with the best student outcomes are largely in the northern and western neighborhoods, and communities like Bayview Hunters Point in the southeastern part of the city have limited access to quality options in and around their own neighborhood.
As a result, a majority of families are choosing to send their children to district schools far from where they live.
We cannot allow this to continue.
There is a true need for a quality elementary school option in Bayview Hunters Point.
Since 2003, KIPP Bay Area Schools has provided high quality education to over 1,000 families in Bayview-Hunters Point.
We want to open KIPP Bayview Elementary in direct response to family demand.
We have spent time listening to and learning from community members about their experiences and what they want in an elementary school for their children.
I met a mother whose youngest child is entering kindergarten and who said to me, if we don't open this fall, she will be forced to look at costly parochial options.
She deserves Kipp Bayview Elementary as an option.
I heard the story of one of our KIPP alumni who graduated from our high school and whose younger brother is entering kindergarten this fall.
She believes that attending our elementary school will set her brother up for continued success in middle school, high school, college, and beyond, an opportunity she wished she had had for herself when she was younger.
I met a mom who toured our Kipp Elementary School in Redwood City with me, and after observing classrooms, said that it was the type of learning environment that she wants for her daughter in San Francisco.
And I heard the stories of Bayview Hunters Point community leaders, such as preschool directors and pastors, who have seen the impact Kipp has had on their children that they've worked with, and who want to be able to share this elementary option with their families.
These are just a few of the stories from families that they have shared with me.
All of the stories from our Bayview Hunters Point families and community members deeply matter and cannot be silenced.
They're asking KIPP for an elementary school in their neighborhood.
We are committed to opening that school this fall.
Their dreams for their children's futures are in your hands.
The two schools that KIPP currently operates in Bayview Hunters Point, our middle school KIPP Bayview Academy, and our high school KIPP SF College Prep, both predominantly serve Bayview Hunters Point families and have a longstanding track record of success.
Both schools' academic results on last year's Smarter Balanced Assessment, shown in the graph in blue, exceeded those of peer district schools in Bayview Hunters Point, shown in orange, as well as the California state average, which is shown in gray.
In fact, KIPP SF College Preps Charter was recently unanimously renewed by SFUSD because of its strong student outcomes and the quality of its program.
By opening KIPP Bayview Elementary, we will honor the promise we made to families by giving students an earlier start and a continuous journey to and through college.
At KIPP Bayview Elementary, we promise to honor the collective strength of our students, family, staff, and community.
We believe that all students are capable of achieving at the highest levels and should be seen and valued at school for who they authentically are.
And we will cultivate a learning environment that is nurturing, rigorous, and reflective of our community's identities and aspirations so that our students are empowered to lead fulfilling, choice-filled lives.
To make this vision a reality, all of our students will have access to a rigorous academic program, be a part of a powerful learning community, and participate in opportunities for deeper learning.
We will implement a common core aligned academic program through a balanced literacy approach and through a math curriculum that emphasizes building students' fluency, conceptual understanding, and problem-solving skills.
Through daily small group instruction, our students will receive differentiated support that meets their needs.
We will cultivate an inclusive, nurturing, and safe community where students receive explicit social-emotional learning development in all grade levels.
Daily classroom community circles that follow a responsive classroom approach will ensure that our students feel a sense of belonging at school.
We will implement restorative practices to hold our students accountable to choices that they make through opportunities for reflection and logical consequences rather than through punitive measures.
We believe in setting high expectations and high supports to help all of our students be their best selves.
Opportunities for deeper learning will bring students' identities and strengths into the classroom, making school more relevant and purposeful for them.
Beginning in year one, all students will have the opportunity to participate in arts-based electives during the school day.
In all grade levels, students will also engage in project-based tasks aligned to Teaching Tolerance's social justice standards.
And once our founding classes enter third and fourth grade, they will participate in choice-based electives that allow them to more deeply explore an area of personal interest.
KIPP Bayview Elementary is committed to serving all students.
We uphold a fair and transparent enrollment process that is open to all families and is free of admission requirements.
Of the families who have already applied to our school, a majority of them live in Bayview Hunters Point and the surrounding southeast neighborhoods of San Francisco.
We expect that about 40 percent of our students will be English learners and about 10 percent will need special education services.
We are committed to their success.
Language development will be consistently integrated into daily lessons to provide multiple opportunities for students to explicitly practice their oral and written language skills.
Our extended school day daily small group instruction and personalized learning programs will enable teachers to support and track the growth of our English learners.
Response to intervention and student success team structures will allow our school to monitor the progress of our students.
For students who need additional interventions, our special education team will work closely with students' families to put in place an individualized education plan that meets their child's learning needs.
All of our special education services are free to parents.
By approving this school, you will grant hundreds of families in Bayview-Hunters Point the right to choose a KIPP Elementary education for their children.
Our students will play, learn, and grow in a learning environment where we care for ourselves and others, where we value our identities and differences, where we leverage our strengths, and where we always pursue excellence and honor the power of our community.
Our students will embody these values and will enter fifth grade with a strong foundation of academic and social emotional learning skills that will prepare them for life and career.
We sincerely appreciate the positive recommendations from the ACCS and CDE staff to approve our charter petition.
Please consider these recommendations and listen to the voices of parents and community members who have put their trust in us and vote today to approve Kipp Bayview Elementary.
KIPP is powerful.
KIPP is a great opportunity.
KIPP Bayview Elementary is vital to my community.
As a pastor in the Bayview community, I've seen kids graduate from KIPP and excel on to college and it's been a wonderful experience to see kids matriculate to higher levels of education because of what KIPP has done in my community.
KIPP is integral to the success of students, young boys, young black men in this community.
We need something like KIPP, a school like KIPP in this community that lets our kids know from the beginning, from kindergarten, that college is possible, that they can make it as long as they choose to succeed.
We need KIPP Elementary and our neighborhood to complete the KIPP circle.
Thank you for your consideration of our charter petition.
We look forward to addressing any questions you have.
Now we have 10 minutes for the opponents to the charter petition.
District and county members.
Good afternoon.
Am I on?
Good afternoon, President Kirst and board members.
My name is Michael Davis.
I'm the Director of Policy and Planning and Charter Schools for San Francisco Unified School District and County Office of Education.
I'm not here as an opponent of the recommendation.
I'm here as a proponent of the prerogatives of the San Francisco Unified School District Board of Education and the constituents that they serve.
I just want to recap how we got here.
Currently in San Francisco, as has been mentioned by the petitioners, our board currently authorizes three KIPP schools, two middle schools and one high school.
We would all agree that as measured by standardized test scores, the SBAC currently, that those three schools are producing good outcomes for historically underserved students in our district.
That is not a dispute.
The issue we have here is that within the very narrow constraints outlined by the charter school law as it currently exists, our board had to review the petition for another KIPP school in our district, the KIPP Elementary School, with their intent to serve the Bayview area.
Within those narrow constraints, our board did make some findings with concern to student discipline issues in their current schools and their ability to carry out the kind of educational program we'd like to see for those children.
The CDE staff echoed some of those same concerns and made additional findings about the finances of the school.
So when we were here for the Advisory Commission for Charter Schools, the recommendation from the CDE staff was denial of the petition.
The advisory commission listened to what both sides had to say.
From what I can tell, there was not a consideration of the CDE staff recommendation.
The vote was whether or not to approve or recommend that you approve the petition.
So, we made findings at the local level.
We present those findings to the petitioner.
The petitioner gave some response but did not really amend the petition to address all of our concerns.
At CDE staff level, there were findings to support denying the petition and then clarifications were made to
changed the recommendation from CDE staff to approve the petition.
So where we are is that if you approve this petition, there will be a KIPP elementary school in San Francisco Unified.
San Francisco Unified has many members, or
community members that you will hear from that don't support the school.
As you can see, there are many people that do support the school.
If you approve it, we will be in the position of having our local board working with a school that we did not approve, but we will do that.
You have to understand that they also have a Prop 39 recommendation or request in so that we will have to find a way to provide the school with facilities.
As a county office, we will also have to deal with their state apportionments on a monthly basis and divert other resources to take care of administerial functions as well as
having to disrupt some of the really tough work that we are doing in the Bayview area to improve the schools that we have there and make them a better choice for our students.
So it's an issue of we know what the rules are.
I've been here before.
In the past, we've actually made findings to deny renewal of a charter school that had been operated by the state for five years and clearly was in violation of the state's rules for their financial conduct.
And your board approved them anyway.
only to finally see the wisdom of our board's findings and close the school one year later.
But where we are is my board, the Board of Education of the San Francisco Unified School District, understands what the rules are.
We believe that the rules need to be changed because there is too much of a presumption that your board will approve petitions on appeal.
And we feel very strongly that our ability to control, to serve the constituents of our local community is unduly taken away under the current process.
And so we will, if you approve the petition,
I have to work with KIPP on facilities and other issues and go from there and hope that the state board oversight will make sure that things are done in a way that will benefit San Francisco.
Thank you.
Okay, we're now ready for the public comment.
One minute each.
Please introduce yourself and if you represent somebody or some organization, state that as well.
So let's have the list.
For item number five, would the following speakers please line up?
Michael Flores-Castaneda, Claire Crawford, Bishop Chris Baker, Mike Hutchison, Elida Fisher, Adrienne Adamichikova, Melissa Dar Carvajal, Allison Collins, Tracy Brown, Jewel Roberts-Plung,
Anna Keller, Rosalyn Taylor, Marie Huxley, Beth Thompson, Shanti Reed, and I will come back with the next 20.
Go ahead.
Thank you.
My name is Claire Crawford.
I'm within the public interest.
As you know, this is the first of six charter petition appeals before you today after sound decisions by local school boards.
In January, prior to the last SBE meeting, we shared with you our analysis of this board's tendency to overturn local and county board decisions to deny deficient petitions.
At that time, the SBE had approved 71% of petitions denied at the local level and fully one third of those schools were not open.
In the short time between January and now, yet another SBE-approved school, Paramount Collegiate Academy, failed.
Shut down mid-year with virtually no notice to students.
Students were sent scrambling to find a new school.
The warning signs were there from the local and county boards of education.
I urge you to be judicious in considering the decisions of the local elected bodies in the six petitions before you.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, board.
I'm Bishop Chris Baker.
And I'm going to stand and let you know why I'm here.
As a single parent of an African-American boy from 18 months to 24 years old, getting ready to graduate from college with honors, going to a undergraduate after this.
And I'll tell you why.
Because I chose to put him in a charter.
The charter did not come looking for me.
I went to look for a charter to have better options.
I chose that, and when I see the success of what these schools are doing for kids, I support it.
The only problem I have is why do we always focus on the negative?
If we continue to focus on the positive, we can achieve what we need to achieve and look at the other mechanism and bring that along.
So I solely support this, and I ask each and every one of you to look at your hearts and your minds
and support this and honor it.
And let's watch our kids grow.
So when you're in the grocery store, you're in the grocery store.
You can feel good about what you approve.
Thank you.
Rosalyn Taylor, Eastside Teachers Association, San Jose.
Yielding my time to Allison Collins.
Kevin Murphy, Parent & Salse, ceding my time to Allison Collins.
Hello, my name is Allison Collins and I'm a black parent in San Francisco Unified and I'm a very involved member of the African American Parent Advisory Council and I've been working for the past several years with black families across our district to help elevate voices of parents in our schools and make sure that they have a seat at the table when it comes to decision making in our district.
I want to talk to you about another school.
It's Dr. George Washington Carver Elementary.
Several years ago, I met with families there and they were concerned because their building was not
the way that they felt it should be, and we worked together to elevate their voices.
They came to the board, and the district responded, and it did a $1.9 million redesign, which recently opened this fall.
Families told me that they were crying.
They were so happy to have what they consider a new school in the Bayview.
As a community, the Carver Village is an amazing community.
They offer wellness programs, things like that.
What is concerning for black families that I'm talking to and specifically Carver families, I support families in choosing schools and I support them being involved, but I have two extra people who have ceded their time.
Okay and they are expressing to me that they are concerned because Kipp Elementary is saying that they want to have their new school in Dr. George Washington Carver's new school and for them to co-locate in that school would mean that they would have to push out vital resources that are necessary for their community.
They have 9% of their students are homeless and
and they also have a high level of students that face trauma and things like that in the Bayview.
So a lot of these resource rooms that they provide outside of classrooms are for quiet spaces for students who are experiencing trauma.
They have social workers and wellness centers and science rooms and a computer lab for kids who we know don't have as much access to technology.
They are extremely concerned about KIPP moving into their school.
I support families in having a voice in their school
You've had extra time.
I hope that you give Carver families a voice in also who is in their school that they've worked so hard to fight for.
Thank you very much.
Yeah.
Now I want to restate our rules.
We do not allow in these charter hearings seating of time.
So each person has one minute.
Okay, then I will talk very fast.
My name is Alita Fisher.
I'm the chair of the Community Advisory Committee for Special Education and SFUSD.
I'm not here to talk in my capacity as CAC chair, but I am bringing a copy of our charter position statement for you all.
I'll leave it here.
I'm the adoptive parent of four African American children out of foster care.
My oldest is a senior at Mission High School.
When she joined our family at age four, she had such severe
separation anxiety due to trauma in her life that I could not... I had to be next to her at her bed when she fell asleep.
And now she's a thriving senior graduating in June.
She's been accepted to multiple state universities.
She's deciding whether she wants to go to San Jose State or whether she wants to go to a small Division III college back in Maryland so she can play basketball.
Now, all of this is because of the wraparound services provided to her in her various schools that will be pushed out if resources are removed from SFUSD and allocated to charter schools.
Our children deserve the support and services they need.
Are we rubber stamps here?
Is the power of the pen mightier than the power of the sword, or is the power of the rubber stamp the mightiest of them all?
Thank you.
Hello, my name is Arianne Adamchikova.
I would love to be able to make my statement in Spanish.
Is there somebody that would be able to translate me back into English for the audience?
I understand, but I have people in San Francisco that are watching me, and they do not have translation headsets.
You have a translator.
Yes.
You have two minutes since its translation.
Okay.
Bueno.
Me llamo Arianne Adamchikova.
Soy una ma... My name is... Okay.
Okay.
And so I say one sentence and you... Okay.
Bueno.
Soy una madre de San Francisco.
I am a mother of San Francisco.
Are you going to say it at the same time as I do?
So I say it one minute and then she says it one minute.
Or are we going to do... Right?
Two minutes total for this.
Please proceed.
You have two minutes total.
Okay, so don't talk at the same time, okay.
Bueno, entonces soy una madre de un estudiante en la escuela Everett de San Francisco, perdn.
Entonces, como madre de un estudiante y tambin como maestra de los hispanohablantes recin llegados de pases de violencia y mucha guerra de Centroamrica, yo s muy, muy bien las necesidades de los recin llegados que ellos llevan cuando entran en nuestras escuelas.
Nuestras escuelas pblicas ofrecen muchos servicios y mucho programas de empoderamiento para los padres.
Entonces, necesitamos nuestras escuelas pblicas que son abiertas para todos.
Estos estudiantes llegan todo el ao, llegan con trauma, llegan aos y aos atrs en cuanto a la acadmica.
Time in Spanish, yeah.
I am a parent of a 13-year student and I have been an active parent volunteer for the last eight and a half years that my son has been in that district.
I also have 16 years experience as a Spanish teacher, Japanese teacher and a newcomer teacher for Central America with limited
people that are interrupted, formal education.
As a parent at my son's school, I have had a brilliant opportunity to get to know the diverse indigenous American communities that attend and thrive at our local public schools.
I have worked with families and students who speak Mon, K'iche, Ka'chikel, Mixteco, Zapotec, and Naxatuan.
KIPP is forcing a school into our district that will not be able to serve the needs of our immigrant and refugee students.
It is incredibly important to me as a parent and teacher and human being that all of our students and families are blessed with the ability to get to know each other
learn together and become lifelong friends on our local schools like Everett, Marshall, MEC, Fairmont, and many others serve new come youth from other countries.
They come as refugees through the year at the moment of their arrival to our cities.
However, like the Spanish colonialists that came over 500 years ago,
with an agenda.
KIPP charter schools are coming to colonize and take over our local community schools.
We are public schools.
We support inclusion of all our students no matter what trauma or disabilities or problems they bring to us.
Thank you very much.
Hi, my name is Tracy Gallardo.
I'll do my own translation after.
I was here to read a statement from Siobhan Walton, our board president, who denied the KIPP charter.
And I want to actually talk, because I've worked years, 25 years, voting in or getting people elected that represent us, my community, Latinos, African-American.
We've worked hard to get Board of Ed members to carry our voice so that they can be there showing us, representing us.
I'm a teen mother.
I'm a mother of four.
I attended three of San Francisco's failing schools, and here I am.
I rise, and so do other students.
I can tell you hundreds of success stories that we have, just like they can.
My community, the Latino community, came out against KIPP, located in our newcomer school.
The Prop 39 space allocation will take sweet, precious space from our newcomer students.
The Latino community has come out against it.
We couldn't afford a bus to bring our students here, but we're here today to tell you that it will be a hardship.
Mi nombre es Tracy Brown Gallardo y estoy aqui para decir que no estoy en acuerdo con esto, lo que esta pasando.
los programas de newcomer en el mission education center no deben que quitar espacio para este nuevo programa no es gusto los los nios necesitan servicios no pueden compartir un edificio porque todos los cuartos estn usado para servir los los nios
y estamos aqu unidos como latinos no podan pagar un bus para llegar aqu no tenemos suficiente fondos as para eso y as es que ahorita estn dando espacio para esta escuela y le va a quitar espacio de nuestros estudiantes y por eso estoy aqu
Here we are with uh
My name is Julie Roberts-Fong.
I'm a parent at Redding Elementary, which is an excellent public school in San Francisco's Tenderloin.
We're one of the first schools that a lot of newcomer families come to in the city.
Over 80% of our families are low-income families.
Over 75% speak another language at home.
We have 25 languages spoken.
And right now I'm missing a school site council meeting where our families are trying to decide whether or not we will have a split class or whether we'll take away a computer teacher.
And the reason that that's happening is because KIPP tells our fourth and fifth graders that they need to apply early in order to get into sixth grade to avoid some kind of test.
So I want to speak up for the impact that having unaccountable charter schools has on our excellent public schools, and I'm not alone.
I've been talking with families from MEC and from Carter, which will be damaged by a co-location, a potential co-location, or by having another school in their neighborhood.
And we have, just over the past week, over 400 signatures that have been gathered in the community opposing this charter school from opening.
Thank you.
Hi, I'm Mike Hutchinson, a proud graduate of Oakland Public Schools.
I'm also the founder of the Oakland Public Education Network and a founding member of the Journey for Justice National Alliance, a national alliance of black and brown-led grassroots organizations organizing across the country.
We stand with the NAACP and Black Lives Matter in calling for a moratorium on charter schools and school privatization.
were actually offended by this process, that there would be an appointed board of the state that thinks it is their right and their authority to overturn the decisions unanimously made by local communities.
This has been a longstanding problem, and hopefully at some point we're going to see an end to it.
Oakland has the highest rate of charter schools in the state of California.
It's had a devastating effect on our community, including during the 2017 school year, three rounds of mid-year cuts totaling $15 million, and I'm going to be racing home later for another discussion about school closures.
We need to do much better than this.
I would expect people serving in this position to want to do much better than this.
If we have people coming into our communities who want to work with our schools, then let them do it under the public school umbrella.
But charter schools are not public schools, and please respect our local communities.
Good afternoon, Michael Flores Castaneda with California Teachers Association, here to let you know that CTA is strongly opposed to overturning the decision of the local and county school board, or local and county boards.
With one in ten California students currently enrolled in charter schools, with 22 charter schools currently under the state board authorization, and another six on the agenda for this afternoon, with a potential 30 percent increase, the board needs to closely examine each appeal mindfully and carefully, especially in this case where there's any lack of real parent interest.
What happens with the remaining students within the district when facilities and resources are allocated now to students outside of the district?
We've heard it all day long, local control is the California way, but overturning the LEA and the district or the county board decisions is not a local control.
Please respect their wishes.
Thank you.
Good afternoon members of the State Board of Education CDE staff.
My name is Marie Kawase Huxley and I'm the Chief of Schools for KIPP Bay Area Schools Public Schools.
I'm here today to ask that you approve our charter for KIPP Bayview Elementary School so that we can respond to the needs and desires of the Bayview community.
We are proud to have educated San Francisco students in Bayview Hunters Point since 2003.
And our proposal to open an elementary school in the neighborhood represents our continued commitment to the community and to the families who have asked for more school options.
We propose to launch an elementary school in the Bayview where all students learn and grow in a healthy, joyful, and safe environment.
We have a strong elementary school program that consists of rigorous curriculum, social-emotional learning, and restorative practices.
Thank you for your careful consideration of our charter petition and for your service on behalf of California students.
Good afternoon, I'm Beth Thompson, the founder and CEO of KIPP Bay Area Schools.
We greatly value having been part of the Bayview Hunters Point community for the past 15 years and offering a high quality middle and high school program.
We are committed to holding ourselves to the highest standard of transparency and excellence when it comes to our academic, financial, and operational outcomes.
Kit Bay Area Schools is a locally governed nonprofit organization.
We adhere to the Political Reform Act, the Brown Act, the Public Records Act, and have a conflict of interest code approved by the Fair Political Practices Commission.
On behalf of all of our current and future families in the Bayview, many of whom have been asking for this school for several years, I respectfully urge you to approve our petition.
Thank you.
Please excuse the interruption.
Will the following speakers please line up?
Lenore Crawford, Pastor Walker, Den Hernandez, Eliza Rodriguez, Timothy Demery, Jelena Wright, Rosa Gonzalez, Luz Torres, Robrina Parker, Geraldine Anderson, Raven Campbell, Karina Hernandez, Ricardo Hernandez, Jacqueline Reyes, Andrea Evans, Carla Vasquez.
Good afternoon, board members.
My name is Shante Reed.
I am the founding operations manager for Kipp Bayview Elementary.
Real change in education is a grassroots effort in communities and schools across all of San Francisco.
Our efforts are a reflection of the choices parents make in deciding where their students have an opportunity to go to school and ultimately the future of their children.
Without educational options for families, we limit the type of diverse experiences and lives
our families and communities could have.
Equity and access to quality education is not a cliche, but it is a call to action that we intend to provide for our parents and families in the Bayview-Hunters Point community.
Our efforts to retain students in the Bayview-Hunters Point community is demonstrated through our community of practice.
That community of practice includes meeting with our parent design team, partnering with preschools and daycares and existing elementary schools in the community,
to move forward that effort.
Our goal is to build a community school and not a school that resides within the community.
We do hope that you do consider our petition on today.
Thank you.
Hi, Ona Keller with the California Teachers Association.
In Kip's presentation, they talked about wanting to have a sense of belonging.
And I think a lot of that is the community that makes up a school, the teachers and the counselors, the administrators, who are all there as caring adults to help these kids.
But you have to wonder, when Kip has only 25% of their staff have clear credentials in 17-18, they have an average of two years of teaching experience.
that what is KIPP doing that is not attracting highly qualified teachers who have clear credentials, who have experience in the classroom?
Why aren't they staying?
Why aren't they able to attract teachers of color?
Their Bayview school in 2014-15, according to EdData, had zero black teachers and two-thirds of their teachers were white.
There's something wrong when a school can't attract folks from the community to be there, to be part of the school, to be teachers, to be counselors, to be the librarians.
And so I would really question whether or not that sense of belonging is possible without people who are committed to staying at the school for the long term.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, board.
My name is Lenore Crawford and I am a mother of four and I am a Bayview resident.
Two of my children have gone through the KIPP schools and both are successful in college.
I am here to speak for my grandson who will be entering kindergarten in the fall of 2018.
I don't know if you've ever gone through the school board process to get your children into a school that has academic excellence.
It's a nightmare.
So I am petitioning and pleading with the board to give us parents, an active parent, school choice,
and to be able to decide if we want to send our KIPP where our tax dollars go for the public schools.
And prior in elementary school, I paid private schools for my kids.
And then when KIPP came into the picture, I was so thrilled because I didn't have to come out of my pocket to pay
for a private school for my children.
Thank you for this opportunity.
I petition you, please, to give us a consideration because KIPP brings Bill's character.
It helps them to have life skills.
Other than the strong academic performances, my son got a full scholarship to a college and my daughter is doing very well.
Thank you, board.
Honorable Board Members, I am Dr. Relius Walker, a pastor of the True Hope Church of God in Christ in San Francisco.
The True Hope Church in Bayview-Hunters Point stands as a beacon of light for approximately 50 years, improving
the community and housing, jobs, health and wellness and quality education.
The church has assisted several over the years to finish universities in this state and also traditional black colleges.
God, there is a crisis in education.
and African-American, Latinos, and Pacific Islanders in San Francisco.
We must rise to meet this challenge today, and I believe you board members can meet that particular challenge.
We must leave here today
and hopefully you will leave here by approving this particular charter.
I also have a resolution from my board members of my development corporation made up of about 10 churches that also sent a resolution asking you to approve this charter today.
Thanks very much.
Hola, me llamo Rosa y soy residente de la comunidad de Bayview.
Estoy presente porque estoy abogando por la escuela Key Bayview Elementary.
Ahorita mi hija Ashley va a Key Bayview Academy y est en el quinto grado.
Yo he visto que desde que entr a Key, ella se ha enfocado mucho en su estudio y su inters en la universidad ha crecido.
Yo creo que este cambio ha sido porque en Key Bayview Academy le dan tarea de lunes a domingo
y empujan a los estudiantes que sobresalgan acadmicamente.
Antes, cuando mi hija iba a Bred Hart, noms tena tarea de lunes a jueves y no senta esa presin para mejorar.
Estoy muy satisfecha con el crecimiento de Ashley, y eso me motiva a poner a mi hijo Joseph en Keep Bayview Elementary.
Yo me di cuenta que Keep iba a abrir una nueva primaria cuando vi que tenan una mesa
en un evento comunitario que se llama Resilient Bay View Neighborhoods en Octubre.
Por favor, aprueben esta escuela.
Hello, my name is Rose Stein.
I am a resident of the community, Bayview.
I am present because I want to advocate for the KIPP School, Bayview Elementary.
Right now, my daughter, Ashley, goes to KIPP Bayview Academy, and she is in the fifth grade.
I have seen how KIPP has helped her focus in school and in her studies.
and her interest in going to a university.
This change that KIPP Preview Academy has done and it's going to bring a lot of good to our community.
She receives homework from Monday to Sunday
and pushes the students academically.
Before my daughter used to go went to Bret Hart.
She only had homework from Monday to Thursday and she didn't feel that push.
I'm very satisfied.
with the growth of Ashley.
And that motivates to put my son Joseph in the KIPP Bayview Elementary.
I noticed that KIPP was going to have another school because of a booth that was
because of an event, a booth that the community had.
The name is Resolent Payview Neighbor Fest in October.
Please approve this school.
Hola, me llamo Luz y vengo a esta tarde para demostrar mi apoyo para la escuela Kid Bay Elementary en mi comunidad.
Cuando mi familia se cambi de Los Angeles a San Francisco, yo estaba viendo una escuela de alta calidad para mis hijos, Kevin y Melanie.
When my family moved from L.A., I was looking for a good school for my kids, Kevin and Melanie.
In Los Angeles, my son went to KIPP Comienza and he was very happy.
with the high academic expectivities and the focus
So when I moved to San Francisco, I looked for a similar school like KIPP, but I couldn't find one.
When I put Kevin
in Leonard Fillon Elementary School, his grades went down very much before he was very well in school.
My own son states that with KIPP, it was very different.
The subjects were very different, and the teachers would push them.
Next year, my daughter Melanie will be in first grade, and I want her to start KIPP.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
My name is Jelena Wright and I have lived in the Bayview for the last 10 years.
The Bayview is changing a lot.
I love to see the diversity in the community and I really don't like how people are getting pushed out of our community.
I'm speaking because I want my daughter to go to school, to go to a good school close to home.
I want her to get the education all kids of color deserve.
I think it is important for my daughter Taraji to go to school with kids that look like her and that want to succeed.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, board.
My name is Timothy Demery.
I'm here as a parent, an educator, a person with deep roots in the Bay Area, as well as a community engagement team member supporting Bayview Elementary.
I came here prepared with testimony.
However, a parent who couldn't make it today told me to read this.
My name is Lovely Wilson.
I'm a proud mother of four.
I would like to express my love, passion, and share how thankful I am for KIPP San Francisco.
The passion and engagement that the staff has toward families is amazing.
What stands out the most is the communication between the parents, which allows me, as a working parent, to stay connected at all times.
My hope is that my youngest two, three and five years old, have an opportunity to experience what KIPP has to offer at an earlier age.
I believe in my heart that KIPP would surpass my expectations when the elementary school is approved.
I need KIPP, our children need KIPP, and my community needs KIPP.
We need quality teachers and staff, we need a structured learning environment, and we need you all today to approve KIPP because it would be the best investment you would make in my community.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, board.
My name is Ricardo Hernandez.
I attend Archbishop Riordan High School in San Francisco, which is an all-boys Catholic school.
I went to Kid Baby Academy, and they gave me the tools I used to succeed.
I wouldn't be able to get up early without problems, sit up straight in class, read and write at a college level, and solve math problems without problems, without the KIPP curriculum and the dedicated teachers.
I want all the children in my community of Babies Hunters Point of San Francisco to have the option of going to elementary school
middle school and high school with the same values and college prep techniques.
You as the State Board of Education passing this charter can validate my desire for a distinguished education for the deserving children of my community.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, board.
My name is Dina Hernandez.
That was my son, Ricardo, that was just speaking.
Kid Bayview, being a Bayview resident means a great deal.
The school offers so much.
I wish that there was an elementary school that would have been able to give my son the tools that he has today, starting from the beginning.
He has started in Catholic school.
I put him in KIPP.
He did amazing things at KIPP Bayview Junior High.
He goes to a Catholic school because they gave him tools that he can further himself with a different education, even being in a Catholic school.
Bayview-Hunters Point deserves to have the choice for our students to be able to go to whichever school they choose, whether it's public, Catholic, charter.
We as residents should have that choice.
I don't understand how we have so much going on and the choice is not available.
Hopefully you'll grant us Kipp Elementary.
Good afternoon, board.
I'm sorry.
My name is Rovina Parker.
I was born and raised in the Bayview.
I have four children.
I raised my children in the Bayview in different public schools.
My last child is a product of a KIPP school, which then now is KIPP College Prep High School.
She went on to graduate from KIPP and now attends Paul Quinn College.
I say all that to say because
Being that I live in a Bayview, that means I've seen change.
Change is okay, it's good.
I feel that it's unfair that we can't have the opportunity to possibly have different schools or a choice of our school.
Being a grandmother also, I have a three-year-old that's growing up right now that we're looking for school.
So I ask that you please, within your hearts, grant us the opportunity of the school in the Bayview.
Good afternoon, Commissioners.
My name is Geraldine Anderson.
I live in the Bayview District of San Francisco.
KIPP stands for Knowledge is Power Program.
I stand here today as a parent first, registered voter, and 29-year veteran employee of City and County of San Francisco with a legal and moral obligation to ensure all the children in San Francisco have access to a world-class education.
KIPP has provided that to my son who is a KIPP graduate.
With data that was presented at the petition phase at the San Francisco Board of Education and the state level with the advisory commission last month I plead with you today to adopt the recommendation to approve KIPP TK to 4 elementary.
Our children deserve the best and I believe KIPP has a strong educational foundation and mentorship that would last a lifetime into college, career choices and community contributions.
Commissioners, let's make this positive change and make a difference in the lives of the children who we as parents would like to see graduate and lead productive lives contributing back to our society.
Thank you for your time.
Hello, my name is Raven Campbell.
I'm a 2017 graduate of Occidental College and current employee of KIPP Area Schools.
But before all of that, I was a middle school student at KIPP San Francisco Bay Academy.
In elementary school, I found myself at a school where I was the only black student in my classroom.
My teacher was not approachable and she did not like my inquisitiveness or imagination.
And eventually, me and my mother decided it was time for a change, and I ended up at KIPP, San Francisco Bay Academy, and turns out I had lived just a few blocks away.
Throughout my time at KIPP, my teachers set high expectations and held me accountable to meeting them.
They challenged me academically, but most importantly, they believed in me.
What a difference it would have made if I could have started there one year earlier or let alone when I was four or five years old Unfortunately, there was no KIPP elementary in San Francisco yet But now we have the opportunity to have one and students have the opportunity to start their journey to college earlier Please allow us to open KIPP in the fall.
Thank you
Will the last group of speakers please line up?
Jasmine Johnson, Julian Vasquez-Helwig, Eric Premack, Janelle Rooley, Anna Marie Azerbaijan, Maria Hansen, Shelley Mongmember, and Kevin Murphy.
Good afternoon.
My name is Andra Evans and I'm vice chair of KIPP Bay Area Schools.
I am very proud to have been involved with KIPP in the Bayview since we opened the first middle school 15 years ago.
KIPP has proven what I've always known to be true, that the black and brown children in the Bayview are smart, resilient, and just as capable of success as their peers in more affluent parts of San Francisco.
In fact, San Francisco College Prep, opened only four years ago, is already the highest performing school in the entire city for African American students.
These are not just statistics.
I have seen the transformation that KIPP education has personally in children's lives, and as you've heard from community members, they've seen it too.
That's why we're here today.
KIPP is not here asking for growth for growth's sake.
We are here because parents have come to us and asked us to open an elementary school.
It's the parents who are demanding a pathway from elementary school through high school.
And I ask that you approve this petition today.
Thank you.
Hi, good afternoon.
I'm going to be seating.
No, okay, well, I wanted to just re, I wanted to give justice to one of our parents' writing that she wrote.
I just didn't feel like the translation was well, and I just wanna respectfully repeat it in English.
I speak both Spanish and English, so I just wanna make sure that I really value what she had to say.
So her name's Rosa.
Hi, my name is Rosa, and I am a resident of the Bayview community.
I am here because I am advocating for KIPP Bayview Elementary.
Right now, my daughter Ashley attends KIPP Bayview Academy, and she is in the fifth grade.
I have noticed that since she entered KIPP, she has been focused much more on her studies, and her interest for the university has increased.
I think that this change is due to the fact that I put her at Kid Baby U Academy because they give her homework from Monday to Sunday, and that pushes her to excel academically.
While at Brett Hart, that wasn't the case.
She only had homework from Monday through Thursday.
She is interested in putting her child in Kit Bayview Elementary.
His name is Joseph, please.
Thank you for considering this story.
Thank you.
So I'm just going to be translating for Jacqueline, but I'm going to let her read the Spanish first.
Buenas tardes.
Mi nombre es Jacqueline y voy a leer un comentario escrito por mi compaera Diana Vasquez.
Ella es una mam lder como yo y no pudo asistir hoy.
Hi, I'm Jacqueline.
I'm going to read this commentary by Diana Vasquez who's a mother leader like myself who couldn't attend today.
Soy una madre del rea de la misin donde existen varias escuelas del distrito escolar y donde lamentablemente el nivel acadmico es mucho ms bajo que otras reas.
I'm a mom that lives in the mission area of San Francisco where there exists many schools of the school district that unfortunately have an academic level that's much slower than other areas.
In San Francisco we already have a middle and high school for KIPP, but the kids that come in to the KIPP schools come in very behind.
And here we know that an elementary school would be much better.
Yo soy madre de un nio con educacin especial, y asiste en la escuela Keep San Francisco Bay, y yo veo que es una escuela con muy buenas estructuras.
Mi hijo ha estado muy bien atendido hasta ahora, y aparte por la misma escuela le pusieron terapia ocupacional.
I'm a mother of a child that is in a special ed program and attends KIPP SFB.
And I have seen that the school has very good structures.
My child has been very well attended to and has even been given occupational therapy at the same school.
Why deny a new school that is for kids with a thirst for knowledge?
Nosotros como padres debemos tener opciones en donde matricular a nuestros hijos.
We as parents deserve to have options for our kids where they go where they want to go to school.
Good afternoon board president Kirst and state board members.
My name is Janelle Rooley.
I'm an attorney with the Law Offices of Young, Minnie, and Core here today in very strong support of Kip Bayview Elementary.
We urge you to vote for approval in accordance with both the CDE staff and also the ACCS recommendations for approval.
I wanted to underscore that today's decision is really only about the KIPP-Bayview charter petition itself.
There have been a lot of policy considerations that have been brought up, and maybe there's a time down the road to talk about those, but today our focus is on the charter petition, which presents a sound educational program whose petitioners are demonstrably likely to successfully implement
and that contains a reasonably comprehensive description of all the elements.
You have heard today a very clear call for an elementary school in the Bayview.
KIPP has been around in San Francisco in the Bayview for 15 years, so this is not fast growth.
We understand the district's position.
Nevertheless, charter schools are lawful entities with very specific statutory requirements, and we ask that you uphold those today.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
My name is Jasmine Johnson.
I am the founding assistant principal of Kipp Bayview Elementary School.
I'm going to be reading the testimony of a parent who unfortunately couldn't be here this afternoon.
Hi, my name is Marisol Rosales-Silva and I have been a resident of the Bayview District in San Francisco for nine years.
I have seven children ages 5 to 14 and have been a KIPP parent since 2013.
I need for KIPP Bayview Elementary School to open this coming school year in the Bayview so that my children and all children in my community can receive the opportunity to have an outstanding education in a public charter setting.
I have had the experience of being able to communicate and have such caring and empathetic team of teachers that will meet my children wherever they are and push them nonstop to make the level of achievement they need to.
With that, I share that my children all have different ways of learning, but their teachers have worked tirelessly with them in ways that help them individually rather than teaching one particular way and allowing them to fall through the cracks.
Thank you for your time and consideration for the approval of Kipp Bayview Elementary School.
Hi, Julian Vasquez-Heilig, Education Chair, California NAACP.
In the fall of 2016, the NAACP Board of Directors approved a national resolution calling for the moratorium on charter schools until transparency and accountability in their operations can be achieved.
Following this action, the NAACP created the Task Force on High-Quality Education,
The task force made four recommendations.
One of those recommendations was a rigorous authorizing renewal process for charters.
NAACP's national task force concluded that only local communities should serve as authorizers.
Charters should not be fiending to circumvent local control because they believe that the California State Board of Education is ready and willing to oblige their whims.
However, considering the historic lack of accountability for charter schools in California,
Excuse me, I'm so sorry, I lost my power there.
It is understandable that KIPP is here today.
A couple quick data points.
39% of charters approved by the State Board of Education have failed in California.
That's 15% higher than county and 10% higher than unified district.
Let me be clear, the California NAACP does not support the Bay Area KIPP charter petitions.
Thank you.
Eric Premack, Charter Schools Development Center.
This group obviously has an impeccable and long-term track record in this particular area of San Francisco.
They meet all of the criteria we urge you to approve.
It's unfortunate that the discussions get dragged down to the level that we're seeing today, and I'm hoping that
the kind of message that you folks say send through your actions up here, send a message out to the local level that these things should be dealt with in a more appropriate way locally.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, Colin Miller with the California Charter Schools Association.
I will associate myself with Eric's comments for brevity.
We are concerned about the influx of actions at local level that are essentially ignoring the intent and the spirit of the Charter School Act to encourage and support the establishment of charter schools as an integral part of the public school system in California.
We strongly support KIPP, and their organization has, as Eric said, just a tremendous track record of success in serving underserved communities.
Not in any way to dismiss the good work and the pockets of good work that are going on in San Francisco, but there are always opportunities for more excellent schools in every community, so we urge your support.
Thank you.
My name is Marisa Hanson.
I'm from San Jose.
I urge you to deny the San Francisco KIPP.
One thing you can do is you can go onto a website and you can look me up and you're going to find that I hold a valid teaching credential.
But one thing you're going to also find if you start looking at the KIPP teachers,
you're gonna find that a lot of them don't.
The things that you're hearing tonight are not true.
Me and a couple of my colleagues looked at our local KIPP that we have in San Jose and found that over half of the teachers did not have valid credentials.
They had permits, they had expired credentials, they were teaching outside of their credential.
That is not what our students deserve.
They deserve credentialed teachers.
Credentialed teachers, where can we find them?
We can't.
We have a shortage right now.
There are credentialed teachers in the San Francisco district and I urge you to deny this charter and allow them to stay in their school district.
Thank you.
Hello, my name is Karina Rodriguez.
I'm a former KIPP student from San Francisco College Prep.
I'm also one of the founding class members, meaning that I was the first one to graduate from that high school.
Also, I'm the founding member of a custom program we have in partnership with Boys and Girls Club.
We had a lot of things going on in high school.
But they weren't bad.
There were changes needed for the district itself.
We had classes, teachers, good, bad, but everything was made for a reason.
Every change that happened over there, it was for a reason.
Now if you go to a Cape high school, a Cape middle school you will see there is a good change in everything.
You will see students eager to learn, eager to go to school unlike other schools I've gone to.
Since I was nine I've gone to different schools, many from the district and two I wasn't actually very happy with my learning time in district schools and I was actually more eager to go to Cape schools.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, dear members of the State Board of Education and city staff.
I am Ana Maria Aristizabal.
I'm the Director of Growth at Keep Bay Area.
I'm a Latina, and I'm an immigrant myself.
And I work to make the dreams of these families a reality every day.
I am here to share with you our long-time intention to open an elementary school in the Bayview Hunters Point.
We were surprised and disappointed to learn that the district initial offer assigned us to the Mission Education Center campus in Noye Valley, over three miles and one hour away from our existing schools, walking.
We were deeply concerned over displacement because our families need their school close to their residences.
Moreover, we do not want to disrupt important SFUSD programs that serve immigrant children and families.
We understand the worries of the families in the mission that benefit from this program and are here petitioning against us.
It's our understanding that the district has a space in the classrooms, in the neighborhood, in the Bayview, and we welcome the chance to partner with the district to make a location viable for us and partner with the existing schools.
Thank you for your attention.
OK.
I now declare the public hearing closed.
And so we're ready for board member discussion.
It's typical that we let one of our liaisons speak first.
Board member Williams will lead off.
Excuse me.
So I want to say I really appreciate the comments and the approach taken by the San Francisco Unified School District staff.
Remember, it was refreshingly direct.
and candid about the concerns that they have at San Francisco Unified School District in terms of their facilities and their funding, and knowing that that's not a legal reason for denying a charter school.
I've been aware of the KIPP schools for at least 15 years, maybe 20 years.
Their network, I've never heard anything about their network.
I remember when I first heard about the first KIPP school in San Jose that I had heard of, and it was intentionally
and thoughtfully designed with a focus on low-income African-American students.
Since then, they've expanded the focus to always low-income students, but also Latino students.
And it had such a
I visited that school, and it had such a thoughtfulness, intentionality, and innovative kind of approach to thinking about the culture and the families that these kids came from and what would engage them the most in learning academics.
It was very impressive.
And I've had no reason, whether it was when I was executive director at EdSource and we studied charter school performance,
or whether I've been on the State Board.
I have not had an occasion since to do anything but keep my high opinion of KIPP schools since then.
I do want to clarify that the CDE's initial recommendation
was a preliminary recommendation for denial pending further information.
That's what they went into the ACCS with.
It was not a firm recommendation for denial.
They wanted to hear what the ACCS had to say.
And then they changed, the ACCS voted five to two for approving the KIPP school.
And CDE also subsequently changed their recommendation to a full,
a recommendation for approval, which I support.
Member Holladay, do you want to add at this point?
since you asked.
I think Janelle really stated it pretty well when she indicated that a lot of the comments that we've heard today are really about a greater policy issue about charter schools in the state and how they operate.
There were also some pretty glaring misconceptions from a number of the speakers.
But we're not here to make those sort of broad stroke legislative sort of decisions, nor are we here to necessarily dismiss every misconception.
What we are here to do, however, is to do a de novo review of the petition and of the petitioner, what the petitioners are offering to this community.
And when we do that, we listen carefully to the ACCS and we listen carefully to the CDE.
And in this case, I think that there's a consensus that this is a good opportunity for families in the Bayview 100 Point.
Any further board discussion?
Board Member Ortiz-Lacombe.
Yeah, I think so many things bubbled up today and we're hearing more and more of it.
And it's unfortunate, you know, when I when I see communities of color pitted against each other, that saddens me.
When we're looking at immigrant students, at least in face value, based on comments against African-American students, that's demoralizing.
That is not what the goal of education is.
And, you know, when we talk about the local control, I see local residents that are advocating for and against.
And I think you're right.
We're here.
And maybe it's worth explaining what our role is because it comes up over and over again.
You know, I hate to think of ourselves as having to assign roommates I don't want to live together to to really coexist at the local level.
But we do have a responsibility.
And it really saddens me to hear the pitting of to see the pitting of communities, specifically communities that are already marginalized.
So let's not do that to ourselves.
Let's not do that to our students, because both of our students, all of our students could benefit from different types of school.
My children attend district schools.
My husband's a district teacher.
That wasn't my choice.
But I can impose upon someone else the choice that they choose for their children.
So let's just be respectful of that.
I'm really saddened by this dynamic.
No, Board Member Strauss.
Just to everyone who came today to share their feelings on either side of the issue, I just want to thank you for taking the time from your days to be here and for the district and the petitioners.
To our liaisons, I do think, and just to build on what Member Ortiz-Lincoln said, is that there's a lot of issues here that are struggling between, with the community, the use of district space, the issue of outreach and support and wraparound services, which we know lots of families need, the conflict between
additional space that local schools can use and the entitlement under the law.
But we are limited by what we can do here.
And I think it's important.
You know, we we don't have the power to change the legislation.
We have to follow along with the role of the state board is in the appeal process.
So I think it might be helpful, maybe a member holiday just to kind of highlight for us again and for the public.
what the requirement is, because we had to do a fair and neutral hearing today, but what we can approve and not approve based on really restricted, the requirements are in the law of what we can approve or not approve, and I just think it might be helpful to revisit what our role is here, because we're not here to determine Prop 39 space, we're not here to determine, we only have decisions based on certain areas in spite of emotional,
decisions and how we feel about, our role is very, very clear in the law.
So I just appreciate that before we make a decision.
Lisa, would you come forward and just as staff and just guide us on what we as a board are required by statute to do?
Well, the Ed Code section, so pursuant to Ed Code section 4650J, so petitioners for a charter school that are denied at the local level may petition the State Board for approval.
Let me pull up my Ed Code section here.
It's based on certain conditions.
Okay, so I can first give you the reasons if that.
Oh, thank you.
That's not it.
We have legal counsel do this?
I think we ought to have legal counsel.
Give me just a sec.
I just am not finding it.
I'm sorry.
Go ahead.
Judy Sias.
Oh, here it is.
Sorry, Chewy.
I didn't see it.
There are four reasons for denial in the education code.
It's the same four reasons that are for denial at the district, county, and the state board level.
As I think Bruce or Trish said, it is a review of the petition at each level.
Even though you're an appellate body, you are not limited by the findings of the district or the county.
You do a de novo review of the petition.
The four findings are the same.
One of them is not, Lisa will read the findings, the fiscal condition, declining enrollment, that is not one of the reasons for denial.
So I'll let Lisa read them to you.
Thank you.
Sorry, Judy, I wasn't finding them.
So there are four reasons.
The charter school presents an unsound educational program for pupils to be enrolled in the charter school.
So they have to make, the board will have to make one of these findings just as the locals have to as well.
So the first finding is a charter school presents an unsound educational program for the pupils to be enrolled in the charter school.
The petitioners are demonstratively unlikely to successfully implement the program set forth in the petition.
The petition does not contain the number of signatures required, and the petition does not contain an affirmation of each of the conditions described in the subdivision also.
So it's the same conditions that would be at the local level as well.
And of course, to your point, Member Strauss, is that our hands are tied.
Legally in lots of ways as you say we are not here to make a decision about an appeal based upon whether or not It will involve a prop 39 situation or whether Financially it puts a burden on one entity or another The fact is that we have to look at this as a separate You know
task of making sure that the petition is going to meet those four requirements.
And then it's our obligation to approve.
And that's stated very clearly in statute.
I'll just elaborate on that a little bit more.
You mentioned, and so did Judy Saez, the de novo review.
And for those of you that don't know Latin, that's basically with fresh eyes.
We don't overturn district decisions or county decisions.
We look at what they did, but we have an advisory commission on charter schools that is in statute and has regulations and has a diverse group of people on it, including a representative of district superintendents and of counties and of traditional school teachers.
We listen to their advice and we listen to CDE's analysis, but in the end,
We need the law and the regulations give the State Board its own discretion to come to its own judgment about whether or not a charter petition adequately met the four conditions that Lisa just described.
And just a further note is that because we know this work is hard,
Because we know it's hard on you whether you're the petitioner applying or you're the district or the county hoping for a different outcome.
Because the climate has gotten more challenging and difficult.
Member Holiday and I attend every one of the ACCS meetings even though that's not in our job description.
We do that in between state board meetings because we want to get as much information as possible from as many parties in order to come to a decision about what we might recommend.
We take this very seriously.
Okay, I have at this point Karen Valdez.
Thank you.
So a point of clarification for me.
So I understand that the petition comes to the local level.
And so San Francisco looked at it.
They did their due diligence.
They had findings.
And I know that financially, we can't deny a charter based on that.
But it does contribute in some ways to unlikely to implement if the finances aren't all there.
And I know that in the original report, I mean, charter school is what I'm talking about in the budget.
And so then I know that in one of the online reports, the summary for ACCS, it talked about the concern about finances.
So my question is, how much did the petition change?
And I know in a de novo, it doesn't necessarily change, but there's agreements, right?
So what were the big agreements that helped us have more confidence in this going forward?
Does that make sense what I'm asking?
That was the information we talked about a little earlier on, the additional information we did ask for after the ACCS meeting.
So we did ask for some clarifying information.
For example,
We saw that the budget was highly reliant on philanthropic funding, so we asked for some additional information, like where is that coming from?
Does the KIPP Foundation already have that?
Is it in the bank already?
We did get some bank account information, some financial statements.
We then took that into account as we looked at the multiyear financial plan.
That was one element that we looked at additionally to feel that we could make a viable determination on their fiscal soundness from this point forward.
We also had they had included some information on the San Francisco proposition a and H that had passed We didn't see anything initially that that made us comfortable knowing that the charters that Kip would Be able to get actually use some of that proposition funding so they submitted some clarifying information to us like the narrative from the proposition and
that gave us more comfort in being able to then use those fundings, that funding they had in their budget, we had initially taken that out because we really couldn't verify that.
So we were able to put that back in to then determine if, on top of the philanthropic funding, that we felt their budget and the financials were viable.
So that's the type of thing that we did.
We also asked for some more clarification about employee qualifications and salaries, that kind of thing.
We had some questions about what they were accounting for in terms of their facility allotment out of the LCCF, so we got some clarification from them on that.
Then, we asked about whether their teachers were opting in if they were opting into CalSTRS.
So we asked for some clarification on that.
They said in this case that their employees would participate in the federal social security system and had an option for a 401k.
So it was those types of things that we asked for some clarification on that gave us a comfort level on their finances and then also more on their operational elements.
Does that help?
Okay.
Board Member Rucker.
Okay, so I also agree that there is clear legal guidance and requirements on how the board, in reviewing this case for an appeal, must act and what they must be guided by.
But what always presents a conflict for me, and it's been an ongoing concern during my tenure on the board, has been how, in doing the de novo review, how significantly different
the content or additional information that the board uses in its review that substantially changes the application that the county office or the local district school board would have reviewed in their process to either approve or deny the charter petition.
And I remain concerned that a lot of the information that is often added
to a petition that is reviewed in the department's process is more than merely technical and is more material than technical.
And so while the petitioners and the people who are opposed to the petition have very emotional concerns about why the petition is or is not a good idea,
And I agree with Board Member Lincoln that I also hate to see communities of color divided on these issues.
What continues to divide my decision-making process is my continuing concern about the differences between what is being reviewed here that is either technical or material and that
definition and that work continues to evolve.
I have an easier time when those changes are not made with approving and substantiating an appeal than when in cases like this there are clear additional pieces of information and content that have been added to the charter.
So, and I continue to ask every time we have
these particular petitions that come up like this with added new information that was not clarified or that doesn't seem to have been considered by the district.
I continue to have concerns that we don't resolve what is clearly material or what is clearly technical because it seems to change every single time to fit the circumstance with pretzel-like acumen
to make it work to it for the purpose of approving it.
So I have that concern.
And, you know, today for this petition, I'm not going to vote on it because that is my concern about what happened with the material that was and the additional content that was added for the review by the department.
Board Member Williams.
I want to be clear that the petition was not changed.
They did not change the petition that they submitted.
CDE asked them to clarify some things they did not understand in the petition, and that's the prerogative of the district, it's the prerogative of the county, and it's the prerogative of the state to ask for clarifications.
So for, as an example, one CDE practice is that if there is what they call soft money in the budget, philanthropic funding, they tend to take it out as not being, you can't count on it.
And that's a wise thing to do if it's, they're going to write grant proposals, they're going to try to raise money.
In this particular case,
KIPP was given the opportunity to explain how their foundation will fund this.
And KIPP is one of those foundations that if they're making a commitment to a school, it's money in the bank.
It's not really soft money.
So it's my understanding that you asked for clarification because it wasn't completely clear, but they did not come back.
There were no technical amendments.
Is that correct?
There were no modifications.
It was just asking for information that can be done at the district level and the county level.
And frankly, should be if there's an interest, a genuine interest by the district and county to understand the petition more fully before taking action.
Yeah, I'm ready for a motion.
Can we get a thank you.
Well, I just one brief comment and then I'll make the motion.
The brief comment is that I have over the five, six years now or whatever, been working with CDE.
I am impressed with how careful CDE's review of the petitions have been, how careful they are not to
make material revisions to a petition and stay within the realm of clarification and occasionally a technical amendment.
I feel very comfortable with what has been going on in that realm, even though I know others have a sense that it may not quite be that way.
But I'm saying this honestly from all the meetings and all the liaison calls that we have.
Anyway, I will move CDE recommendation.
And I'll second.
Motion by board members.
Yeah, go ahead.
I just had a comment, and it doesn't have anything to do with the motion.
Just in general, because I saw it here, we see a lot of these what I call dash PIs, where it's like data dashboard.
They're using colors, but then also the API numbers.
Can we not do that anymore?
Because I saw it in one of the slides to show how this school would compare to the neighboring schools, the rankings.
But it's like color and ranking, an actual number.
And I've seen this in a couple of charter proposals.
I think it's confusing, because now we have a new data dashboard.
Yeah, it was in the presentation.
I know we have a million other presentations tomorrow, so if you're listening, do not do the dash PI.
We have a dashboard.
It's color-coded.
Use that information.
We don't need to use numeric numbers and a color.
That does not exist.
It's not a real accountability system.
Thank you.
All right, I think we're ready for the vote.
All those in favor, raise your hands.
Okay, it carries.
Is there any abstentions?
One abstention.
Okay, so that carries.
Thank you.
Yeah, we need a break.
So let's, yeah, let's come back at 5 of 4.
5 of 4.
Okay.
Okay, the board will reconvene and we're now on to item six.
The establishment of a charter school in this Eastside Union High School District in the Santa Clara County Board of Education appeal.
Okay.
So we're on to item six and Lisa will present for the department and then we will proceed to the public hearing.
Item six is an appeal by KIPP Eastside High School to establish a new charter school pursuant to the Ed Code section that took me forever to find a few minutes ago.
Petitioners for a charter school that have been denied at the local level may petition the state board for approval of the charter subject to certain conditions.
This is a summary of KIPP East Bay.
On August 17, 2017, the Eastside High School District voted to deny the petition on a vote of three to two.
On November 1, 2017, the Santa Clara Office of Education voted to deny the petition by a vote of four to two.
On November 28, 2017, the petition was submitted to the State Board of Education on appeal.
The proposed plan is for a 9-12, a high school, a site-based program in Eastside High School area.
The targeted enrollment is 134 students in the first year of operation in 2018-19, increasing over the five-year period to 500 in 2022-23.
Again, targeting the traditionally underserved students in the Eastside High School District.
The Advisory Commission on Charter Schools met on February 7, 2018, and the commission moved to recommend approval of the petition.
The motion passed by a vote of six to one, and in the same case as the first KIPP we heard a little earlier, the petitioner submitted additional information to CDE after the ACCS meeting that was reviewed by staff as we did with the first petition for the elementary school.
The CDE is recommending that the State Board hold a public hearing to approve the request to establish KIPP Eastside High School for a five-year term.
The recommendation is based on demonstratively likely to implement the program due to a realistic financial plan and operational plan and a sound educational practice and comprehensive description of the educational program.
I am here and available for any questions that you might have.
Okay, thank you.
Is there any board questions that you would have that are technical before we begin?
Okay, not seeing any.
Then we will follow our procedure of last time where we have a public hearing.
So first, we're going to have an open public hearing.
Each side will have 10 minutes.
And then we'll have public comment at a minute.
and then the board will deliver further.
So we will start with those who support the recommendation to approve the charter school petition.
So these are people that support the petition by KIPP.
And so you have 10 minutes.
I declare the public hearing open.
Good afternoon board members.
Thank you for your time and attention.
You have invested to consider our charter petition.
I am Michelle Baraki the founding school leader of our new KIPP Eastside High School.
In 2009 I began my teaching career at a traditional public high school and in 2013 I joined KIPP San Jose Collegiate.
There as a teacher and assistant principal I've learned to be a leader in a school that holds high expectations
and provides a college preparatory education to all its students.
I am excited to remain in the San Jose community to found and lead our next high school.
KIPP has partnered with families in East San Jose since 2004.
We are here to provide students with the opportunity to be successful and to deliver on the promise of a college preparatory education.
Here are some words from our families about what KIPP means to them.
Outstanding.
Brilliant.
Quality.
Mejor educacin.
Outstanding.
Excelencia.
Buena educacin.
Mxima educacin.
KIPP is our future.
KIPP High School means continued success for my grandchild.
KIPP it the best.
Porque quiero que cumpla sus metas, sus logros, y alcance sus sueos.
KIPP es...
A great power, but above all, a community force for the whole community of here, of Quipraix, and of all of San Jose.
That's why we want you to support our community, whoever it belongs to.
Because they are given an attention that in other schools they don't have, and each one, what they need.
That they leave better prepared, they worry about them, as people, as individuals.
Because for me, they are some of the best high school I have ever known.
The best that exists here in the Bahia area.
Because for me, it is the best high school that San Jose, California can have.
I want to bring you to East San Jose.
Currently, we have three middle schools, KIPP Heartwood, KIPP Heritage, and KIPP Prize.
All schools have been locally authorized, including our existing high school, which was renewed November 2017 by Eastside Union High School District.
Next fall, for the first time, there are 300 KIPP students entering the ninth grade.
This is the primary driver for opening the second high school to fulfill the promise of an aligned KIPP path in San Jose from middle to high school for our families.
We know KIPP middle school students are best served by having the opportunity to attend a KIPP high school.
Students who attend KIPP Bay Area high schools are more likely to graduate from high school, matriculate to college, and graduate from college.
Specifically, here is the data for KIPP San Jose Collegiate.
We ensure all students fulfill the A through G graduation requirements that prepare students to be eligible to apply to college.
This compares to the 56% for the average of the district and only 35% for Hispanic students.
Through our KIPP through college program, we continue to work with students throughout their college education.
KIPP San Jose Collegiate student outcomes exceed those of peer student populations within Eastside Union High School District and within the state.
To highlight the achievement of our socioeconomically disadvantaged students, we are performing 23% higher in ELA and 26% higher in math compared to the district.
We also use advanced placement exams as a measure of our students' college readiness.
As you can see here, KIPP San Jose Collegiate students have a higher AP participation and passage rates as compared to the district and state respectively.
We are proud to share that our school program has been recognized as one of the top high schools in the nation.
Based on our strong track record and history of serving the Eastside community it was our hope to be locally authorized and continue to partner with the Eastside Union High School District.
In efforts to collaborate we met with district staff and board members since January 2017 to discuss our petition and accommodate their requests.
We even reduced the projective size of our school from 800 to 500 students.
Despite a positive recommendation for approval, the board denied our school with no findings saying the vote was symbolic in nature.
KIPP appealed to the district's decision to the Santa Clara County Office of Education.
The county staff also granted us a positive recommendation.
Unfortunately, SCOE wanted to unilaterally impose clauses that were unacceptable to KIPP
and did not agree to negotiate prior to November 28th in order to meet the SBE's timeline in case we could not reach an agreement and therefore denied our petition.
Though our families were deeply disappointed and disheartened by these events, we remain undeterred in providing the best possible education for our students.
We are thankful for the Advisory Committee on Charter Schools and the CDE staff for recommending the approval of our charter petition.
KIPP Eastside High School will build off the success of its sister school and provide all of our KIPP middle school students with the same opportunity to be successful and deliver on the promise of a college education, college preparatory education to all of our families.
The new KIPP Eastside High School's official name is KIPP Navigate College Prep.
We are committed to actualizing every student's potential by connecting students' purpose, talents, and passions to their learning experiences.
The logo serves as a visual representation of our school vision.
The six values represented by the star spell out circle, a representation of our community coming together.
Circles are powerful because they create a natural equity, inviting everyone to be seen and heard.
The compass is our personalized wayfinding tool used in service of creating inspired and purposeful lives.
Here is an overview of our school core program.
Today I will highlight a few of our instructional and cultural pillars.
Students need to be given academically demanding content and be provided with support.
The AP for all curriculum enables all students to participate in a truly rigorous academic program and tackle college level work in a supported and scaffolded way.
Many of our students enter ninth grade with a variety of needs and this school is ready to meet their needs through a multi-tiered approach that includes staff development, foundational courses and individualized interventions.
We are asking a lot of students.
Teachers, as teachers, we will close the gap in student learning while holding a high bar by building strong muscles in our academic power moves.
Lesson internalization is our deep level planning of the AP for all curriculum with a focus on creating exemplars and anticipating misconceptions.
Data-driven instruction uses classroom-level data to improve student outcomes.
When teachers engage in dialogue and make sense of the data together, they develop a much deeper understanding of what is going on relative to student learning and can create a strategic reteach plan to close the gaps in student learning.
Observation feedback is critical to the growth and development of our teachers' execution, where teachers will receive regular feedback on their teaching practice.
At KIPP, character education is just as important as academics.
Therefore, we have a robust advisory curriculum that focuses on social-emotional learning for students to foster and maintain positive relationships with themselves, one another, and the community.
They learn to leverage their individual and collective strengths for the good of others.
Students rigorously extract value from failure, reflect, and grow.
Social emotional learning helps build a strong culture.
Students have a sense of belonging to authentic relationships with one another.
SEL also amplifies academic results.
Students feel safe enough to take academic risks to really grow.
Phase work is the personalized SEL curriculum which students and staff engage in in advisory to explore their own identity, strengths, passions, and align their actions to their personal and professional goals.
Each day, students will have access to learning opportunities to open their doors to their futures.
Four years from now, we will have our first class of students cross the stage at graduation with their ability to articulate their purpose and how they're connecting their education to their career aspirations.
Students will confidently step into the future with real world rigorous learning experiences to reflect upon.
They will have an unwavering belief in themselves and one another and what they can accomplish because they're comfortable with courageous challenges.
Students will look back on their high school experience with pride of their individual and collective growth and achievement.
With innovative mindsets, our graduates are equipped and ready to take on the world.
Thank you and we look forward to addressing your questions.
We now have 10 minutes for the people opposed to the petition.
Good afternoon, President Kirst, state board members, community, and staff.
My name is Christelle Johnson, and I serve as the director on the charter school oversight and monitoring team for the Santa Clara County Office of Education.
The Santa Clara County Board of Education is the largest county authorizer in the state of California, with 23 authorized charter schools, which serves approximately 10,000 students, and spans 31 districts across Santa Clara County.
On September 5th, 2017, the County Charter Schools Office received a petition from the KIPP Eastside High School Charter Team seeking to establish and operate a public charter high school for grades 9 through 12.
This petition was submitted on appeal from the Eastside Union High School District.
On September 20th, the Santa Clara County Board of Education held a public hearing for KIPP.
SCCOE charter staff reviewed the KIPP Eastside High petition and recommended approval of the petition during the Santa Clara Board decision hearing on November 1st.
The approval contained several items which needed to be addressed within the MOU process to be completed by January 31st, 2018.
After review of the proposed MOU and the recommendations made by school staff, on October 30th, KIPP requested that SCCOE revise the terms and the recommended board resolution for approval and have the MOU completed by November 28th.
Or that an alternative is that Santa Clara County Board of Education move to deny the charter so that KIPP could appeal directly to the State Board of Education.
On November 1st, 2017, the Santa Clara County Board of Education voted 5-2 to deny KIPP Eastside High School petition on the grounds that KIPP would not agree to the proposed expectations expressed in the approved resolution and proposed MOU.
Good afternoon my name is Chris Funk superintendent for Eastside Union High School District and my goal tonight is this afternoon simply to provide you some context of how my board of trustees voted to talk a little bit about choice and about the process for charter school appeals.
First and foremost, when you look at the intent of the charter school law, I think Eastside is the poster child of that intent.
We currently have 12 charters in our district, 10 approved by us, two approved by the county.
We have 11 comprehensive high schools.
It was never the intent of the charter school law to have more charter high schools than the high schools that represent the district.
We collaborate amazingly with our charters in the sense that no charter has gone to the county on appeal for a renewal.
Our process is transparent, it's fair, and we have renewed over and over again with our charters, including KIPP.
We have provided five-year leases to all of our charters that are 10 of the 12.
Two of them are located at National Hispanic University.
Five-year leases so that we don't have to do the dance of Prop 39 every single year.
We have provided bond monies to upgrade and build facilities for our charters and provide technology.
We've included language in our upcoming June 5th parcel tax to provide to our charter schools.
We've even provided a approved agreement from the board to allow KIPP to build an 800-student high school on the district campus.
KIPP did not pull their contingencies.
At the very last minute, they missed their deadline to release their contingency, and that deal died.
For 800 students, we would not be here today if they had approved that, which our board had signed and sealed, ready to go.
When you talk about the intent of the law, it's to provide underrepresented schools or neighborhoods that have underperforming schools an opportunity for a charter school.
We have 25 high schools in Eastside Union High School District.
When you look at our data, our graduation rates have gone up six straight years.
The state-defined graduation rate is 85% for our students.
It's 80% for African American, it's 77% for Latino.
But when you look at our locally defined cohort rate, kids that start with us and attend 720 days all four years, our cohort rate jumps to 95% at the district level, 96% for African American students, and 91% for Latino students.
Our kids continue to grow because our enrollment grows throughout the four years, whereas KIPP and other charter school, their enrollment goes down.
And so I have a lot of respect for the program for KIPP, but when you talk about 100% of your kids are A through G compliant, but you don't have the same number of kids, your seniors that you started with in ninth grade, that skews the numbers.
The whole point of why my board chose to vote no is because we've reached that tipping point.
We are in declining enrollment.
At the very same board meeting to review this petition, they had a resolution to lay off 140 employees over the next two years in order for us to have a positive three-year budget.
How could they be fiduciary responsible members of their community, voting members of the community, elected by their community to lay off individuals and approve another charter for 500 students, which would then take away the support structures that we have in place in Eastside.
They just could not do that.
And so yes, we talked about the last presentation, and we have this review of what the law states.
But this board has the power and has demonstrated the ability to skirt the law in the past.
I was at the last month advisory commission when the chair of the commission sits there and gives advice, executive coaching, which I believe in amazingly, executive coaching should happen, but giving executive coaching to the petitioner on how to improve their presentation, how to improve their petition to make it stronger.
That's not defining the law.
That's skirting their responsibility.
This board has also approved charters in the past, not necessarily the KIPP San Francisco, where there has been material change, where grade levels have been lopped off petitions, and this board has approved it.
And the elected officials at the local LEA and the county denied it.
So I'm not asking you to advocate for new law.
I'm not asking you to change the law.
I'm asking you to use your ability to take a stand and say enough is enough and support Eastside Union High School District, support Senator Beall's SB 1362,
to allow school districts the ability who have declined enrollment, who have charters already in their school district and in the neighborhoods where new petitions are being requested, so that school districts have the opportunity to deny that.
Not a single one of our charters is fully enrolled, including KIPP Collegiate.
Every single charter has kids from outside the district.
Our families have choice.
They have amazingly great schools to choose from.
We're asking you to support the fiduciary responsibility that our elected officials have to our community and deny this petition.
Not deny it because KIPP is not a solid program.
Not deny it because we're against charters.
Eastside has demonstrated that we support charter schools.
We're asking you to support us because we're in decline enrollment and we cannot have more charters at the expense of laying off teachers.
Thank you so very much and I'm here to answer any questions for you.
Thank you.
Okay that concludes those opening statements and now we will continue with the
public comment one minute each.
Will the following individuals please line up for item six.
Kent Burke, Michael Flores Castaneda, Mike Hutchison, Jenny Ludwig, James Staten, Tracy Brown Gallardo, Alita Fisher, Melissa Dar, Adrian
Adam Cordova, Anna Keller, Rosalyn Taylor, Andrea Evans, Maria Yelpik, Patricia Martinez, Nolan Highbrow, and Janelle Rooley.
Pass the paper.
I'm waiting for the paper.
Go ahead, please.
My name is Ken Bird.
I'm here on behalf of the California Teachers Association.
I'm passing out to you something that was posted on the website.
The question really is, should this petition be denied?
Because what the petitioner referred to, well, he couldn't agree to certain conditions, and they kind of glossed this over.
The issue was, they were asked to commit to file a government code 1090.
That's the general conflict of interest statute.
Now, does that apply?
I have a 17-page opinion from the legislative analyst that says it does apply.
Now, we don't have time for you to discuss the issue, but there's a difference between the corporation code and the government code.
It essentially says, I'm not going to have a conflict of interest for everyone.
So I leave it there.
Query, how can any member of the state board in good conscience be mindful of his or her fiduciary duty to the public trust to approve an appeal when the appellant charter school petitioner will not commit to the most simple basic conflict of interest law on the statute?
Thank you.
That's an issue you need to discuss.
That's litigation pending.
Mike Hutchinson with the Oakland Public Education Network and Journey for Justice National Alliance, and we stand in solidarity with Black Lives Matter and the NAACP in calling for a moratorium on charter schools and school privatization.
In Oakland, we have the highest rate of charter schools in the state of California.
And of our 40-plus charter schools, only two of those schools have been started in what we call the hills in Oakland.
All the other charter schools have been started in low-income communities of color.
And we know that if charter schools provided a better educational outcome, our families in the hills would be demanding charter schools.
Instead, the opposite has happened, and they've only been put in our neighborhoods.
And I actually take offense to the idea that the community is pitting ourselves against each other.
What's happening is the same colonial model where charter schools are dropping into our communities, and they're the ones driving this wedge in our community.
You have the authority to vote no.
you actually have the moral responsibility to vote no.
And many of us across the state of California are looking for leadership, are looking for somebody who's gonna stand up for our communities who over history have been disadvantaged, and the charter schools are just adding to that disadvantage.
So please vote no, please vote your conscience, and use Oakland as an example.
They haven't helped us.
Jenny Ludwig, Eastside Union High School District, nationally board certified teacher, 2007 master's degree in teacher leadership.
Why am I telling you this?
I want to let you know that I do think I'm qualified to have an opinion on unsound educational practices.
Is it an unsound educational practice when you have test scores pulled from great schools that say that you have 29% of your Hispanic students proficient in math?
Yet, they are claiming 100% graduation rate on the same website.
When we take our four-year graduation rate, you take Independence High School where San Jose Collegiate is housed, they have 85% four-year graduation rate as does KIPP.
What is happening to those kids?
How do they have 100% rate but only 85% on a four-year level?
Because they are kicking out their kids when they are not reaching that 100% mark.
Just before graduation, they are obviously kicking out their kids, and we know this.
They are sent back to us.
Our principal just told me that.
And they come back to us, and then they change our statistics.
They have AP classes.
Great.
Only 51% of their kids were passing the AP classes, according to the website I looked at, not what she's putting up there.
And our students at Independence, at the same school where they're housed, have 60% pass rate.
So I ask you to vote no based on educational practices.
Thank you.
Hello, hi.
My name is James Staton.
I'm with the San Jose Silicon Valley NAACP.
And we are, I'm here because we oppose this petition.
We oppose it on several grounds.
One, we have a national moratorium, a resolution calling for a national moratorium on charter schools because we have concerns about oversight, fiscal accountability, and the targeting of black and brown low-income communities.
Two, we believe in local control.
And this petition seems to skirt that.
Two, locally elected bodies of officials have looked over this petition and rejected it.
And three, the diversion of scarce, very scarce resources in the district.
As I stated before, there are 12 charter schools in the district that are already using these resources.
We do not need any more.
Thank you.
Good afternoon board my name is Rosalyn Taylor and among other things I am the mom of three kids who are black who all graduated from public high school and the University of California system.
I have been teaching math in Eastside San Jose for 31 years longer than charter schools have existed in the state of California.
It began at 100 schools there are now 1,200 charter schools in California 12 of which are in my district and three are at one school and none of these charters are at capacity.
If KIPP and the other charter schools that we already have are not a capacity, why do we need another charter school?
Our publicly elected school board denied the second KIPP.
Our publicly elected County Board of Education denied the second KIPP in part due to the KIPP Foundation refusal to abide by state law, including California Code 1090.
I ask you, the appointed State Board of Education in California, to honor the voters of Santa Clara County and deny the petition.
Thank you.
Please pardon the interruption.
Will the following speakers please line up?
Isis Diaz, Carmen Delevos, Roberto Sota, Melissa Albrega, Aidan Ma, Katie Peterson, Faro Quadri, Ellie Herrera, Quinn Ma, Beth Thompson, Maria Huxley, Marissa Hanson, Lynn Johnson, Derek Gasly,
Kristen Rivers and Cassandra Salcona believes what this is.
Good afternoon again.
My name is Janelle Rooley, attorney with the Law Offices of Young, Middy, and Core in support of KIPP Eastside High School.
We heard a little earlier the six reasons that a charter petition can be denied.
That's what the law allows, and that's what we're operating in today.
Within the Charter Schools Act, there are actually a few different mentions of what the legislature's intent is.
The legislature declares what its intent is.
None of those mentions talk about the number of charter schools within a particular school district or jurisdiction.
The district's policy arguments and disagreements with the plain legal requirements are better and more appropriately before the legislature.
Neither school districts nor the State Board of Education have the legal authority to decide what's enough.
Only our elected officials can do that and the district is actually expending resources on a bill to do that, to advocate for a bill to do that.
We ask again that you focus on this particular charter and help KIPP to fulfill a promise that it made to hundreds of middle school students in San Jose to allow them to continue on to a KIPP program for high school.
Thank you.
Hello, everyone.
My name is Maria Yepes, and my daughter, Emily Prado, is an eighth grader at KidPrize.
And I'm here as a part of the Eastside San Jose community.
A couple of years ago, we were dragged into a very devastating situation as a family, and KidPrize became our main support system.
Our school cares about academics, but also about my kids' well-being.
her emotions, her struggles, and her family.
Ms.
Angrelian, Ms.
Machado, with my daughter's teachers, they were there for us every step of the way of our recovery until Emily got back on her feet emotionally and her grades went back to normal.
KEEP shares our family values and even we have the same goal.
I'm here to ask you to say yes to our new high school.
We need it.
Allow Keep Navigate to help me to walk my daughter to college.
Thank you.
Good afternoon everyone.
My name is Patricia Martinez and I am a parent at KIPP Heartwood Academy.
My son's name is Santino Martinez.
I would like to share my personal experience with KIPP's special education services.
My child attended the local schools before attending KIPP but unfortunately he was not being provided the services he needed to meet his IEP goals.
In our educational goal, if our educational goal is to prepare our children for higher education in the workforce, then we should teach our kids in a setting that prepares them for just that.
I keep Santino's place in general education classes and gets pulled out for services that he needs.
He is able to learn math, social studies, science, reading, and writing with the rest of his peers and still receive the support he needs to meet his IEP goals.
This type of setting is a direct reflection of the real world.
College students attend class with all individuals, as I did, and those that need accommodations, as I did, and services received and the same goals for the workforce as I do now.
Santino started fifth grade in Cape with six goals and now he's only time with one goal and promoting to ninth grade.
Please please approve this high school.
Appreciate your time.
Thank you for your time.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, my name is Isis Diaz and I'm currently a college counseling fellow at KIPP San Jose Collegiate.
I attended both KIPP Heartwood Academy Middle School and KIPP San Jose Collegiate High School before going on to Notre Dame De Namur University.
I returned to work at KIPP because I wanted to pay it forward and help students get to and through college just like I did and that was in big part thanks to KIPP.
My eight years with KIPP were not easy, but the minute I stepped into a college classroom, it was clear that they were worth it because I was prepared for the four years that lied ahead.
I'm a part of our KIPP through college team, which supports students while they are transitioning to college and while they are in college.
My favorite part of my job is the fact that we are equitable in our work.
It does not matter if a student has a 4.0 or is not eligible for a four-year university straight out of high school.
We provide support and access to resources needed to help every single student succeed.
I chose a career in education because I believe in our school systems and I believe that every single child has the right to a quality education.
I'm living proof that KIPP is that place.
Please allow for KIPP Navigate to open so that all our KIPPsters can continue their experience.
Thank you.
Good evening board.
My name is Heriberto Soto.
In two years, my daughter is gonna be looking for a high school.
My daughter's got a good foundation from K-Middle School.
My older son, he just graduated and went to UC Merced.
So sometimes we must wanna say that everything is the same.
In this school, they give us really good education.
Even though, you know, when we have the Hispanic people we have in tact that we are not to learn, KIPP have proved the opposite.
Our children are going to four-year universities, and so we don't want to say that some other people are smarter.
So we know we have to work harder, but we are getting there.
Please approve the school.
Make sure that most of our kids have a great education.
We wait for Superman for too many years.
After I was looking at the APIs, I understood that I had to look for something else.
We need big solutions for big problems.
Thank you very much.
Hello, my name is Melissa Alvarenga and I am the Community Engagement Manager at KIPP Bay Area Schools.
I want to talk about the work that I've been doing in the Eastside Union High School District with families, community organizations, and alongside Ms.
Verrocki in preparation of KIPP Navigate College Prep.
Students and families have been part of every single step of the process creating a vision and design for the school.
Our goal is to be a school of the community and not just in the community and build it together and make sure it reflects the needs and the interests of the people you see in this room.
We held multiple meetings at each one of our middle schools and also in local youth centers and community centers where families had the opportunity to be decision makers and advocates in the political arena and many inspired to run for office themselves.
I hope you keep these same families and students at the forefront as you make the final decision today.
Thank you.
Good afternoon board my name is Katie Peterson and I'm a nationally certified school psychologist who has supported our KIPP schools in San Jose over the past four years.
As advocate of students with disabilities and mental health needs my first priority is to ensure that the needs of all of our students
are being met.
Our team members do whatever it takes to support students' special needs.
As our saying goes, we find a way or make one.
We have partnered with the Diagnostic Center of Northern California to build a program supporting students on the autism spectrum from the ground up.
We have and continue to train our teachers and staff on evidence-based practices to ensure that our students are thriving in our care.
I came here today to be a voice for students with disabilities.
Your vote in favor of KIPP Navigate College Prep will allow us to provide a continuum of care and support for our students with disabilities and their families with whom we have had the privilege of building relationships over the past four or more years.
Thank you very much for your consideration.
Buenas tardes, voy a hablar en espaol porque mi ingls es un poco mocho todava.
Voy a hacer un talk con mi compaera.
Hola, buenas tardes.
Mi nombre es Carmen Davalos.
Soy madre soltera y tengo dos nios.
Uno atiende a la escuela de Rocketship y uno est atendiendo a la escuela de Keep Harvard.
Yo siempre he dado la, inculcado la educacin a mis hijos.
Tengo mi nia, se llama Atsiri, ella ha tenido la pasin por la educacin siempre.
Ella cuando comenz con Rocketship ha demostrado que es muy lista para aprender.
Ella tiene una muy buena fundacin acadmica.
Ella termin cuarto grado a nivel de octavo grado en literatura y matemticas en sexto.
Kim Naviguer es mi opcin que yo quiero para mi hija para que ella siga creciendo acadmicamente y tenga un futuro lleno de opciones.
Estoy orgullosa de que mi hija ha logrado esto con su gran esfuerzo, teniendo un 95% en todas sus clases.
Ya estamos hablando acerca de la cual universidad ella va a ir ella quiere ir a la universidad de Santa Clara yo quiero que vaya a Stanford por eso pero ya dice que no quiere irse lejos de mami
Por eso estoy tomando mi tiempo, mi da de trabajo hoy, para representar a muchos padres que no pudieron llegar hoy porque no pudieron.
Si se venan de trabajar, los podan correr.
So estoy aqu porque pienso representndolos a los paps que no pudieron llegar.
Pido su apoyo para nuestros estudiantes que sern los prximos profesionales.
Y pido la aprobacin para esta escuela que es la luz al final del mundo para nosotros.
Gracias.
Hi, my name is Carmen, and I am a single mother, and I have two children.
At City is attending KPA, KIPP.
I have always included the importance of education to my children.
At City has always had a passion for school.
She started at Rocket Ship.
She has a good academic foundation.
She finished fourth grade with an eighth grade level in literature.
KIPP Navigate is my option that I want for my daughter so she can keep growing academically and so she can have a future full of options.
I am proud of my daughter.
what she has achieved till now, having 95% in all of her classes, we are now talking about what university she will be attending.
She wants to attend Santa Clara, but I want her to attend Stanford.
She doesn't, however, want to go far away from me.
That is why I am here, taking a day off of work
representing a lot of the parents that could not attend.
I ask for you to support our students since they will be our next professionals.
For the parents of the future, for the parents of low income, KIPP is our light at the end of the tunnel.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, respected State Board of Education members.
My name is Farouk Khadri.
First of all, I would like to thank you guys to give me this forum to speak to you.
I am a proud parent of four boys that are in the KIPP system.
Two are in the high school, one is in a middle school, and one graduated from KIPP high school and is attending UCLA at this point.
It was the hard work of the teachers, the staff members, the counselors, and the leadership of KIPP that made
it possible for my son to be able to attend UC.
KIPP is one of the schools that just does not get them to college.
It is one school, I don't know if any other high school does this, makes a mentor for that graduate to go and be with him for the four year until he graduates from university.
which is a big thing for me.
With the help of this board today, we will be able to open another such jewel in the Eastside Union High School, which will provide parents a choice that is best for their child.
I strongly believe that this KIPP Navigate is, you should approve that and thank you again for your time.
Good afternoon, my name is Elia Reda and I am the founding operations manager and a KIPP parent myself.
KIPP schools have played a very impactful role in my family.
As a single mother raising two girls, their academic success had always been my number one priority and I decided that KIPP was a natural fit to how I raised my daughters.
As my daughters attended King High School, they faced social, emotional challenges.
Many times I felt hopeless not knowing what I could do next to help my daughters.
The support and love that my daughters and I received from the teachers, counselors, and admin was beyond what I could have wished for.
The saying, it takes a village to raise a child was true in our case.
My daughters and I could not have done it without the village that loved us, supported us, and pushed us through those very dark times.
My daughter's graduations and trips, taking them to college were for me the proudest moments ever.
I was proud, I was happy, I was excited because the dream of watching my girls go to college was coming alive.
And I felt so blessed and grateful for the KIPP Village that helped me get my little girls to college.
Please support the opening of KIPP Navigate College Prep.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, board members.
My name is Aiden Mai.
I am a 12-year-old 8th grader and a member of the founding class of KIPP Prize Preparatory Academy in San Jose.
I started my journey with KIPP in August of 2015, and it has been quite the ride.
I can tell you right now that I am not the same little 6th grader who first walked into KIPP, and I have grown so much at KIPP, not only intellectually, but as a person as well.
KIPP is constantly highlighting themes of social justice and change in its curriculum, even in math class.
All of us have taken the guidance of our teachers to change the world for ourselves and others to heart.
Early this morning, my 8th grade class led a protest in San Jose to call for the tightening of gun laws in America.
KIPP is educating the future leaders of this country and your approval vote would allow more and more kids to achieve their ambitious dreams.
Mahatma Gandhi and Barack Obama have told us to be the change that we wish to see and that is what KIPP is training us to do.
Your vote would have a huge impact on my classmates and I. Thank you for your time.
Good afternoon.
My name is Lynn Johnson.
I'm a teacher at Oak Grove High School in Eastside Union High School District, but more importantly than that I am also a parent.
I have two students who attended the Eastside Union High School District, one who graduated from Oak Grove High School where I teach and where they are
planning to cram in the newest KIPP school.
He is currently a U.S.
Marine firefighter serving your country and keeping you all safe.
His twin graduated from Mount Pleasant High School and is currently a civil engineering student at Oregon State University.
If you want to look for choice in schools, there's choice in schools.
First of all, the other thing I'd like to say is, in my opinion, there are no traditionally underserved pupils in the Eastside Union High School District.
I'm actually an alumni from a bazillion years ago.
And if all KIPP is trying to do is find a home for their middle schoolers, they're not actually serving people in the Eastside Union High School District.
But what I really wanted to talk about was the fact that there is no space at our school at Oak Grove for this school.
They are going to get rid of our emotionally disturbed program, they're gonna move them onto campus where those kids are gonna be surrounded all day, as well as our counseling program.
Thank you.
Hi my name is Kristen Rivers.
I am also a national board certified teacher who actually is not currently teaching but I'm here as a parent.
I have three children in the Eastside Union High School District and
I just really wanted to emphasize I had my daughter in a charter school so I am not anti-charter but as a public school teacher I have also seen what happens to the resources and the kids and the parents and the involved families when charters open up.
And I want to offer that this, if they build it, they will come, we have seen, is not bearing out in the east side.
We have enough charter schools.
What we need is attention to the schools that are already there and doing amazing, wonderful things, as I have seen with my own children.
So thank you.
Hello, my name is Marisa Hansen.
I'm a teacher in the district as well as a community member and a parent of a special education student.
And as you might have seen in the petition, special education does not mirror what we offer in Eastside.
A child like my son who would be accepted in Eastside wouldn't be accepted in KIPP.
They don't offer the services.
So that is a reason in itself to deny it.
It does not mirror what the district has.
Also, like we talked about, there is choice.
There are 12.
The current KIPP has room.
50 of those students are not Eastside.
At least 50.
There could even be more.
Our district was willing to consider increasing that KIPP number.
if we remove the students that were not Eastside and we added in the students that they said they needed to do.
So we were open to compromising, but they were not.
At the county board, they actually encouraged the county board to deny them so they could come before you and let you approve them.
They said that.
I hope all of you watched that video.
Thank you.
Hi, my name is Derek Grasty.
I'm a parent, educator, and community leader.
Both my sons are graduates of the Eastside Union High School District.
They're both college graduates and beyond.
Eastside offers a wonderful program.
The charter does not offer real choice.
Choice would be a performing arts academy or a STEM or STEAM magnet school.
They're not offering that.
They're trying to replicate what the district already does.
There's already choice there.
And they're not doing it at the high level that the district can provide it.
There is no science lab.
Music is not there.
Sports is not there.
And in terms of special education, that's already been stated.
But it's very telling that a psychologist spoke and not a special education teacher because they don't have one.
Thank you.
Would the last group of speakers for item 6 please line up?
Patty Cortese, Bill Simmons, Michael Ho, Naja Ali,
Gripal Kaur, Tina La, Valera Cortez, Jessica Galbaran, Shannon Fan, Teresa Martin, Nathan Bellamonte, Israel Alvarez, Anne Finney, Lisa Baker, Serena Gonzalez, Manuel Dominguez, Kevin Murphy, and Anna Marie Edzer-Bezal.
Good afternoon honor board members.
My name is Quynh Mai.
I'm a parent of four thriving students at KIPP.
Over the years our family has experienced various school models from public to private and charter and found that KIPP's most effective in bringing out the scholar in our students as well as offer supports to those that need the extra help.
Our Bay Area community loves it, that keeps high quality of education, is accessible, free and open to all, with a student body a true reflection of the local community, with all of its diversity, special needs and strengths.
The argument that keeps new school will take resources away from public school should not be relevant in this petition.
We need to learn to share resources and enable all students, not to limiting our choices for our kids.
Being from Silicon Valley, which is known for its innovation, we should embrace healthy competition in education.
It should not be divisive debate of public versus charter school, but a collaborative partnership for our children's future.
We hope to count on your approval.
Thank you.
Good evening board, my name is Juanita Rodriguez and I am reading this letter from Trustee Grace Ma from Santa Clara County Board of Education.
I appreciate your board work in supporting sound charter schools, promoting innovative and willingness to approve petitions which meet the intent of the charter school law to provide choice to communities along with improving pupil learning
with innovative practices.
I also appreciate your boards cutting through various red hearings of administrative controls that are being imposed on charter control that are not stated in ed code for charters and are specifically left in a gray zone of regulations.
I hope that with an approval of charter school on appeal to your board that you would for the record state your decision based on the fundamental tense
of the law choice for communities and improving pupils outcomes.
Thank you, Grace Ma.
And I'm also a parent from a student that's at Kipp Price.
Please approve the charter.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, my name is Marie Kawase Huxley and I'm the Chief of Schools for Kitt Bay Area Schools.
We are committed to getting all of our students to and through college.
You heard this commitment and some of the voices today from students, staff, and families.
Our student retention rate is 91%.
The majority of our families that leave report the reason for leaving is due to relocation.
As a region of schools, we are committed to restorative practices and to social emotional learning.
We're proud of the strength of our school communities.
Please vote to approve our KIPP High School.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, I'm Beth Thompson, the founder and CEO of Kip Bay Area Schools.
After 10 years of working closely with the Eastside Union High School District and having received a positive staff recommendation for our proposed high school, we were surprised and disappointed by their board's decision to deny our charter petition without findings.
We have a long track record of success in East San Jose and pledge to continue to hold ourselves to the highest standard of transparency and excellence when it comes to our academic, financial, and operational outcomes.
We are deeply committed to responding to our middle school parents and providing a KIPP high school option for all of our middle school students in East San Jose, which is why we are petitioning for the approval
of KIPP Navigate College Prep.
Over 250 families have already submitted enrollment applications for our proposed school.
Please let their voices be heard.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, Patty Cortese, Vice President of the Eastside Union High School District Board.
I'm here to add my personal perspective as a board member and a 20-year volunteer in a mentoring program in the district, working with students who have greatly struggled with school.
Due to declining enrollment and other factors, our district is facing layoffs, including many positions that support some of our most vulnerable students.
Positions like counselors, advisors, and activities directors among them.
An additional charter would only exacerbate this situation.
As a board member, I am responsible for ensuring a high quality education for all of our students, especially the students I have worked with in the past, those who need these vital services in order to succeed.
Opening a new school under these circumstances would be imprudent and an injustice to the 23,000 students in our comprehensive schools.
Non-cooperation with unjust laws is one of the most powerful tools for social change.
Thank you.
Good afternoon board members my name is Michael Huynh and I am here to shed some light on the negative impacts of KIPP on at Independence.
As a student athlete and being a team captain I've seen the negative impacts on not only my athletes as well as my fellow peers.
During my sophomore year, my track team was only able to practice at the most two times on our own track.
Track has very technical events and requires the track to be used.
However, our facilities are never available to us or rarely available to us.
Not to mention a couple days ago, I took my team out on a run on an outer perimeter of the campus, including KIPP.
When I ran by, we were looked down upon and we were given, we were kind of made fun of, my own team.
not to mention
Aside from sports, there's also a negative impact on the environment at Independence.
During class, I can hear people from KIPP very loud, disruptive, sometimes they're playing ball and they kick around our door, and it's very disruptive to the learning environment.
Furthermore, Independence encourages students to do extracurricular activities and opportunities never being the limiting factor.
We uphold the notion of fair education for everyone, but I ask, will KIPP
Good afternoon.
My name is Najmal Ali.
I'm a senior at Oak Grove High School, and at my school we already have summit charters on our campus who have already taken over 25 of 30 portables.
We share our gym, our equipment, our fields, and many other resources with them.
This sharing itself has limited my access to my own school's facilities.
My school's black student union wanted to hold an art show for Black History Month, and we weren't able to use our own school's small gym due to the charter's extensive reservations.
Having the charter on campus has also created more congestion and traffic around school, not only for students and teachers, but for our surrounding community.
This is a hazard on its own, but this traffic has increased torities for myself and many of my fellow classmates.
Every three torities equals an absence, and every eight unexcused absences resorts you to truant status.
Students are being disciplined unfairly as a result.
If we allow KIPP on our campus, it would not only further limit student access to resources, but continue to penalize students for conditions they have no control over.
Every decision made needs to be in the best interest of our community and KIPP school is not in the best interest of our community at all.
Hi I'm Gripal and I'm a junior at Independence High.
The charter schools have affected me and my family.
I play basketball and our practices are inconsistent because we have to share the gym time.
And we don't know when our practices are going to end.
My parents both go to work around 3 in the morning.
So I get home around 10.
And I barely have time to do homework, let alone eat dinner.
So some nights, I go home and don't eat dinner and go straight to work.
Thank you for your time.
Good afternoon.
My name is Tina.
and I'm a sophomore at Independence.
As a former student at KIPP San Jose Collegiate, I have experienced the environment of both public and charter school.
For the three months at KIPP, I felt limited to the opportunities of multiple extracurricular activities and learning academies.
Public school like Independence High School has opened new doors allowing me to interact with new people, teachers, and coaches.
The social impact of a public school is its diversity and ethnicities.
The fact that KIPP only accepts students who meet their academic requirements shows that KIPP has failed to uphold the notion of providing fair education for all.
Thank you.
Hello, my name is Valeria Cortez.
I go to Independence High School, which currently houses three of the 12 charter schools in our district.
Living in the East Side San Jose, my family once believed that charter schools provided a better education than public schools.
Every one of my siblings have attended a charter school at one point in their academic lives.
As a witness to their experience, the shift from a charter school to a public school was eye-opening.
KIPP's condescending attitude towards public schools, especially their host campus, Independence,
is unacceptable.
Their claims to have a better education is poured upon our parents, but in reality, education is what the students make of it.
Charter schools limit their education to college recommendations, but the benefit of teaching academies, AVE programs, AP, sheltered classes, and so much more, gives students the opportunity to learn at their own pace and find their passion.
Education is priority and the students and parents should not be obliged to follow the slogans circulated in the community by these schools.
Accepting KIPP's petition will only find us here again.
Thank you for listening to our experiences and observations.
Hi, my name is Jessica, a current student at Independence High School.
My mom and an alumni at Independence High School asked me if we still use the planetarium and if elementary kids still use it for a good learning experience of seeing and discovering stars.
My answer was no.
The charter schools have converted into a classroom, taking away the experience of the planetarium that my mom once experienced.
Knowing that I could have had that experience, it makes me sad that it was taken away from me, others, and younger generations.
Thank you.
Hi, my name is Shannon Fan.
I'm a sophomore at Independence High School.
And on behalf of the students at Independence, we believe that expanding the charter schools on our campus will increase unnecessary tensions.
This greatly affects student-athletes and our school events due to the charter school having equal access, having our practices and rehearsals late.
They have equal access which means that we have to rotate schedules.
This causes us to have irregular times for practices and rehearsals meaning our parents never know when to pick us up.
We end up staying at school way too long 15 hours or more.
By having practices and rehearsals late it affects us as student athletes causing us to come home tired and late.
Charter schools are extremely affecting us at Independence High School and I hope other schools will not have to face the same disturbance.
Oh thank you.
Good afternoon my name is Theresa Martin and I'm a senior at Independence High School.
I'm here today to share issues about the charter schools being at our campus.
When I was a freshman at Independence I was on the girls volleyball team and our practices were right after school so I had time to do my homework to eat dinner with my whole family and get enough sleep.
My brother is a current freshman at Independence, and he is on the volleyball team as well.
He has practices from 7.30 to 9.30 p.m., and he doesn't get home till 10 o'clock.
Because we now have to share our gym with charter schools, my brother isn't able to do the things I got to do.
He gets home super tired and eats dinner alone sometimes, and it's a hassle for me and my mom to wait at school till 10 o'clock because she's at home cooking or taking care of my other siblings.
I believe that we should be the priority first, independent students, since it is our gym and it is our school.
The issue with the charter schools affects not only my family but others as well and we shouldn't have to constantly deal with it.
Thank you for your time.
Good evening, my name is Nathan Balmonte.
I'm currently a senior at Independence High School.
As you know, we've recently been experiencing many issues concerning charter schools and comprehensive high schools.
As a public school student, I've witnessed many issues throughout my four years of high school.
They've stated that KIPP builds character, that they have different opportunities, and that they can progress in the next level of education.
While attending a public school, I believe you can acquire the same characteristics, we have programs like AVID, Teaching Academy, Academy of Finance, and many more.
That can build your work ethic and that can teach you to plan for the future.
This can also shape you into a better individual.
All I'm pushing for is that if charter schools would like to expand, at least consider the negatives that would result.
Consider the students that will be cut of their counselors, their programs, and their benefits, just for a charter school that offers the same type of attention and education.
to come and take time out of our very own programs.
Thank you.
Hello, my name is Israel Alvarez.
I'm a student of Mount Pleasant High School.
During my elementary school, I was lured to attend my local charter middle school that marketed and prouded themselves towards the local elementary schools of being an elite middle school compared to the surrounding middle schools.
However, after my graduation, I decided on attending a public school instead.
I was disgusted in continuing charter schools because of the artificial environment the school developed within by recommending multiple students to move to another school because of the lack of good grades.
In addition to the three years of schooling, many of these recommendations were pushed on lower grade, lower performing students on the weeks towards important state testing.
Miraculously, on test week, multiple of these students have moved to the nearby public school.
As a result of these recommendations to lower performing students and marketing towards younger, naive students of an elite education,
It creates a bubble of excellent students in charter schools and leaves the public system with demotivated students that degrades the public and schooling system.
Good afternoon.
I'm Anne Finney.
I'm the Athletic Director at Independence High School.
And we are good neighbors.
We've worked hard with the other charters on our campus.
We have three, but it just doesn't work.
We were told it was because of declining enrollment, but what people forget is the number of activities and sport activities does not decrease.
So we have two gyms, which is a luxury I get, but when we have
are five basketball teams plus 10 more from the charters.
There's just not enough time in the day for the kids to get a good school day practice and be able to have time at home.
We have to rotate our schedules.
We have our basketball team coming in at six a.m.
And going to class at 7 20.
We have kids starting at 7 20 and having to wait until 7 30 to start their practices.
It's not a good picture for anybody.
The same thing happens with soccer.
We have three fields, but we have
16 teams, counting the charter schools, needing that time on the field space.
If somebody has to gain, everybody has to compromise.
What I'm saying is it's just not good for kids on either side.
Thank you.
Hi, I'm Serena Bugunis, and I'm a senior at Independence High School.
I'm a student athlete, so I remember freshman year when Kip and other people had to use our gym.
Our practice started at 7 and ended kind of at 9.30, and I didn't have a ride home, so I had to walk.
My house is about a two-hour walk from the school.
also Kip does have different breaks and lunches as us so again I'm a student athlete and a student comes first an athlete and during their luncheon break we hear them playing the soccer ball kicking it on the door and it's very disruptive and you know
Sorry, it's very disruptive and it's very hard to concentrate.
Hearing the loud bang and no teachers or no administration will tell them to stop or anything.
Thank you.
Hi, my name is Manuel Dominguez and I'm a three-sport athlete at Independence High School.
During the football season, we needed to use our small gym because of the poor air quality, but KIPP was using it so we had to wait for about an hour until they finished up.
That only didn't waste practice time, but it wasted time that I could have been doing my homework or studying for a test.
Another time I was affected by KIB was during the soccer season.
Because we share a field, we had many practices super late, around 7 or 7.30, and that went to about 9.30.
One time we've also went to practice for less than 30 minutes and got kicked off because of them.
I'm now in baseball and they wanna expand KIPP all the way to our field, but why should we allow that when we've already gave them our other field?
I keep my grades up all year long to be in sports and having practices pushed back, canceled, and our field getting taken over is really disappointing to me.
Thank you for your time.
Good afternoon my name is Lisa Baker and I work at Independence High School also.
We share our site with three charter schools and one of them being KIPP and my position at the high school is called student advisor.
Recently my position was put forth on the layoff list because of the upcoming negative fiscal impact on our district.
I help supervise our 100-acre campus.
I'm also a liaison and work with our neediest students.
They deal with issues such as depression, anxiety, alcohol and drug abuse, and social emotional issues.
I work with their families as well as I connect them with our district and community services.
Some of these programs are counseling with social workers, psychologists.
We work with probation, prevention, and the gang task force.
If my, if we allow another charter school and it really impacts our district my position will probably be eliminated which really will negatively impact our most neediest students.
Thank you for your time.
Ladies and gentlemen, I'm Bill Simmons.
I'm a sixth grade English and history teacher in the San Juan Unified School District.
And I'm here in opposition to you approving another charter.
You approved a charter, Pacific Paramount Collegiate Charter, in our district.
And our district denied the charter because they were not financially solvent.
The County Board of Education denied the charter, but this board approved the charter.
That charter closed on February the 8th of this year.
Our district was required to pick up the pieces of the approval by this board.
This board should be listening to the local school boards, the local elected officials, and looking at, now we're looking at a district that you're gonna put into financial insolvency because you're gonna approve another charter.
That is not what you should be doing.
Thank you.
Eric Premack, Charter Schools Development Center.
In the interest of brevity, everything that I said about the prior one I'll say in here.
There is something though, it's just very distressing to see adults who are supposed to be modeling behavior for children encouraging some of the types of comments that we're hearing today.
It's very disturbing to see adults in the audience here encouraging children.
to engage in some of the type of behavior that we're seeing here today and the types of comments that speak of charter kids as being lesser than, deserving fewer facilities, not willing to share the limited facilities that the public has available.
You really have to question whether these people have a place in a public education system and whether it's appropriate for them to be in those kinds of positions.
It's really disturbing.
Thank you.
Hi, Ramel Antoine with the California Charter Schools Association.
I want to say that CCSA works with each of the charter members as they work as they want to start new schools and communities to provide quality service.
KIPP is one of those schools that has worked with us throughout the entire process to meet all the elements of the charter law and to ensure that they can gain approval
at any level they go up to as long as the bodies are considering the law as it stands.
So with KIPP, we support them.
We want to make sure that this board understands that their petition is sound and that they are fiscally solvent and are ready to serve the communities as they have a deep track record of providing great service to communities.
Thank you.
Dear members of the board and staff, I'm Ana Maria Aristizabal, Director of Growth at KEP.
When the Eastside Unified High School District denied our petition, we were dismayed to see that the district discarded years of collaboration and months of working together towards the opening of our high school in Eastside.
While we were working on the charter petition with the district, we were negotiating a long-term facility to solve many of the issues that students here have complained about.
Unfortunately though, the district made a long-term deal conditional to not opening our second high school and capping our growth.
We want to move forward as partners of the district and remain committed to make it happen.
Please approve our petition.
I'm Kevin Murphy, parent and teacher on the east side.
Charter schools claim to be public schools.
They claim amazing feats, perhaps they play by different rules than true public schools.
Perhaps KIPP is not truly a public school.
Public schools would be supported predominantly by public funds, would you agree?
A comprehensive annual financial report of KIPP area schools revealed that during 2015 and 2016 charitable contributions to their budget elipsed public funding.
How is that a public school?
In 2016 charitable contributions of $23 million comprised 36.53% of all revenues received by the network elipsing state aid.
In 2015 contributions of $22 million elipsed the $17.2 million of state aid.
Eastside Union High School District budget relies on over 80% of its funding from the state.
Eastside Union High School District has public schools.
KIPP is not but in name only.
State Board of Education should support true public school students deny the KIPP petition honor the local public's decision.
So we've heard talk today about how the law has to be followed.
My name is Ona Keller.
I'm with the California Teachers Association.
So we've talked today about how the charter school act has to be followed.
You know that the things that these students and parents are bringing up is really a question of policy and it's not a question for you.
But I think you need to really see what your decisions are doing on the local level and the impact that you are having on all of our public schools.
But if you don't care about that, if you don't care about the problems of co-location, if you don't care about the financial distress that you're putting these school districts under, then I'll give you some legal reasons to go ahead and deny this school.
I'm going to pass this out.
There's a number of reasons you could deny this school.
You could deny it based on the fact that they don't serve EL and SPED students in the same proportion and that they're going to dramatically impact and increase the already wide gap between the types of students that are served in Eastside and in the existing KIPP schools.
Or how about the fact that their governance is bereft of parental involvement.
They are going to meet one time this year in San Jose during the school day.
How is that allowing for parental involvement?
How is that allowing for teacher involvement?
It's an undemocratic system.
Thank you.
Okay, that concludes the public hearing and I'm going to ask our legal counsel Judy Sias on this to make some comments on the fiscal impact of argument that's been made by the opponents.
Judy Sias, legal counsel for the board.
I think would you like me to go over the reasons for denial again President Kirst and statute?
Well, not all of them.
I just want to go over the impact on the district, declining enrollment.
Yes, as the superintendent stated earlier today, Eastside superintendent stated, the fiscal impact on the district is not a reason to deny a petition.
You look at the petition and you analyze the petition based on the factors in law for the petition.
Declining enrollment of the district, number of charters that already exist in the district, those are not reasons for denial of a charter petition.
Okay, thank you.
Wanted to get that on the record.
Board member Rucker.
Well, yeah, let me start with the charter liaison.
Sorry.
Yeah.
First of all, I would like to thank very sincerely the superintendent of Eastside Unified that your explanation of the situation in your district was not only clear, but it was I think it was honest and candid.
I really
I'm sympathetic with the notion that the tipping point may have arrived and how that feels.
And at the same time, while all this is going on, you have been working diligently to support not charters, but all kids, I think is probably your the best way of saying it in in your community, in your district.
And so
I have a great deal of respect for the work that you've been doing.
Okay, Board Member Rucker, you're next.
Well, first of all, I want to thank everyone who took the time and made the effort to come to today's meeting.
And I have to say in the time that I have served on the board and in the time I've been monitoring the board before I came to serve as a member, this was a very unique hearing.
You tend to expect, and I have expected that there would always be a great deal of passion on both sides of the conversation, both in support of a charter petition as well as in opposition to a charter petition, and districts have always argued about the fiscal impact or the concern about facilities.
However, I'm confused about some information that just can't be correct.
I heard, I think, and I read, I think, that the district had made a recommendation for approval, that the county had made a recommendation for approval, and for some reason it was denied so that they could appeal it to the board.
I'm just, I got confused about that, and I was, and so if I've misstated that, I'm hoping I misstated that, because it just can't be accurate that somebody asked for the appeal, asked for the petition to be denied,
so they could appeal it to the board knowing that they would be approved.
So I got confused on, I'm not done.
So I got confused on that.
The second thing I'm confused on is I'm accustomed to hearing parents and students showing up in large numbers in support of choice and advocating for how the schools they are currently in have failed them and talking about how this creates a real option and a real promise for them that they do not currently have.
This is the first time I've heard something exactly the opposite.
Instead, I'm hearing large numbers of students saying that the charters create more problems than they solve, and while there's advocacy for choice, this is a choice they do not want.
The other thing I'm hearing is that for all of the other schools that exist, there has been a very strong and very positive relationship between the district and the charter, and that the reality is the charters currently are under enrolled from what their enrollment numbers are.
but we're going to add another charter.
So while choice is very clear and very dynamic and very diverse in this district, there is some reason why the community at large seems to be rejecting this choice.
So I'm confused because this is the first time I've ever seen a charter petition that contains all of these factors passionately supporting the idea of choice, the idea of access, the idea of balance,
and a rich, high-quality curriculum, but it's in support of the existing school.
The other issue that was brought up here was the concern about the co-location.
And while the adults are having their conversation about money and fiscal constraints and declining enrollment, the students are talking about the decline in the quality of their educational experience.
And we need to hear that, even if while we have made material revisions in charters, we have approved charters because we have stated that the district has not met their obligation to support those students.
These students are saying the approval of this charter is not meeting the district's obligation to support them as well.
So we have a clear conflict about the interest of students as a key stakeholder here, the interest of the district, and the interest of the charter.
And the other thing that confused me is this is the first time I've actually heard Eric Premack give this board legal advice about how to interpret the law.
This is the first time in a charter hearing I've actually heard anybody say, we have to follow exactly what the law says.
So I'm just very, this is a unique hearing, and I'm actually happy.
My grandparents, they are long gone, but they have said, if you live long enough, you'll see everything that can happen.
Yeah, who's next?
Felice Ortiz-Lacombe.
Yes, and I believe the county was going to come forward.
I also was a little confused.
I understand that initially the recommendation from the school at the school level at the local school board was to approve and for no particular reason the board decided not to and then the second motion was not to approve but there was no real valid reason given.
However, when it came to you, you also moved it forward with approval and the charter school petition
that have been denied, and I want to know why.
Why they rather you deny it so they could appeal to us.
Because I think that's problematic if people feel like, just deny me so I could go to them.
That's also something telling.
So I want to know what the reasoning was.
And I know that you'll probably provide it, but I also want to hear from the charter school.
Yes.
Yeah, the charter school, when we went over, our team had reviewed it and could find no findings.
We did talk about an MOU and some of the conditions in the MOU, and the charter school, KIPP, did not like some of the areas that we had identified we were going to negotiate, and they wanted us to come to a conclusion by the 28th of November so they could meet the timelines here.
We had to the 31st of January.
And so they said if that could not be extended, they would like to come to the state.
And so because they would not agree to the conditions in which we established, they requested to come to.
Yes, you want to.
Michelle Johnson for Santa Clara County Office of Education.
When we brought our MOU to KIPP, we found they had 15 different areas that they wanted to go through the negotiation process.
The originally KIPP Foundation was part of their petition saying that they are a sole statutory member.
When we brought that we brought the MOU saying we want to make sure that all parties are part of this MOU because and they wanted to have KIPP Foundation removed.
There was issues with regards to oversight.
We require that because we authorized 23 different charter schools we
require that we receive monthly reports from a financial standpoint so that we can monitor the fiscal.
They didn't appreciate, they didn't agree with our monitoring pieces.
There was issues with regards to the governance section.
There was issues with regards to 1090, issues with regards to the conflict of interest, issues with regards to admission priorities, year-end closure and reporting requirements, audit language and identification issues.
notification with regards to pending litigation, closure procedures with regards to their schools, term and renewal requirements, information with regards to additional sites, and revocation language.
So there were multiple issues that were raised for us to negotiate through the MOU process.
Can we hear from the charters and then from CDE?
I would also like to hear how we resolve that.
Let's hear from CDE first.
That MOU that's being discussed would have been between the county and the charter school.
So that wouldn't have been something that we would have been engaged in.
If the school is approved, we then have our own MOU that would be between the state board and the charter school.
So we wouldn't be engaged in that MOU.
Go ahead.
There's no standard MOU, is that correct?
I mean for the CDE you have a basic MOU that you are consistent with with charters that you're in oversight of, correct?
Correct.
But there is no statewide standard for an MOU for a charter school.
Not that I know of, no.
And as a result, when a district comes into a situation of negotiating, we have no idea exactly how extensive that MOU was, how onerous it was to the charter school, or how lenient it was.
We have no idea.
Yeah, MOU is Memorandum of Understanding for students out there.
I know that there were the Prop 39 facilities.
That's why we had to hear this today.
Was that mixed up in these timelines at all as your understanding?
The need to qualify for those on time?
that was there was a request for them to be heard today but the prop 39 piece is not something that we evaluated on behalf of the state board because that would then be negotiated between the Charter School and the school district.
But there's a prop service yeah maybe you can answer that one too.
Yeah the Charter School both KIPP schools believe that they needed to either get an approval today or they would not meet the deadline for the proper deadline I don't
Party?
The local.
The local deadline.
No, whether that's true or not, I don't know.
However, that's a regulatory deadline under Prop 39, that's a regulatory deadline.
State deadline, not a local deadline.
Okay, state deadline.
But I go back to the issue about whether the charter school said, look, just deny us and we'll go to the state board.
There can be logical reasons for that in terms of timeline.
Pardon me?
I can't hear you.
I don't know that they said that, but what I do know is that the district has indicated that the charter school did not want their original deadline for the MOU negotiations in January.
They wanted it by the end of November, and when they couldn't reach that agreement of making the deadline sooner,
the district has indicated that the charter school said we will just go to the state board.
And one does have to realize that starting up a new school is a lengthy process and being approved in July is a difficult thing.
Ortiz Lacone asked for the KIPP people to comment so I'd like to call them next.
We very, very, very much wanted to be approved at the local level and we were deeply disappointed that we were not able to be approved at the local level.
When we went to the county and my colleague was part of those conversations,
It's my understanding that the county said we are changing our practice and charters will no longer have an opportunity to be in dialogue and discussion and negotiate an MOU.
It will be part of the resolution and must be accepted wholesale, that that was a new practice and we wanted to have the opportunity to discuss some of these provisions.
We understand that the county had struggled with other charters that were postponing the signature of the MOU for like months and even years.
And of course, that's a situation that nobody wants to be in.
So I understand they were trying to anticipate some of those discussions, so they wanted to bring it forward.
However, I must notice that I only received the MOU because I asked for it one week before the vote, and we only got to see it three business days before the vote.
So we came to that discussion very open and very transparent because the relationship with SCOI had been tremendous and had been so open and fluid that we were actually hopeful that we were going to be able to negotiate at that very table.
Unfortunately, we were told that we should not engage lawyers, that we were going to deal with that afterwards.
And only after we expressed our concerns and everything that we could not accept, unfortunately, they decided to put together a resolution by which we will be imposed
all of the clauses that were included in there.
So we were left with no options but to try to make a case the night of the appeals at the SCOE board meeting, and with the impression that we were not going to be able to reach a resolution that very night because our lawyers were not in agreement with their lawyers.
It was clear that there was not going to be a path forward for us and certainly we needed to secure a Prop 39 facility for our school because we knew that there was not going to be another way for our school.
So we needed to go for the timelines that would allow us to do that.
So we proposed the county, why don't we come together and we reach an agreement on that MOU before the state deadline comes.
And we were going to put hours and hours and hours into reaching an agreement, and they said that they could not agree to that, to a November 28th deadline.
From November 1st to November 28th, they couldn't agree to.
And that was the deadline so that we could submit our package by December 1st to this board.
Actually, there was a motion from one of the members of the board at SCOE, if I remember well, Dr. DeSalvo, who actually passed the motion.
We didn't ask them to deny.
We say, if we cannot agree to the terms that you are proposing, we would prefer to be denied.
But we asked them to approve our charter petition.
Well, because we were not going to be able to accept the terms under which they were going to impose us.
Yeah, okay.
Trish Williams.
Yes, I want to ask you to clarify, and the attorney that's standing behind you, the government code 1090 issue, both as it applies or doesn't apply to charter schools, and whether or not they were asking the district, the county were asking it to also apply to the foundation.
and if that was one of the unacceptable conditions.
And as well, I think it might have, I've been here a long time, so forgive me for a lapse of time here, but I think maybe it was the previous agenda item that, or it may have been you, that where the operator talked about all of the things that they do do for transparency and public transparency besides 1090.
So if you could address that part of it, because I understand that was a big part of what we can't, we cannot agree to these terms.
You need to explain 1090 and yeah, what is it?
So, Government Code 1090 is a conflict of interest law that is specific to government agencies, whereas Kit Bay Area Schools is a non-profit public benefit organization.
And as I mentioned earlier, we do adhere to the Brown Act, the Public Records Act, and the Political Reform Act.
I also mentioned that we have a conflict of interest code that's approved by the Fair Political Practices Commission, the highest standard in the state, and our board and leadership annually submit the form 700, outlining economic disclosures in accordance with that policy.
Adherence to Government Code 1090 could unnecessarily disrupt the governance and operations of a charter school.
For example, charter schools cannot operate rent-free like school districts do.
Under Government Code 1090, if any of our board members offered to provide a no-interest real estate loan to Kitt Bay Area schools,
That board member could be subjected to criminal sanctions even if the board determined through its legally required conflict of interest policy that the loan was in the organization's best interest for its own benefit and fair and reasonable.
This could make securing and paying for facilities much more difficult and force charter schools to divert resources away from educating children.
Our board already complies with state and federal law regarding conflicts of interest.
We are locally authorized by eight districts, none of which require us to comply with 1090.
In 10 years of operation, we've never been suggested to be acting improperly in matters of financial or operational oversight.
We agree to comply with all applicable laws.
And can I ask them one more question since they're standing up there?
The facilities issues have just grown more complex and more difficult for both charters and traditional public schools.
I've been on the Eastside campus before a long time ago, and it was huge.
It's a very large campus, yes.
And where are, do you know where you would be expecting to get facilities, and do you know where the other charters are housed on the campus?
The Independence High School campus is where our current high school is housed.
The Prop 39 offer that we received, the preliminary offer for this proposed charter school, KIPP Navigate, is not on that campus.
It's not on the Independence High School campus?
Okay, so the concerns that we heard earlier about impacts on especially student access to fields and gyms and things like that, your location would not impact that at that school?
According to the district's preliminary offer, that is not a consideration for placement.
Okay.
Okay, who's next?
yeah well somebody will have to call on him Patricia so I didn't realize that part of
Again, I want to make sure that I want to be corrected because I am confused about the MOU piece and whether it was negotiated or imposed by the district because I heard the presentation from the district and they suggested that they had enumerated a list of items that they wanted to have a, I'm sorry, the county, I can't.
the county, that they wanted to have a conversation with you about.
And as it's been stated, you know, LEAs can develop and craft their own MOUs.
And what I just heard you say, based on what I just heard from my colleague who is the liaison to our ACCS who crafts our own MOU, you didn't like the MOU that the county was crafting,
under their authority, so you're coming to the State Board because the State Board has a different MOU, which may be related to the reason why the suggestion was made that it would be better for you to deny the charter so that you could get the appeal to the State Board.
But then, so, and again, if I'm wrong, please correct me, but then you also made a statement concerning Ed Code 1090,
and whether or not your charter school is required to be compliant with that.
And so I didn't know that that was part of the issue in the MOU.
So there was, in June 2017, the Legislative Council sent a legal opinion to Assemblymember Reginald Jones.
It was his request number 1713203.
And they can, the Legislative Council concluded, it is our opinion that a charter school
is subject to the conflict of interest provisions in the Political Reform Act of 1974 and Government Code Section 1090, and they did have a clear legal opinion that's been published.
But what I just heard you say is you are not.
So now who is correct?
You, the charter school, or the legislative council advising the state of California?
Yeah, let us get our legal counsel up here to talk about this.
I'm not going to have I know this issues before the legislature as well.
And the legislature has not acted.
But there's no it is not.
That's been published that says they are.
So that's why I want to know.
OK.
All right.
The legal counsel will answer the question.
Legislative Council, Judy Sias.
Yes, please speak into the microphone.
Judy Sias with the State Board of Education.
That is the Legislative Council opinion, but there is legislation and there are differing legal opinions out there as of now.
There's legislation proposed that would clarify whether or not 1090 applies.
That has not yet made it to the Governor.
But that's not my question.
My question is today, is the issue about what was contained in the MOU
from the county the reason why the charter petitioners asked the county to deny them so they could come to the state board and not have to deal with 1090.
I think that's the crux of my question.
The State Board of Education's MOU does not require compliance with 1090.
I heard them say, the charter, that there were several other reasons as well though.
But, okay, and so our MOU does not require that.
And one of the bones of contention between the charter, and again, because I didn't understand all of this as I read this information and heard the presentation, I'm
mortified that I'm making some statements that are not accurate, but I am confused.
So, the county office had an MOU that contained this requirement, which they have the legal authority to write, as I understand from Board Member Holliday.
The charter petitioner didn't seem to like that, and they, in shopping around MOUs and comparing, we seem to have one that is
I'm going to use the adjective easier because it doesn't contain some of the requirements that the county office wanted to include.
And so they asked for a denial so that they could come and be approved here.
They said there are many other reasons in addition to the 1090 that they had to negotiate.
The timeline I can clarify.
There are timelines on our website as to when we need to receive petitions in order to make a certain agenda.
December, January, that we needed to receive the petition in order for it to make the March agenda.
They wanted to, needed to make the March agenda, the charter school, in order to make the Prop 39 statutory deadline.
So that's why they're saying there wasn't time to negotiate.
Okay.
This is a real abuse of this process.
Regardless, the statute is real clear about what we can do, how we can handle an appeal, but this isn't a real abuse of this process.
And I'm very concerned about that.
Okay, Karen Valdez is next.
I do want to give Superintendent Funk a chance to talk, but I don't want to, I don't want to confine it to this 1090 issue.
So I will call on you.
Let's, all right.
Okay, so my question is just on the lottery system to get into the school as we're talking about this because that does impact the Prop 39 because it's going to be the students that reside within East Union High School District is how I understand it, correct?
So has the lottery already been done?
Are we assuming that the students from the middle school are matriculating to this new high school?
I don't know what the admission component is in terms of the lottery.
So if somebody could clarify that.
You ought to answer that.
CDE will answer that.
They don't know, okay.
Michelle Verrocki, founding school leader of KIPP Navigate.
Our lottery is scheduled to run on Friday, the 16th of the month, and we do not have application requirements, so we're open to all of our students.
The lottery, when it runs, it gives preference to students who are currently in our KIPP middle schools.
And so as I shared before, we have 300 students who are in the three KIPP middle schools that are in the Eastside Union High School District.
Sorry, it's not in the Eastside Union High School District.
They're separate middle school districts.
And so they would all come up into the Eastside Union High School District when they are entering high school.
And so we give preference to our KIPP middle school students and then also then open up to all of the other students within the district.
So to clarify, then, if you're matriculating all of your middle school into that high school, the high school enrollment you're starting with, could you repeat that number?
What are you starting with year one in your high school?
So we will be starting with 134.
And so it sounds to me that all of those students will be KIPP students.
Between KIPP San Jose Collegiate and KIPP Navigate, we aim to open to serve all of our students at our middle schools.
And that would cap the enrollment for any other lottery potential?
So because KIPP San Jose Collegiate is expanding to serve more students as well, we will have additional spots available for students within the district.
But most of our enrollment will be from our KIPP middle schools.
And then of the percentage of all of your middle schools, how many of those middle school students are residents of East Union High School District?
Of the 300 KIPP middle school students, we anticipate about 90% of them will matriculate to a KIPP high school.
And of those, the number that are within the district, I'm not too sure off the top of my head what that number is.
Good, thank you.
Yeah, it's board member Strauss.
Before you leave, I do have a question.
My understanding from some of the presentation, and then I want to talk to the superintendent, is that there are still vacant spaces in KIPP high school seats.
How many open seats are not filled right now that have already been granted local charter authorization that the KIPP students could matriculate to?
What vacant seats do you have now that are not full in high school?
So at KIPP San Jose Collegiate, where I've worked the last four years, we've had the entire duration of my career there, a long wait list.
And so we have full enrollment and we constantly have over 100 students on our wait list.
And so by opening the second school, we'll be able to ensure that all of our KIPP middle school students have an aligned middle school to high school path, as well as being able to continue to offer a college preparatory education for students who may not have come to our middle schools
that early on.
Okay, but so do you, then are you saying that you currently have filled all your seats that you currently have in high school?
Because that's not what we heard in some of the testimony.
No, the charter high school, the charter school seats are full of all the ones that you've been granted, is that correct?
Did I understand that correctly?
So all of our seats are full and we do have a long wait list.
I think one of the points that has been brought up is there are a few students within our high school that are outside the bounds of the district and that is because families have had to relocate but they continue to stay with our program until the students continue into college.
Okay, thank you.
I just want to mention, I don't know of any legal requirement that they have to be students within the district.
I wasn't asking.
I thought that was the whole idea.
I was just asking for vacancies.
I don't know what this is.
No, no, I thought there was, my question was, are your high schools fully enrolled, the KIPP high schools right now?
And what I heard you say is yes.
Yes.
And we have a long waiting list.
That's, that was my clarifying.
Yeah, that's my clarifying question.
Okay, so I, is that okay?
I do want to ask the Prop 39 question for the superintendent and ask you for Eastside Union High School District Superintendent if, just a question,
Just a compliment to you and your staff, of all the charters we've heard and charter appeals, I have not heard a more collaborative or cooperative district process.
in sharing space, in making five-year commitments to space, and local granting.
So in your effort with KIPP and all the charters that you authorized appears to this point to have been cooperative and collaborative in process, and things changed at this point, which was different.
So, and I just as a, before you comment, I just was thinking having run a large high school and managing fields, and I can't imagine 16 soccer teams, let alone all the number of basketball teams,
understanding how challenging it is for athletics, it seems like you're trying hard to maximize the use and cooperate within the intent of Prop 39.
I'm just interested in sort of how things switched and what's happened that's so different from past authorizations.
Yeah, you can answer that, but there are other questions you might want to respond to, so I don't want to just restrict you to that because there was a lot of issues brought up that you may want to respond to.
But you can start with that one and
Go where you want from the superintendent Eastside Union High School District.
Thank you for the compliment.
Appreciate it.
I believe we are the poster child district for collaboration with our charters and a reminder that it was a 45 year lease to have Kip build their new high school on our district office property that they backed out of.
But I wanted to clarify the point that was made earlier.
The reason why we have students and so many from Independence is because we have three charters on the Independence campus.
And they were speaking passionately about the impact of charters and sharing space on the Independence campus.
Now, full transparency, for KIPP East San Jose, we made our primary initial offer at Oak Grove High School.
What the CEO did not tell you is they denied that request and requested Independence High School.
So it would be a fourth charter on Independence High School.
So I just want people to be transparent when they speak to you, because that's not being very transparent.
Are there other questions that you like?
Because the 1090 is not an issue.
That was a county issue.
Okay, if that's, we want to have KIPP respond to that then.
Our initial request was to put the new KIPP high school on the Independence campus because ACE was moving somewhere else and there would be portables available and that would allow for more collaboration.
As those issues continued to rise, we saw that those portables would be removed and that was an unlikely spot.
And so when we got our initial proposal, we were placed on Oak Grove High School.
And if you look at the boundaries of the East San Jose High School District, it's a very large school district.
And Oak Grove is located in the very south part of that district.
Currently, we have of our 300 KIPP middle school students, only two students who live in the zip code of where Oak Grove High School is because the Eastside Union High School District encompasses many zip codes.
So we did indeed deny to be at Oak Grove High School because it's just too far from our families.
If you look at the traffic and the way our families would have to commute, they would have to spend so many hours in the car trying to get their students to school.
And many of the students are also enrolled in other middle and elementary schools depending on the size of our families and where their children are in the progression to their schools.
So we have requested to be placed on another one of the comprehensive high schools within the district, but we have requested to be at one of the six comprehensive high schools that are in between KIPP Heartwood, KIPP Heritage, and KIPP Prize.
And so there are other options that are
are not Independence High School.
We recognize that Independence High School does have three campuses, and there are other high schools that do not have a charter or that only have one at this time, and so our intent is to try to relieve the issues that have been brought up by Independence, because as members of the KIPP community, we feel those same struggles, and we also have a lot of students who are in sports and in clubs, and we wanna build comprehensive schools,
to ensure that all of our students have that opportunity and we recognize the hardships it causes when we need to share and when students have really long days as a result and so our goal is to try to find a compromise and try to make it work with the district and we've also gone to great lengths to try to find a long-term home for KIPP.
We really want to be able to provide our own facilities so we're not
like always located within the campuses of the current high schools and so when we think about the facility request that went to the district to be built on the district land the reason why that fell through at the last moment is because we need additional time to work out one of the different proposals around the VTA agreement because the students would have to cross over VTA land.
And we didn't have enough time with the timeline that the district gave us to be able to work out that final agreement, and thus the school fell through.
And so had they granted us two-week extension in which we had asked for, we would be able to build that school for Kip San Jose Collegiate, and we would be able to remove our students from the Independence campus.
And that is our ultimate goal, is to be able to not be encroaching on the independence campus or additional schools, but to be able to build our own comprehensive high school.
We're able to provide those funds, we're able to build the school, we're looking for land to be able to do that.
Given the approval, we would be able to continue those efforts in finding land to build schools.
But in the meantime, as we are growing, that is our first.
We need to rely on the Prop 39 process to have a facility in that time being.
Okay, Board Member Holliday.
So we don't know for a fact what all went on over the past long series of negotiations.
We don't know exactly what intent any one individual had during these weeks and months and I guess years involved in all this.
But what we do know is that we have two KIPP middle schools with families who care that their middle school students matriculate.
into a KIPP high school and that this is a viable alternative for them.
We know KIPP's reputation as a solid charter organization.
We just approved another KIPP school five hours ago, and I believe that this is a valid petition.
that all of this discussion about MOUs and all of that is really not in our purview to pull apart.
And instead, I think that this is a charter school that needs to be approved and I will so move.
Is there a second?
I'll second.
Moved and seconded.
Further board discussion?
Okay, all those in favor, raise your hands.
Okay.
Any abstentions?
One vote no.
One no vote.
All right.
Well, the board will recess till tomorrow.